COVE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
PROTECT THE LEGISLATORS PUBLIC
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
BECAUSE OF WITNESSES WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY- SO FAR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
ILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AND ASK
THAT EVERY TIME THAT YOU WISH
TO BE RECOGNIZED THE USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EVERY TIME YOU
RECOGNIZE A SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE
PLEASE SELECT A NEW BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON ME
WHEN YOU'RE DONE. AND ONCE YOU
RECOGNIZE TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON SCREEN
STATE YOUR NAME AND THAT YOU
ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE- TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE SUBMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOWING WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
PUBLIC COMMENT DEPARTMENT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. I WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN. AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. THAT NUMBER FOR
PURCHASE. IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE FIVE FOUR EIGHT
NINE AND THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO
THREE FIVE. FIVE THREE FOUR
THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE HEARING
ALL THE PANELS OF WITNESSES ON
THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT AND ONCE WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL THE WITNESSES
WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE TOPICS TODAY.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
YOU FIRST HEAR YOU DIRECTLY IN
THE MORNING- STICK FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE I'LL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING A HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE HEARING
PROCESSING CONDUCTOR HEARING
CENTERS CLOSE TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR TECH
FOR PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. AND WITH THAT WE WILL
BEGIN THE HEARINGS- I WANT TO
WELCOME OUR SPECIAL APPOINTEE
TO THE SPECIAL TWENTIES TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES- SENATORS MINUTE
NUMBER WELCOME I THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US AS WELL AS- SIX
SENATOR LAYERED IN OUR STEAM
FORMER SECRETARY HERE- WHO'S
WHO'S ON HAND WE'RE ALSO
INTENDING TO HAVE I THINK. A
FEW MORE MEMBERS JOIN US OUR
VICE CHAIR AND. POTENTIALLY
MAJORITY LEADER SHORTLY. I BUT
WE'LL GET STAR HERE. WITH A FEW
OPENING COMMENTS AND THEN WE'LL
WE'LL START DIGGING INTO
TESTIMONY- AS A RECAP ON
OCTOBER FIRST IN THE EVENING.
THERE WERE REPORTS- IN THE LATE
AFTERNOON EVENING OF AN OIL
SHEEN OFFSHORE HUNTINGTON
BEACH. IT WAS STARTING TO COME
IN THE NEXT MORNING AT NINE AM
A PIPELINE LEAK WAS OFFICIALLY
REPORTED BY THE OPERATOR OF
THAT PIPELINE AMPLIFY ENERGY.
THEN THE OIL SPILL RESPONSE
BEGAN IN EARNEST- ABLE FI HAS
CHIPPED CHOSEN NOT TO ACCEPT
THE INVITATION OF THE COMMITTEE
TO TESTIFY HERE TODAY AND WILL
BE ADDRESSING- SOME OF THOSE
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS FROM
AMPLIFY AS WE PROCEED HERE. BUT
THE PIPELINE THAT RUNS TO
AMPLIFY AND COPIED OFF SHORES
PLATFORM KELLY IS THE SOURCE OF
THE OIL PRODUCTION THAT RUNS
THROUGH THE PIPELINE IN
QUESTION. THAT SURE THAT THAT
PIPELINE IS A FEDERAL IN
FEDERAL JURISDICTION BUT IT
BRINGS THAT PRODUCED OIL
ONSHORE INTO STATE WATERS AND
EVENTUALLY ON STATE LANDS. I
WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN OUT THERE RESPONDING TO
THE SPILL- WE WENT DOWN TO THE
SIDE- OUT ONTO THE AIRCRAFT
WORKING TALKING WITH COAST
GUARD OSCAR L. E. S. CDFW
RESOURCES PARKS. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY VIGILANT AS WELL AS
THE ARMY OF VOLUNTEERS WHO
SHOWED UP TO HELP OUT AND ALL
THE BUSINESSES WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED- THE NEWS THIS MORNING
WAS THAT SBA LOANS ARE NOW
GOING TO BE OFFERED SOME OF
THOSE BUSINESSES BUT THEY HAVE
CERTAINLY NOT BEEN MADE WHOLE
FOR THE LOSSES THEY EVEN
TOURED. NOR IS OUR ENVIRONMENT-
AS A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIAN
THOUGH INTO. A SURFER AND
SOMEBODY LOVES THOSE WATERS
WITH ALL MY HEART I DO
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE- BUT WE
WILL DIG INTO WHAT WENT WELL
WHAT DIDN'T GO WELL WHAT WE CAN
DO TO IMPROVE OUR EFFORTS AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY HOW WHAT WE
CAN DO TO ADDRESS. THE LONGER
TERM LIABILITIES OF HAVING
ACTIVE OIL PRODUCTION OFF THE
SHORE OF CALIFORNIA ON A
SENSITIVE COASTLINE AMIDST
PLENTY OF SHIP TRAFFIC AND
OTHER USES AND TRY TO GET OUR
HEADS AROUND- HOW TO ACTUALLY
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE CLIMATE
AGENDA- THAT. MAKES THE
TRANSITION AND BEGINS TO END
THESE PRACTICES- TO THE COASTAL
ECONOMY IS ESTIMATED TENS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
AND A LOT OF THOSE COMPONENTS
ACTUALLY DEPEND ON A SHORELINE
THAT IS FREE FROM POLLUTION
INCIDENTS AND THIS OTHER KIND
OF INDUSTRIAL ACTIVITY THAT
LIMITS OUR- ABILITY TO UTILIZE
THE COAST AND ALL THE RESOURCES
IT OFFERS OFTEN THOSE NUMBERS
ARE QUANTIFIED. AND THE VALUE
OF. DRILLING MAY BE.
EXAGGERATED IN PROPORTION TO
THE THAT IT PROVIDES THE PUBLIC
BUT- WE'RE LOOKING HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE FOR WHAT THOSE
LIABILITIES ARE- AND WHAT A
FRAMEWORK COULD BE. NOT JUST TO
ADDRESS THOSE BUT HOW WE CAN
PREPARE AND RESPOND BETTER IN
THE FUTURE BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY THIS WILL
PROBABLY NOT BE. THE LAST TIME
WE'VE HEARD OF AN INCIDENT SUCH
AS THIS- AND TO BE CLEAR. THE
INDUSTRY AND IN THIS CASE
AMPLIFYING THE OTHER PARTIES
RESPONSIBLE MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. AND PAY TO MAKE
THE PUBLIC AND OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL. AND FOOD NOTION
OF COMPANIES OUT THERE GOING
BANKRUPT OR FINDING SOME OTHER
LEGAL MECHANISM TO EVADE
RESPONSIBILITY. BELIES THE
PUBLIC TRUST AND UNDERCUTS OUR
ENTIRE. REGULATORY FRAMEWORK-
SO WE'LL BE ADDRESSING SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES AS WE GO ON BUT
TODAY WILL FOCUS MOSTLY ON THE
RESPONSE EFFORT- AND SOME OF
THE DETAILS THERE WE REALIZE
THAT THERE'S STILL AN ACTIVE
ONGOING INVESTIGATION UNDER WAY
AND SO WE MAY NOT GET EVERY
ANSWER WE'RE LOOKING FOR HERE
TODAY BUT- I THINK THE MAIN
MESSAGE OUGHT TO BE THAT. IF T.
AS LONG AS THE- HEROES LONG AS
THE CLEANUP IS STILL GOING
WE'RE GOING TO BE DIGGING INTO
THAT. BUT EVEN WHEN IT'S
COMPLETE THE WORK IS NOT DONE-
SO I WANTED. TO PASS THE
MICHAEL OVER TO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO MAKE SOME
OPENING COMMENTS AND THEN WE'LL
HEAR FROM T. MINISTRATION OUR
FIRST PANEL- INTERMENT. THANK
YOU CHAIR STERN- I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING
SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY SEVEN
WHICH INCLUDES THE LOWER HALF
OF HUNTINGTON BEACH- THIS
NEWPORT BEACH LAGUNA BEACH I
BELIEVE MY DISTRICT HAS THE
FINEST BEACHES IN THE COUNTRY-
SO AMAZING BEAUTIFUL- PRESERVES
COASTAL ECOSYSTEMS THAT
PROTECT. MANY SPECIES INCLUDING
ENDANGERED SPECIES OF BIRDS AND
OTHER- FLORA AND FAUNA THAT-
ARE IMPORTANT- IN TWO HERE ON
OCTOBER SECOND THAT THIS WAS
ALL BEING ENDANGERED BY A
MASSIVE OIL SPILL I WAS WAS
DISCONCERTING TO SAY THE LEAST.
NOW I FIRST AND FOREMOST WANNA
TANK UNIFIED COMMAND THE U. S.
COAST GUARD OSCAR DEPARTMENT
AFICIONADOS AND I KNOW WE HAVE
SOME REPRESENTATIVES FROM SOME
OF THOSE AGENCIES TESTIFYING
TODAY OFFER THEY'RE QUICK AND
DECISIVE RESPONSE WHICH I THINK
REALLY PREVENTED THIS FROM
BEING MUCH WORSE THAN IT COULD
HAVE BEEN I ALSO WANT TO GIVE A
SHOUT OUT TO HUNTINGTON BEACH
AND ORANGE COUNTY- WHO ALSO
QUICKLY DEPLOYED A LOT OF
BLOOMS A LOT OF PERSONNEL. AND
I KNOW IT THAT PROTECTED US
SOME OF OUR ECOLOGICAL
PRESERVES- PLACES LIKE BOLSA
CHICA- THE WETLANDS THAT- COULD
HAVE REALLY BEEN SUFFERED FROM
MUCH MORE DEVASTATION THAN THEY
DID- THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THAT EVEN THOUGH WE ENDED UP
WITH A FAR SMALLER OIL SPILL
THAN ORIGINALLY ANTICIPATED
THAT WAS CONTAINED MUCH MORE
THAN THAN WE- I THINK EVEN OUR
BEST- BUT MOST OPTIMISTIC OUT
EXPECTATIONS WERE- WE STILL
CLOSED ON OUR BEACHES FOR
NEARLY TWO WEEKS WE'RE STILL
GOING TO CLEAN THIS UP FOR
WEEKS AND WEEKS. AT SOME POINT
WE HAVE TO ASK IS OFFSHORE
DRILLING WORTH IT- THE RISKS
THAT SEEM OMNIPRESENT THAT
JEOPARDIZE A COASTAL ECONOMY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS
WORTH APPROXIMATELY FORTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR BY SOME
ESTIMATES- A COASTAL- BECAUSE A
COASTLINE THAT NOT ONLY
GENERATES SO MUCH REVENUE FOR
US BUT IS PART OF WHO WE ARE AS
CALIFORNIANS. WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT CALIFORNIA M. PEOPLE FROM
AROUND WORLD THINK CAL THEY
THINK ABOUT. OUR BEACHES ARE CO-
WE ARE KNOWN FOR THAT. IT'S
PART OF WHO WE ARE WITH YOUR
SERVER FOR. MY KIDS GO BOOGIE
BOARDING EVERY OTHER WEEKEND OR
JUST WALKING ON THE COASTLINE
AND ENJOYING THE OUTDOORS. THIS
IS A PART OF WHO WE ARE AND THE
OIL THAT IS GENERATED- THAT IS
EXTRACTED EACH YEAR OFF OF
CALIFORNIA WATERS WHETHER IN
FEDERAL OR STATE WATERS.
ACCOUNTS FOR LESS THAN ZERO
POINT 3% OF OIL PRODUCTION
ANNUALLY. IN THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S NOT EVEN A DROP IN THE
BUCKET AND YET WE CONTINUALLY
FACE THIS THREAT OF OIL SPILLS.
AS THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS AGING.
AS IT JUST SEEMS INEVITABLE IN
AND AS THEY SAY WHERE THERE'S
DRILLING THERE'S GOING TO BE
SPILLING AND UNFORTUNATELY MY
DISTRICT FACED THAT- ADAGE
EARLIER THIS MONTH AND SO. I
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS HEARING TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED
THE TIMELINE AROUND WHAT
HAPPENED- BUT ALSO TO TRY TO
DRILL DOWN AND SEE WHAT CAN WE
DO O STOP THIS FROM HAPPENING.
AND I RENOUNCE THAT I BELONG SO
MY COLLEAGUES HERE WILL BE
INTRODUCING LEGISLATION WHEN WE
REOPEN IN JANUARY. TO END ALL
SPOT FOR DRILLING EXTRACTION
INCLUDING UNDER CURRENT LEASES
IN STATE WATERS. BUT WHAT ELSE
CAN WE DO BECAUSE SO MUCH OF
THIS IS OUT OF OUR CONTROL IN
FEDERAL WATERS. WHAT CAN WE DO
TO STOP THIS TERROR THAT WE
CONSTANTLY FACE FROM OIL
SPILLS. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PUTTING TOGETHER THE
STRANGERS. STERN I LOOK FOR THE
WITNESSES. THANK YOU CENTER.
MEMBERS AND OTHER OPENINGS ON.
SO NUMBER. THANK YOU SIR AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND OTHER ISSUES
THAT ARE IMPACTING CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENT- I'M GRATEFUL TO
YOU FOR INCLUDING US IN THIS
HEARING I REPRESENT THE OTHER
PART OF HUNTINGTON BEACH- SEAL
BEACH AND LONG BEACH AND I WILL
DO A COMPARISON AS TO WHICH
PART OF THE BEACH IS BETTER IN
ANY EVENT I I'M GRATEFUL FOR
BEING INCLUDED AND I'M ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR THE LEADERSHIP OF
SENATOR MEN MER KERR AND OTHER
LEADERS IN ORANGE COUNTY
ULTIMATELY WE'RE ACCOUNTABLE.
WE THE ELECTED LEADERS WHETHER
IT'S LOCAL OR STATE OR FEDERAL-
WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR INSURING
THAT THIS KIND OF EVENT IS
PREVENTED IN THE FUTURE AND
WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING
THAT GOD FORBID SOMETHING LIKE
THIS SHOULD HAPPEN IT IS
CONTAINED AND CLEANED UP AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE- I KNOW
SENATOR MEN WAS ON SITE FOR
MANY MANY DAYS EARLY AND OFTEN-
THE CAR WAS ON SITE. SHE
PROBABLY REMAINS ON SITE WE
WENT DOWN THERE TO BOTH AN
AERIAL TOUR AS WELL AS A
PHYSICAL TOUR GOT THE ACTUAL
OIL ON OUR HANDS BY THE WAY
IT'S NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO GET
OFF IN THIS DEGRADATION HAS AN
IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY HAS AN
IMPACT ON THE QUALITY OF LIFE
HAS AN IMPACT ON THE
LIVELIHOODS OF MANY MANY MANY
FOLKS SO I AM WELCOMING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE HOW WE
CAN CONTAIN AND CLEAN UP AND
HOW WE RESPOND TO THIS KIND OF
TRAGEDY IN THE FUTURE- CINNAMON
IS CORRECT. THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF FIRST RESPONDERS A NUMBER OF
ENTITIES THAT RESPONDED VERY
QUICKLY AND VERY POWERFULLY BUT
I THINK WE CAN DO BETTER I
THINK WE CAN DO BETTER AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT SO
THANK YOU AGAIN CHAIRMAN STERN
FOR GIVING US THIS OPPORTUNITY.
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT PROCESS.
THANK YOU SARAH BURKE CENTER
LATER THANK YOU AND- I WOULD
LIKE TO- AS THE PERSON THAT
REPRESENTS THE- BEACHES WITH
THE ELEPHANT SEALS INCENSE
SIMEON AND OCEANIA AND THE
MONTEREY PENINSULA AND THE
NORTH COAST OF SANTA CRUZ. I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR- BURKE
FOR DPD DEFUSING THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE FINEST BEACHES. IT
AND- THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
HEARING AND I REALLY THANK THE
COMMITTEE THE CHAIR. OF FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER. WHEN I
WAS RESOURCES SECRETARY WE HAVE
THE HORRIFIC SPILL THAT WAS IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY WITH
BROKEN PIPELINE BUT A LOT OF
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
THE RESPONSE THAT WILL BE
TESTIFYING AT THIS HEARING WERE
INVOLVED IN THAT RESPONSE. IN
OUR- IF YOU ARE JUST. ATTACH
MYSELF TO THE COMMENTS OF
SENATOR MEN ABOUT THE LONG TERM
ISSUES HERE AND WHAT WE HAVE TO
DO AND- I WOULD JUST REMIND.
OUR PEOPLE AS SOMEBODY THAT WAS
AN ACTIVIST ON THESE ISSUES IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES THAT
THEY'RE STILL TWENTY SIX
ORDINANCES. THAT WE WERE THE
IMPETUS FOR IN THOSE YEARS.
WITH CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT SAID ON SHORE
SUPPORT ACILITIES SONIC
CHANGES CAN'T BE APPROVED
WITHOUT A VOTE OF THE PEOPLE OF
ART OF THAT JURISDICTION. AND
IT WAS TO ACTUALLY MAKE SURE.
THAT THERE WAS SAFETY OR THOSE
KINDS OF ISSUES THAT ARE AT
ISSUE IN THIS COMMITTEE. AT
PLAY WHEN THAT HAPPENS AND SO.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSIONS AND THE PANELS AND
GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS
BECAUSE I THINK THAT. THAT WE
ARE GOING TO NEED TO TAKE SOME
KIND OF ACTION OR AT LEAST HAVE
AN INFLUENCE OR WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN GENERAL OUT OF WHAT'S
HAPPENED HERE SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING. THANK YOU A LAYER-
MR VICE CHAIR DID YOU WANNA.
THIS IS YOU KNOW A COUPLE
THINGS YOU KNOW I'M I'M AGAIN
I'M I WOULD ECHO MY-
COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS AND- THANK
YOU FOR PUTTING THIS TOGETHER
AND ALWAYS KIND OF. PUT
TOGETHER ON SHORT NOTICE AND
BUT I THINK IT'S THE TIMING IS
GOOD- YOU KNOW I'M ALSO IS A
STRONG CONSERVATIONISTS AND-
I'M DISAPPOINTED IN AND
HEARTBROKEN TO HEAR HOW MANY
DIFFERENT SPECIES INCLUDING
BIRDS AND FISH HAVE DIED
BECAUSE OF THIS OIL SPILL. IN
ADDITION AS A HAS BEEN
MENTIONED THE DENTRO IMPACTS ON
NATURE OF THE LOCAL ECONOMY.
HAS SUFFERED IMMENSELY AND SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
FIND OUR BECAUSE THIS BILL HOW
WE CAN. PREVENT FUTURE ONES.
AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION LOOKING INTO
THIS- BUT- PRELIMINARY
REPORTING LINKS THE CAUSE TO A
BOAT ANCHOR. WHICH IS OUT OF
THE OIL COMPANIES CONTROL SO
IT'S GOING TO BE I LIKE TO SEE
HOW THAT IS GONNA BE MITIGATED
IN THE FUTURE. AND WHAT
POLICIES- YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE STATE THAT'S
CAUSING THIS BACK UP. OF ALL
THESE CONTAINER SHIPS OFF THE
COAST THERE WE GO. BECAUSE YOU
KNOW POTENTIALLY CAUSES PROBLEM
IN THE FIRST PLACE SO. I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT WILL COME UP IN
TODAY'S HEARING BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT ON US. AS THIS
NATURISTS WAS CAN YOU LOOK INTO
THAT BECAUSE WHILE THOSE SHIPS
OR- OFFSHORE THEY'RE BURNING
OIL. BURNING DIESEL TO KEEP
THEIR LIGHTS ON KEEP THE MOTORS
RUNNING. AND YOU KNOW.
CALIFORNIA'S A LOT OF WORK IN
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS TRYING
TO LOWER THOSE EMISSIONS. FROM
THE SHIP'S WHEN THEY'RE IN PORT
SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
WHITE WHY IS THE PARTS BACKED
UP AND HELP CONTRIBUTE TO THIS.
AND WILL SURELY THE OIL COMPANY
HAS SOME RESPONSIBILITY IN THE
MATTER. I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US NOT TO PUSH ALL THE
BLAME ON THE INDUSTRY BEFORE
KNOWING ALL THE FACTS. AND WE
MUST NOT LET BIASES IMPEDE OUR
INVESTIGATION AND QUESTIONING
OF THE SITUATION. AND WHEN I
SAY WE I MEAN US AS A COMMITTEE
BUT ALSO AS THE PROFESSIONALS.
IN THIS IN THE STATE. OF IRAQ
OR SEASON THE FEDERAL BROKERS
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE
INVESTIGATIONS- I'M HOPEFUL
THAT. YOU KNOW WE WOULD. HELP
THEM NOT GET IN THEIR WAY SO
THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE THAT
MUCH FOR THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SO WITHOUT FURTHER ADO WE WILL
PROCEED TO OUR FIRST PANEL- WE
COULD. CALL UP OUR FIRST
WITNESSES AS MENTIONED AT THE
OUTSET- MR WILSHIRE WITH
AMPLIFIED WAS- WAS INVITED TO
TESTIFY- THEY HAVE DECLINED
THAT INVITATION AND- DID SEND A
LETTER WHICH WE CAN DISCUSS IN
A MINUTE BUT- AT THE OUTSET
WE'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM A
DIRECTOR CHUCK BONHAM WHOSE-
HEAD OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE AS WELL AS TOM
CULLEN WHO'S THE ADMINISTRATOR
OF THE HOSPITAL FOR. THE OFFICE
OF SPILL PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE MR COHEN IS THE STATE
ON SCENE COORDINATOR AND
REPRESENTS THE STATE WITHIN THE
UNIFIED COMMAND STRUCTURE- SO
WELCOME TODAY DIRECTOR BONHAM
AND ADMINISTRATOR COLIN. THANK
YOU CHAIR I'LL GO FIRST AND
THEN TURNED OVER TO THE
ADMINISTRATOR AND ALSO THANK
YOU TO EACH OF THE- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LET ME JUST CONFIRM YOU
CAN HEAR AND SEE ME OKAY. HE
ATE YOU'RE COMING THROUGH WELL
DIRECTOR. I THANK YOU. SO IT'S
TRUE MY NAME IS CHUCK BONHAM
AND I'M STILL THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE WHICH I THINK
IS THE GREATEST JOB IN THE
WORLD. LET ME START BY JUST
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR
GIVING THE RESPONSE THE SPACE
TO FOCUS ON A MONTH AGO. AND
WORK WITH US TO SCHEDULE AN
APPROPRIATE TIME TO MEET YOUR
NEEDS FOR HEARING. WHILE NOT
MATERIALLY INTERFERING WITH THE
RESPONSE THAT WAS UNDERWAY AT
THE HEIGHT OF. THE BEGINNING OF
THIS EVENT. AND THE NEXT THING
I REALLY WANT SAYS LOOK. MAKE
NO MISTAKE. SUPER DIRECT BOTTOM
LINE THERE IS NO GOOD WILL
STILL. THE BEST SPILL IS ZERO
NO STILL I HEARD THEY CAUSE
DAMAGE. THEY AFFECT NATURE.
AFFECT OUR BUSINESSES THEY HURT
US INDIVIDUALLY YOU HEARD THE
CHAIR MENTIONED HIS EXPERIENCE
YOU HEARD SENATO MEN AND
NUMBER MENTIONED THERE SENATOR
LAYERED THEY HEARD ME
INDIVIDUALLY THEY HURT EACH
CALIFORNIAN. IF THERE'S ONE
THING CLEAR BECAUSE OF THIS
BILL. WE LOVE OUR BEACHES WE
LOVE OUR OCEANS NO MATTER OUR
BACKGROUND. ARTISANSHIP OUR
POLITICAL AFFILIATION. BUT IN
THESE. SAD UNFORTUNATE MOMENTS
THE TASK FOR OUR DEPARTMENT AND
OUR OFFICE IS STILL PREVENTION
AND RESPONSE IS TO DEAL WITH IT
DEAL WITH IT IN THE MOMENT. SO
I'D LIKE MR KHANNA MEANT TO
GIVE YOU A BETTER GRANULAR
DESCRIPTION OF THE DETAILS WHAT
I'D LIKE TO DO IS PULL BACK TO
A HIGHER LEVEL AND SET THE
FRAME. BUT I CAN'T DO THAT
WITHOUT IT KNOWLEDGE SHARING
THE MARE. UP FROM HUNTINGTON
BEACH SHOW YOU'LL HEAR FROM IN
A MINUTE. THE CHAIR SUPERVISOR
FLETCHER. EVERY SINGLE ELECTED
OFFICIALS SENATOR MAN CENTER-
BERG. THIS WAS AN ALL HANDS ON
DECK ALL OF GOVERNMENT ALL
COMMUNITY EFFORT. EACH OF US I
THINK WORKED HARD TO FIND ROLES
AND LEVERAGE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TOGETHER. THE SAME
RUNS TRUE FOR OUR CITIZENS WE
HAD TEN THOUSAND CITIZENS IN
CALIFORNIA. SIGN UP TO
VOLUNTEER. THE FOLKS IN MODOC
THAT SIGNED UP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I DIDN'T BELIEVE THAT
WOULD BE A CHANCE FOR YOU TO
HELP OUT ON THE GROUND. I THINK
OUR CONSERVATION GROUPS YOU
HEAR FROM SURFRIDER IN A MOMENT.
BUT LET'S GO BACK ABOUT A MONTH.
AND WHETHER IT'S LATE FRIDAY
OCTOBER FIRST TOWARDS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT SATURDAY
OCTOBER SECOND. IN THIS SUNDAY
ON OCTOBER THIRD. WE HAD A
SIGNIFICANT EVENT. A VERY
SERIOUS RISKS TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR ECONOMY.
WHAT WE NOW KNOW IS ABOUT FOUR
AND A HALF MILES OFF SHORE SO
IN FEDERAL WATERS. THERE IS A
PIPELINE THAT RUNS FROM ONE
PLATFORM WHICH IS A COLLECTION
OF THREE PLATFORMS OPERATED BY
A COMPANY CALLED BETA OFFSHORE
OWNED BY A COMPANY CALLED
AMPLIFY ENERGY. THAT LAST
PLATFORM ELLIE. AS A PIPELINE
WHICH DELIVERS THE PRODUCT.
SEVENTEEN POINT SEVEN MILES
INLAND.WHERE THE PIPE COMES ON
SHORE JUST BELOW THE QUEEN MARY
MORE LESS. TO LAND BASED
INFRASTRUCTURE. I HAD A RUPTURE
IN IT AND WE NOW KNOW. BASED ON
VISUAL AND DIVER AND OTHER
EVIDENTIARY EFFORTS BUT ABOUT
FOUR THOUSAND FEET OF THAT
PIPELINE WAS MOVED ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIVE FEET ALSO
CENTER. AND IN THAT STRETCH IS
ABOUT A THIRTEEN INCH
HORIZONTAL ALMOST LIKE A
HAIRLINE FRACTURE IF YOU COULD
IMAGINE A BROWN BREAK. IN A
PIPE WHICH IS I THINK ABOUT
THIRTEEN INCHES IN DIAMETER
CONCRETE ON THE OUTSIDE METAL
ON THE INSIDE. THAT'S THE
LIKELY SOURCE OF THE LEAK. FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING MOMENTS ALL
OF US INVOLVED ASSUMED A WORST
CASE. AT THAT MOMENT IN TIME WE
HAD A PLANNING NUMBER OF A
SPILL OF ABOUT. THREE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
BARRELS WHICH IS ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY ONE THOUSAND GALLONS
ROUNDING AS THE MAXIMUM WORST
CASE. WE SEARCHED TO BE
PREPARED FOR BEYOND THAT
MAXIMUM WORST CASE. AT DAWN
SUNDAY MORNING OCTOBER THIRD
ALL SENIOR DIRECTORS OF THE NEW
SOME ADMINISTRATION WERE ON ONE
PLANE TOGETHER. MY SELF THE
DIRECTOR OF- YES MR DEALER DO
CHEAT THE DIRECTOR OF STATE
PARKS DIRECTOR CAN TERO ID
SECULAR DIRECTOR STATE PLANS
MISTER CASEY WHO YOU'LL HEAR
FROM LATER AND ADMINISTRATOR
CALLING ALONG WITH. THE UNITED
STATES COAST GUARD ADMIRAL IN
CHARGE OF THIS THEATER OF
OPERATIONS. WHAT I DO FROM
THERE THAT MORNING TERRIFIED.
IT CONFIRMED WE WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A SIGNIFICANT EVENT.
WE SHOULD ASSUME WORST CASE.
AND WE SHOULD DEAL WITH IT
APPROPRIATELY BASED ON THAT.
LEVEL OF EFFORT OVER THE COURSE
OF THIS FIRST WEEK. WE SEARCHED
AN INCREDIBLE FORCE WE REACHED
ACROSS THE NATION. AND BY THE
END OF THAT FIRST WEEK OF
OCTOBER NIGHT WE HAD WELL OVER
A THOUSAND PEOPLE DEPLOYED. BY
WAY OF REFERENCE SENATOR
LAYERED MENTIONED THE REFUGIO
SPILL IN SANTA BARBARA. EVERY
WILL STILL IS DIFFERENT THE
FACTS REALLY DO MATTER. REFUGIO
IS. CLOSE IN TIME BUT A DECADE
AGO. HAPPEN WITH THE PIPELINE
HAPPENED IN THE COUNTY HAPPENED
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT'S
STILL WAS ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND GALLONS
WHEN ALL WAS SAID AND DONE AT
THE PEAK OF OUR RESPONSE IN THE
FUTURE WE HAD ABOUT A THOUSAND.
PEOPLE DEPLOYED IN OUR FOR
WORSE. PEAK SO FAR FOR THIS
RESPONSE IS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S ABOUT EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE DEPLOYED WITHIN
THE FIRST WEEK WE GOT CLOSE TO
FIFTEEN HUNDRED AS A FORCE
SEARCH. THE MIDDLE OF THAT
FIRST WEEK GOVERNOR NEWSOM CAME
AND SAT WITH MANY OF YOU.
INCLUDING SENATOR MAN AND-
BURKE. RELATED THE MAYOR ARE
MEMBERS OF THE DELEGATION IN
CONGRESS. ON THE HOUSE SIDE
WE'VE SINCE SEEN SENATOR P- THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S VISIT. WE
FILLED THE VOID PRETTY QUICKLY.
AND I'M SO THANKFUL FOR THE
MAYOR AND OTHERS WHO WERE ABLE
TO DEPLOY THEIR OWN ASSETS IN
THOSE FIRST TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
OVER THE FIRST WEEK WE PUT
PEOPLE ON THE BEACH WHAT'S ON
THE GROUND DEALING WITH THIS WE
HAD A VAST ARRAY OF VESSELS ON
THE WATER. WE PRETTY
IMMEDIATELY BROUGHT THE
COUNTIES OF ORANGE AND SAN
DIEGO INTO THE UNIFIED COMMAND.
TO HELP MAKE DECISIONS
INCLUDING. KNOWING WE NEEDED
THEIR EXPERTISE ON PUBLIC
HEALTH. BOTH AIR QUALITY AND
WATER QUALITY. WITHIN THAT
FIRST WEEK I CALLED THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SURFRIDER
AND WE EVENTUALLY CREATED. I
THINK THE FIRST TIME WE'VE EVER
DONE IT. UNOFFICIAL LIAISON
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSERVATION COMMUNITY TO
INCREASE OUR COMMUNICATIONS IN
THAT SPACE. WE IMPLEMENTED A
FISHERIES CLOSURE. THOSE THAT
ARE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REALIZE THE VALUE OF DUNGENESS
CRAB ON THE DINNER PLATE OVER
THE HOLIDAYS. THE CULTURAL AND
ECONOMIC ANALOG IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THIS TIME OF YEAR
IS ACTUALLY LOBSTERS ON THE
PLATE. PEOPLE LOVE THE FISH
FORM TO CLOSE THAT DOWN BECAUSE
THE FISHERS CLOSURE. AS TIME
PASSED. AND WE GOT INTO THE
SECOND WEEK OF THE EVENT. WE
ALL COLLECTIVELY TOOK FURTHER
STEPS WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
ADAPTING AND ITERATING ON A
TWENTY FOUR TO FORTY EIGHT HOUR
CYCLE. STILL BEGAN TO SHIFT IN
NATURE FROM A LESS OF A PRODUCT
ASPECT WE COULD PICK UP ON THE
WATER TO DEALING WITH TAR BALLS
ON OUR BEACHES. WE HAD AN
INCREDIBLY INTENSE OUTRAGE
CYCLE FOR A WHILE IT WAS DAILY
THEN EVERY OTHER DAY WORK EACH
MORNING. WE WOULD GO THROUGH A
CALL BETWEEN THOSE AGENCIES IN
THE COMMAND. AND LITERALLY
EVERY CITY. FROM LONG BEACH TO
IMPERIAL BEACH REPORTING TO THE
COMMANDWHERE TAR BALLS WERE
SHOWING UP SO THAT WE CAN
ITERATE AND DEPLOY FORCES TO
DEAL WITH IT. WE CREATED A
SEPARATE INVESTIGATORY EFFORT
TO FREE THE RESPONSE FROM
GRAPPLING WITH QUESTIONS ABOUT
PROSECUTORIAL ISSUES. SO NOW WE
HAVE A SUITE OF FEDERAL
AGENCIES MY DEPARTMENT AND
ALSO- AND OTHERS INVOLVED IN
THE KEY EVIDENCE COLLECTION AND
RECORD BUILDING FOR POTENTIAL
PROSECUTION AND DAMAGES EFFORTS.
WE HAD A PRETTY ITERATIVE
DYNAMIC UP OVER FLIGHTS WITH
THE COAST GUARD WHERE I KNOW
MANY OF YOU WERE ABLE TO PUT
YOUR EYES ON THE RESPONSE AND
FORM YOUR OWN OPINIONS. WE ARE
FACED WITH THOSE TEN THOUSAND
VOLUNTEERS AND PUT A LOT MORE
VOLUNTEERS ON THE BEACH PICKING
UP TAR BALLS THAN WE EVER HAVE
BEFORE. BECAUSE OF THE
FISHERIES CLOSURE WE ACTUALLY
ALSO DID SOMETHING WE HAVEN'T
DONE RECENTLY. WE HAVE BEEN
EMPLOYING MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMERCIAL FISHING FLEET TO
HELP US PICK UP SAMPLES. TO
DETERMINE WHEN THE FISHERIES
WILL BE REOPENED. USING HEALTH
INDICATORS. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
OPEN ALL THE BEACHES AND
HARBORS. LOOK THERE ARE MANY
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE GOING ON HERE FOR QUITE SOME
TIME. THANK YOU I'M EXTREMELY
INTERESTED IN THE INVESTIGATION.
I HAVE THE EXPERIENCE OF BEING
INVOLVED IN THE PROSECUTION'S
AROUND REFUGIO. I KNOW WHAT IT
MEANS TO COLLECT THE EVIDENCE
AND WORK WITH MULTIPLE PARTIES
IN THAT SPACE. WE KNOW OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS DOING HIS
DUE DILIGENCE AS WELL. WE KNOW
WE HAVE ACHILLES ONE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND SEVERAL
CITIES ARE LOOKING INTO THEIR
OWN LITIGATION- DYNAMICS. I
KNOW THAT WE WILL SPEND TIME
AND I WELCOME THAT TIME ON. THE
VERY UNDERSTANDABLE WHO KNEW
WHAT WHEN RELATIVE TO STARTING
THISRESPONSE WHICH DOES HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP TO A POTENTIAL
CIVIL OR CRIMINAL DYNAMICS IN
THIS CASE. AND THERE ARE MUCH
BIGGER POLICY ISSUES IT FOR AS
WELL. I THINK IT'S CLEAR WE ALL
VALUE OUR OCEAN AND COASTLINES
ALL SHORTFALL PRODUCTION IS. A
COMPLICATED ISSUE IN MANY WAYS-
SO CLEAR AND ANOTHER. EACH
SPELL CAUSES HARM TO OUR PEOPLE
OUR BUSINESSES AND OUR NATURE.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HASN'T BEEN A
LEADER ON EFFORTS TO PHASE OUT
THE USE OF FOSSIL FUELS JUST
LAST WEEK MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THEM RELATIVE TO
THE DYNAMIC AROUND FRACKING
PERMITS IN CALIFORNIA. SINCE
TAKING OFFICE THE GOVERNORS
URGED THE DEPARTMENT OF THE
INTERIOR TO WITHDRAW CALIFORNIA
FROM FURTHER CONSIDERATION FOR
RENEWED OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT. AND WHILE MR CASEY
WOULD KNOW BETTER I DON'T THINK
IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE GRANTED NEW
OFFSHORE LEASES FOR ALL
PRODUCTION AND ALMOST FIFTY
YEARS. BUT SETTING ALL THOSE
DYNAMICS ASIDE WHICH I THINK
ARE VERY UNDERSTANDABLE AREAS
OF INQUIRY. I'M JUST SUPER
THANKFUL HERE ONE MONTH LATER
EVERYBODY I MEAN LITERALLY
EVERYONE. THE CITIZENS THEY
CALLED THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
SENDING ME PHOTOS OF TAR BALLS
AT SUCH AND SUCH LIFE STATION
IN CARLSBAD MY FRIENDS WHO
CALLED ME FROM SWAMI'S SAYING
I'M WORRIED ABOUT MY SURF BREAK.
TO EVERY ELECTED OFFICIAL. A
MONTH LATER WE NOW THINK THE
LIKELY STILL NUMBER IS
240-006-0090 SIX GALLONS. THE
IMPACT TO WILDLIFE WHILE VERY
SERIOUS COULD HAVE BEEN FAR
WORSE. I'M SUPER APPRECIATIVE
LAST NIGHT THE GOVERNOR WAS
ABLE TO ANNOUNCE WE SECURED A
SUSPENSE IS FOR BUSINESSES
IMPACTED BY THE SPILL AND THAT
THEY WILL HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SMALL BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION
LOANS TO BRIDGE THIS. GOT A LOT
OF WORK AHEAD OF US. I NEED TO
LEARN WHAT WE CAN DO BETTER
BASED ON OUR ASSESSMENT OF THE
STILL. I KNOW WE CAN ITERATE
AND BE BETTER BECAUSE THE
THINGS WE DID IN THIS BILL. WE
LEARNED IN REFUGIO HOW TO BE
BETTER. THE DEPLOYMENT OF
VOLUNTEERS THE ENGAGEMENT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS A
MEDIA OUT REACH TO YOU AT THE
ELECTED OFFICIAL LEVEL BRINGING
COUNTIES INTO OUR UNIFIED
COMMAND ALL WAR ALL HARD
LESSONS WE LEARNED IN REFUGIO.
WHICH WE ADOPTED FROM THE GET
GO IN THIS STILL. NO STILL IS A
GOOD STILL THE BEST SPELLERS
ZERO. BUT I'M THANKFUL WE COULD
ALL APPROACH THIS WITH AN ALL
HANDS ON DECK ALL GOVERNMENT
RESPONSE WE TURNED IT MR CULLEN
FOR THE DETAILS. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR WELCOME ADMINISTRATOR.
THANK YOU KRISTIN MY
PRESENTATION UP. THANK YOU OUR
TRUCK FOR THOSE ARE. REMARKS
ALTHOUGH UPON MANY OF THE ON
THE ASPECTS YOU TOUCHED UPON
AND GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
STERN STUDENTS THREE MEMBER
SINCE AN HONOR TO BE WITH YOU
ON THIS AFTERNOON TO DISCUSS
OUR RESPONSE TO THE PIPELINE.
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN SPELLING AND
I'D LIKE TO START UP BY GIVING
A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR
OFFICES SPOKE PREVENTION
RESPONSE AND THEN GIVE YOU AN
UPDATE ON THE CURRENT SITUATION
DOWN IN ORANGE AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTIES- LET ME SEE IF I CAN
DANCE. SLIDE HERE. THE OFFICE
OF SPILL PREVENTION RESPONSE
MORE COMMONLY KNOWN AS OSCAR
WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN NINETY
ONE BY THE LIBERTINES SEASTRAND
OIL SPILL PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE ACT. IMMEDIATELY AFTER
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PASSED
THE OIL POLLUTION ACT OF
NINETEEN NINETY COMMONLY
REFERRED IS OPEN NINETY. THESE
LAWS WERE ENACTED FOLLOWING THE
EXXON VALDEZ AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THE AMERICAN TRAITOR
STOLE CELEB WHICH COINCIDENTLY
SPILLED MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTEEN THOUSAND GALLONS OF
CRUDE OIL OFF OF. HUNTINGTON
BEACH IN FEBRUARY OF NINETEEN
NINETY. OSCAR IS A TRUSTEE OF
THE STATE'S NATURAL RESOURCES
ON SPECIFICALLY TASKED TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S SURFACE
WATERS. AND ASSOCIATE WILDLIFE
AND HABITATS FROM THE EFFECTS
OF TROLLING. OIL SPILLS. THIS
IS A QUICK VISUAL THAT SHOWS
OUR CURRENT COMPLEMENTS WHAT
TWO OR THIRTY OSCAR MEMBERS ARE
STATIONED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IN OUR OIL SPILL PROTECTION
PROGRAM TO. OUR HEADQUARTERS IN
WEST SACRAMENTO WE HAVE THREE
MAJOR FIELD OFFICES OF FIRST
RESPONDERS CENTER FIELD WHAT
SOUND YOU KNOW SEND BAKERSFIELD
ALONG WITH ANOTHER. TEN
SATELLITE FIELD LOCATIONS. IN
OUR OSCAR FIRST RESPONDERS ARE
PRIMARILY COMPOSED OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION OFFICERS
THAT ARE OFTEN. THE FIRST ON
SCENE- FOLKS ARRIVING THEY
ASSUME THE STATE ON SCENE
COORDINATOR DUTIES ON MY- STORY
ALONG WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
SCIENTISTS AND- OIL. SPILL
PREVENTION SPECIALISTS. THERE'S
A BIT OF BREAD FIBER IT'S
ALWAYS IMPORTANT YOU THE VERY
ELEMENTS OF A PREVENTION.
RESPONSE PROGRAM AND I WOULD
ADD TO RESPOND THAT THERE'S
ALSO A VERY CRITICAL
RESTORATION ASPECT. SORT OF FOR
THE FIRST FORTY YEARS OF OSCARS
COASTAL AUTHORITY SETS WERE THE
LARGEST OIL POLLUTION WAS
PERCEIVED GIVEN THOSE TWO
TANKER DISASTERS IN NINETEEN
NINETY THAT I MENTIONED.
HOWEVER WITH SEVERAL CRUDE OIL
BY RAIL TRAIN ACCIDENTS IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE RAISED THE
AWARENESS OF THE IMMINENT
THREAT OF OIL POLLUTION TO OUR
STATE'S NATURAL RESOURCES NOT
TRUST. BY RAIL OR BY PIPELINE
STANLEY BOIL PRODUCTION OR
TRUCKS INTO ABANDONED DERELICT
VESSELS PARTICULARLY WATERWAYS
LIKE THE SACRAMENTO AND SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER DELTA IS. IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN GOVERNOR BROWN
SIGNED SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY
ONE THE EXPANDED OSCARS
JURISDICTION TO COVER ALL
SURFACE WATERS OF THE STATE
BOTH COASTAL AND INLAND. AND
THIS PAST JULY AUTHORITIES TO
FURTHER EXTEND TO APPLY TO NOT
JUST A DRAWING BUT ALSO. THOSE
RENEWABLE FUELS ARE DERIVED
FROM FEEDSTOCKS LIKE YEAH
HELLO. AND WHILE THESE
RENEWABLES PRODUCE MUCH LESS
CARBON TO THE ATMOSPHERE DURING
COMBUSTION CENTER PATROLLING
CAR PARKS 8% EVERY BIT THE
THREAT TO WATER AND. HABITAT
THE PETROLEUM DOES. ONE OF THE
KEY S. OF PREPARED ESPECIALLY
ARE AREA CONTINGENCY OF THE
KNOWN AS B. C. THAT PROTECT
COASTLINE. IF A COMPANY
TRANSPORTS REFINED STORES OR
PRODUCES OILS ABOVE A
PRESCRIBED AMOUNT PROXIMATE TO
STATE WATERS. THEY'RE REQUIRED
TO FILE AN OIL SPILL
CONTINGENCY ACCOUNT PLAN OR C.
PLAN WITH OUR OFFICE AND UPDATE
IT REGULARLY. SHE PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO SPECIFY CRITICAL
INFORMATION TO DESCRIBE THE
PLAN HOLDERS ABILITY TO RESPOND
TO SPILLED OIL INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT. SOME OF THE KEY
ELEMENTS ARE NOTIFICATION
CONTACT LIST THEY'RE CONTRACTED
OIL SPILL RESPONSE ORGANIZATION
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS AN SRO-
THEIR INTERNAL. CONTRACTED
STORE MANAGEMENT TEAM THERE PER
FRAME I'M SO SORRY TRAINED AND
PROFICIENT IN ALL ASPECTS OF
RESPONSE. A TECHNICAL
DESCRIPTION OF THEIR OIL
HANDLING INFRASTRUCTURE. THERE
SHORELINE PROTECTION EQUIPMENT
AS REQUIRED BY THE RELEVANT ACP.
LANCE FOR AFFECTED WILDLIFE
CARE AND THERE'S ALSO MANY
OTHER IMPORTANT ELEMENTS. SO
WHEN AN OIL SPILL OCCURS
THERE'S AN ALPHABET SOUP OF
STATE FEDERAL AND LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT TYPICALLY
RESPONDS. TO THE NATIONAL
RESPONSE PLAN OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS ICS CERT INCIDENT COMMAND
SYSTEM AND THE UNIFIED COMMAND
AT THE TOP IS A COMBINATION OF
A FEDERAL ON SCENE COORDINATOR
AND SEE THE COAST GUARD OR PPA
BY OPEN NINETY- THE US. ON C.
COORDINATOR FROM OSCAR. A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE SPELLING
COMPANY OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY. AND AN
INNOVATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S NOT IN THE NATIONAL PLAN
BUT WE DON'T EXPLOIT. IN
REFUGIO IN THE COSCO BUSAN
STILL IN SAN FRANCISCO I AM
VERY EFFECTIVELY HERE. IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON SCENE COORDINATOR.
SO THE ORGANIZATION CHART THAT
I HAVE HERE WHILE IT'S NOT MUCH
MUCH BIGGER IN REALITY THIS
SHOW SOME OF THE KEY FUNCTIONS
THAT ASPARTIC TYPICALLY LEADS.
OR PARTICIPATES AND- CONCURRENT
WITH THE RESPONSE OPERATION
WITH TWO BOXES YOU SEE UP TOP.
ON THE- SEVERAL CRITICS I'M
SORRY YOUR TIME CRITICAL CIVIL
AND CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
WHICH BROKEN BOTTOM MENTIONED
AS I'M GOING. AND ALSO A
NATURAL RESOURCE DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT IT'S A PROCESS BY
WHICH THE STATE AND FEDERAL
TRUSTEE AGENCIES WORK PROPERLY
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
RESPONSIBLE PARTY. TO ASSESS
ECOLOGICAL DAMAGES AND LOSS OF
HUMAN USE CAUSED BY SPILLS SO
FOR EXAMPLE AFTER THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN REFUGIO OIL
SPILL ON THAT WAS SETTLED. IN
AND THEN R. D. EIGHT PROCESS IN
OCTOBER OF- AUGUST TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THERE'S TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS.
AGREED UPON TO RESPOND SERIOUS.
REST PROJECTS ABOUT TWELVE ON
MILLION SEVEN AND ENSURE
COUNTIES. MOST WILL STILL
CONTINUES TO CLAIM HOLDERS WILL
NAME THE OIL LIGHT WILDLIFE
CARE NETWORK OR O. W. C. M. AS
THEIR WILDLIFE CARE SOLUTION
THE- WCMH BY THE ONE HEALTH
INSTITUTE AT UC DAVIS IS A
NETWORK OF MORE THAN FORTY
SPECIALIZED. WILDLIFE CARE
CENTERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
IT'S REALLY THE GOLD STANDARD
OF OILED WILDLIFE CARE IN THE
WORLD SO IN THE CASE OF THE
PIPELINE FIVE THIRTY SEVEN SO
WE IMMEDIATELY NOTIFIED ALREADY
SAID THAT THERE WAS SOMETHING
HAPPENING OFFSHORE OUTSIDE
STATE WATERS BUT THEY
IMMEDIATELY- ENGAGED RESPONDED
AND THEY STILL REMAIN. DEPLOYED
FOR THE RESPONSE. SO NOW NO
WONDER THE ACTUAL SPELLING SO
DIRECT ABOUT MENTION. THAT
POINT LIKE THAT WE HAD ON THE
MORE BACK TO THIRD WINTER YOUR-
WHY EXACTLY DRACULA- AND MANY
OTHERS AND THIS IS A CONTRACTED
OUT OF THE WINDOW THAT SHOWED
WHAT WE SAW AND THE HORROR THAT
WE FELT. I BELIEVE YOU'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH THE PARTICULARS
OF SMILE RED DOT WAS DISPLACED
HERE BUT IT'S ACTUALLY JUST
BEFORE THE BAND RIGHT HERE THIS
IS WHERE THE- FOUR THOUSAND
FOUR SECTION DISPLACED A
HUNDRED FIVE FEET. ARE THE
DIRECTOR OF BOTTOM MENTIONED.
ON. SO HERE WE HAVE PLATFORM
BELLY AND- AND THE OTHER TWO
PLATFORMS THAT ARE SERVED AT
PIPELINE AND THEN COMES ASHORE
IS STRUCK BY MENTIONED UP BY
THE QUEEN MARY. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT FUNCTIONS OF THE OIL
SPILL IS THE SHORELINE CLEANUP
ASSESSMENT TECHNIQUE TEAMS TO
ASSESSING CLEAN. MANY MILES OF
AFFECTED BE TRYING. TO SCHEDULE
TEAM DEPLOYMENT CCAP HOTSHOT
TEAMS ARE ON STANDBY TO RESPOND
REPORTS. OILS ALONG THE COAST.
CRICKET TEAM SERVING SCHEDULED
AND DEPLOYED TO THE SPEECHES TO
DO A MORE THOROUGH CLEAN UP AT
THE HEIGHT OF THE RESPONSE AS
DIRECTED BY THE MENTION THERE
WERE MORE THAN EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
TRAINED RESPONDERS BOTH IN THE
COMMAND POST. AND IN THE FIELD.
UNFORTUNATELY THE RESPONSE. WE
ARE REQUIRED TO CLOSE ALL
FISHING A LARGER IN THE OCEAN
IN THE VICINITYOF THE SPELLS
WE RECOGNIZE THAT WAS THIS WAS
PARTICULARLY HARD. ON THE LOCAL
FISHING COMMUNITY HAS A LOBSTER
SEASON HAD TRUST. OPENED WHEN
THE SPILL OCCURRED. AND WE'RE
WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
HAZARD ASSESSMENT OR OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS WE HA. I WILL TELL YOU
A- CHEMICAL DATA AND ADVICE THE
DEPARTMENT. OUR DEPARTMENT. ON
WHETHER CLOSER TO BE LISTED.
NOT. TO REOPEN THIS IS FREE SO
IT'S POSSIBLE. UNFORTUNATELY
GIVEN THE SIZE OF THE SPILL
THEY WERE NOT AS MANY I'M
SORRY. FORTUNATELY GIVEN THE
SIZE OF THE SPELLED OR NOT AS
MANY WYLIE'S CASTLE HE SAYS
COULD HAVE OCCURRED. NOW DURING
pW. SEVEN CAPTURED AND
REHABILITATE MANY BIRDS
INCLUDING IN DANGER SO IT
WORKS. THIS IS A SCREENSHOT OF
ONE OF THEIR MANY FACEBOOK
POSTINGS. SHOWING A CAREFUL
CARE THAT THESE SMALL BIRDS AN
ANSWER THE STAFF AND TO HABITAT.
AND THIS IS A BEFORE AND AFTER
PICTURE OF OIL DOCTOR BROUGHT
IT BROUGHT A SMILE TO ALL OF
OUR FACES FOR HORSES DURING
THIS DIFFICULT RESPONSE.
INSTRUCTED BY AN IMMENSELY WITH
THE VOLUNTEER EFFORT WE ALSO
RECEIVED A TREMENDOUS
OUTPOURING OF INTEREST FROM
CONSERVATIVE CITIZENS. INTEREST
IN HELPING THE RESPONSE.
WORKING WITH CAL VOLUNTEERS THE
WEBSITE WAS ESTABLISHED THAT
REGISTERED MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS FROM MANY
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA. FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY ONE OF THE
CITIZENS WERE OFFERED AN
ABBREVIATED ONE TIME TRAINING
CALLS HAS WATER WHICH STANDS
FOR HAZARDOUS WASTE OPERATIONS.
EMERGENCY RESPONSE IT'S
CRITICAL TRAINING THAT TEACHES
ALL HAZARDOUS WASTE RESPONDENTS
ABOUT THE THREATS OF EXPOSURE
AND HOW TO BEST PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR
COLLEAGUES. THERE WERE FOUR
WELL ORGANIZED SPONSORED
DEPLOYMENTS DURING THE RESPONSE
AN AVERAGE OF THIRTY FIVE
PARTICIPANTS. FROM THE
COMMUNITY DURING EACH ONE OF
THESE. APPOINTMENTS SO I'M
OFFERED SOME FIGHTS WITH
UPDATED NUMBERS FROM THIS
MORNING'S DAILY UNIFIED COMMAND
SITUATION BREAKING SO CURRENTLY
THERE ARE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX RESPOND WRISTS ON THE FIELD
ASSESSMENT CLEANING BEACHES
PRIMARILY IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WHAT CAR BILLS TAR BALLS
CONTINUE TO WASH SHORT. TWENTY
SIX OTHER PERSONNEL AND FOR
OPERATING BASIS AND AN%
ADDITIONAL THIRTY FIVE WORKING
VIRTUALLY IN THE COMMAND
FUNCTION. THE PHYSICAL UNIFIED
COMMAND AT OCEAN COAST COLLEGE
IN COSTA MESA DEMOBILIZED THIS
PAST SUNDAY. TO DATE MORE THAN
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND POUNDS OF OIL AND OIL
DEBRIS PRIMARILY STAND HAS BEEN
COLLECTED. NEARLY A THOUSAND
POUNDS IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY JUST
IN THE PAST TWO DAYS. IF I
CHOSE THE CURRENT STATUS OF THE
UNIFIED. COMMAND USES TO
EVALUATE THE THIRTY SEVEN
ORANGE COUNTY IN SEVENTY SAN
DIEGO COUNTY COASTLINE SEGMENTS.
OPERATIONS CONTINUOUS CACTI THE
STAFF TEAMS LOCATE. AND ARM AND
DEPLOYED TO IRAQ TO THE SITE TO
DATE SCOTT TEAM SERVICE DESK
THREE HUNDRED FORTY THREE MILES
OF COASTLINE AND CLEAN UP CREWS
HAVE CLEANED. FOUR HUNDRED
FORTY TWO MILES ON THESE
NUMBERS OBVIOUSLY REFLECT
REPEAT VISITS TO SEVERAL
SEGMENTS OF THE BEACH. DURING
THE RESPONSE MORE THAN TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND FEET OF
PROTECTIVE CONTAINMENT AND
SORTED BOOM WAS DEPLOYED WE
PROTECTED THIRTEEN CENTS OF
SENSITIVE SITES. INTENDS TO
CLAMP. RESPONSE ASSETS INCLUDED
THIRTEEN RESPONSE VESSELS
MULTIPLE FIXED WING HELICOPTER
AND UNMANNED AIRCRAFT IN. OUR
PEAK ON OCTOBER ELEVENTH
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
PERSONNEL. DECONTAMINATION OF
RECREATIONAL VESSELS CONTINUES
AT THREE LOCATIONS TO DATE TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE CLAIMS HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED FIFTY NINE
VESSELS HAVE BEEN CLEANED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MORE OR TO BE
SCHEDULED WITH ANOTHER HUNDRED
TEND. TO BE ASSESSED. NO
ADDITIONAL OIL WHY LECTURE
CONCERT IN THE PAST TWENTY FOUR
HOURS AND ONE REHABILITATED
BIRD WAS RELEASED YESTERDAY.
THE WCM STRESSES THAT OF THE
ONE HUNDRED AND TEN ANIMALS
REPORTED DEAD ON ARRIVAL AT THE
BOTTOM OF THAT COLUMN. SHE WAS
THEM SORTED STERILE OILING AND
NEED TO BE FURTHER EXAMINED.
ANY DEAD WILDLIFE COLLECTED ON
THE SHORELINE ARE AUTOMATICALLY
ENTERED INTO THIS TABLE. AND AS
THE RESPONSE CONCLUDE. OUR WORK
STILL NOT DONE THE
INVESTIGATION AND RDA THE
RECOVERY OF OUR COSTS AND VERY
IMPORTANT YES THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED. AN ASSESSMENT OF OUR
RESPONSE ACTIONS WITH A LOOK AT
FAMILY BEST PRACTICES BUT WHERE
THOSE AREAS THAT WE CAN IMPROVE
RESPONSES IN THE FUTURE. AND
WITH THAT AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- ATTENTION AND OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING.
AT THANK YOU FOR THAT THOROUGH
OVERVIEW ADMINISTRATOR COLIN- I
DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS BUT AS
SOON- SOME OF THE MEMBERS ALSO
DO AS WELL- I'LL I'LL JUST
START OUT AT THE OUTSET- BY
ENQUIRING- THE TIMELINE FOR
THAT AFTER ACTION REPORT DO YOU
HAVE AN ESTIMATE AT THIS POINT
OF WHEN. YOU ALL ANTICIPATE
COMPLETING THAT THANK YOU
SENATOR- WE'VE ALREADY STARTED
THE UNIFIED COMMAND MATT AND
WHILE THEY WERE STILL MOBILIZED%
OCEAN COAST COLLEGE TO START
GATHERING YOU KNOW SOME OF
THOSE ITEMS I MENTIONED. FOR
THE REFUGIO SPILL IT TOOK US
ABOUT TWELVE MONTHS YEAH WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS TASK. AND-
WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT A TOP
PRIORITY. IF I COULD I'D ALSO
JUST SAY. PART OF WHAT WE
EXPERIENCE AND LEARN FROM IN
REFUGIO IS. AS WE THINK THROUGH
OUR ASSESSMENTS SICK THE
FEEDBACK OF OTHERS INVOLVED SO
I DO THINK PART OF THIS DYNAMIC
WOULD BE. HOW DO WE GET
FEEDBACK FROM OUR CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WERE KIND OF
BROADLY INVOLVED WHAT WOULD IT
LOOK LIKE TO GET FEEDBACK YOU
KNOW FROM OUR LOCAL CITIES.
MAKING SURE WE HAVE THOSE AND
PUT BLINDS FOR THE FEEDBACK AND
ASSESSMENT I THINK WILL BE
REALLY VALUABLE. EXCELL AWFULLY
TODAY STARTS THAT PROCESS IN A
MORE FORMAL CONTEXT BUT- AND
THAT'LL CONTINUE- MY OTHER
QUESTIONS- THE- TO DO WITH THE
ISSUES THAT YOU MAY NOT HAVE
FULLY EVALUATED YET BUT IN
TERMS OF- WHAT WE COULD HAVE
DONE BETTER- I WANTED TO JUST
GET YOUR INITIAL TAKE ON- THE
ACTUAL- THE ACTUAL DETECTION
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE'RE USING OUT
THERE- WHEN I WENT OUT WE WERE-
LOSING SOME CAMERAS AND THE C.
THIRTY SEVENS THAT WERE MOVING
AROUND WITH COAST GUARD. BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE IS
NO SURFACE SEARCH RADAR-
CURRENTLY BEING DEPLOYED- THAT
WE'RE NOT UTILIZING ANY
AUTOMATED WATER QUALITY SENSING
LOUISE OR OTHER TECHNIQUES IN
OUR DETECTION PROCESS- HAVE
YOU. HAVE YOU- AND ANY COMMENTS
ON ON THOSE ISSUES WHETHER- BUT
COULD HAVE BEEN- EITHER MORE
MORE TIMELY IN OUR RESPONSE OR
OR IF THOSE ARE SORT OF
OUTSTANDING ITEMS THE
DEPARTMENT STILL LOOKING TO
OBTAIN OR OR NOT NECESSARY FOR
SOME REASON. A COMBINATION AND
THEN ALAS MR CALLING TO FILL IN
ANY BLANKS FIRST. IT'S TOTALLY
UNDERSTANDABLE AND WE CAN
ALWAYS TIGHTEN UP THOSE FIRST
TWENTY FOUR TO SEVENTY TWO
HOURS AND THESE DYNAMICS. SADLY
I'VE LIVED THROUGH TWO AT A
PRETTY. IMPACTFUL SIGNIFICANCE
LEVEL AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S HAPPENING FOR US IN THE
OPENING MOMENTS IS. TRYING TO
CONFIRM WHAT'S GOING ON DEALING
WITH MANY MANY AND THAT
INFORMATION AND PUTS. AND THEN
BEING STABLE ENOUGH ON
INFORMATION TO KNOW WHERE TO
DEPLOY. OF COURSE YOU DON'T
WANT TO SEARCH A THOUSAND
PEOPLE TO THE WRONG PLACE. SO I
THINK THAT'S A LITTLE BIT WHAT
WILL EVENTUALLY DISCOVER WAS
PLAYING OUT THROUGH THE EARLY
MORNING OF SATURDAY OCTOBER
SECOND. OUR WARDENS ACTUALLY
WORK OUT THERE ALL FORWARD ON
THAT SATURDAY WE HAD FOLKS ON
THE WATER ANYWAY RELATIVE TO
THE LOBSTER OPENER. AND IN THE
DARK WERE YOU KNOW WORKING AS
ONE OF THOSE INFORMATION
CHANNELS. SECOND COMMENT
SENATOR. I AM NOT QUALIFIED TO
COMMENT ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
DETECTION TECHNOLOGY I DO THINK
WE SHOULD KEEP OUR MIND OPEN
AND PUSH OURSELVES TO IMPROVE
IN THAT AREA REMINDER THE
FEDERAL WATERS PRETTY FAR OUT
AS TO THE PLATFORM ITSELF. AND
I AM NOT AWARE OF EXISTING
WATER BILL YOU DYNAMIC OUT
THERE THAT MAY BE COLLECTING
WATER QUALITY FIRST FOR EXAMPLE
PERHAPS OVER TIME THAT NETWORK
COULD BECOME THAT AUTOMATED AND
THAT FINE TUNED. AND THIS IS
WHERE MR CULLEN MAY HAVE
SOMETHING TO OFFER EACH YEAR
PART OF US FIRST CHARGE IS TO
BE CONVENING INDUSTRY AND THE
EXPERTS IN THE SCIENTISTS TO
PURPOSEFULLY ASK WHAT IS THE
NEXT VERSION OF TECHNOLOGY. I
DO THINK WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
INTO WHAT CANBE HAPPENING
OVERNIGHT WHAT COULD BE
HAPPENING IN THE DARK THERE'S A
LOT OF DIFFERENCE OF OPINION IN
THIS PROFESSIONAL SPACE HOW
MUCH YOU CAN BE DOING IN THE
DARK BUT THAT SEEMS TO ME AN
OBVIOUS ARENA TO THINK ABOUT AS
THE TECHNOLOGY. ADMINISTRATOR
CALLING YOU WANNA. THE
TECHNOLOGY. YOUR SOUL OUR OUR
CUTTINGS STATUTE BE. PERKS KING
STREET STAND ACT MANDATES SAY-
THAT WE BEST TRIPLE
TECHNOLOGIES SPILLS AND SO WITH
THAT IN MIND EVERY TWO YEARS
SINCE THIS PAST FEBRUARY WE CO
HOST OIL SPILL TECHNOLOGY
WORKSHOP THIS PAST ONE HELD
VIRTUALLY OVER THE COURSE OF
FOUR DAYS HAD SEVENTY ONE
COUNTRIES REPRESENTED WITH MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED
PARTICIPANTS- EVERYTHING FROM
REMOTE SENSING TECHNOLOGIES-
TO- VARIOUS BOOMING INTO
CONTAINMENT TECHNIQUES AND SO
FORTH SO. SPECIFIC TO THIS BILL-
LOOKING BACK AT MY PREVIOUS
CAREER IN THE COAST GUARD- I
FLEW MANY MISSIONS WITH
SOMETHING CALLED A SIDE LOOKING
AIRBORNE RADAR WHICH WAS A
SYNTHETIC APERTURE RADAR WHICH
WAS VERY. CAPABLE OF DETECTING
VARIATIONS AND WATER DAMPENING
SOMEONE OIL SLICKS ON THE
SURFACE OF THE WATER IT MAKES
IT A LITTLE BIT FLATTER AND THE
RADAR CAN DETECT THAT. THAT WAS
EMPLOYED EARLY ON IN THIS BILL
IT WAS ABLE TO SEE- SEE SOME
THE BOUNDARIES OF THE HEAVIER
OIL IT'S INEFFECTIVE FORESEEN-
WE'RE NOT AWARE OF AND PERHAPS
THAT TECHNOLOGY WILL BE
DEVELOPED AS ANY SHORE BASED
RADAR THE COMPULSORY. IN DETECT
OIL. ON OUR PARTNER STARTED
DESCRIPTIONS TO IN A LAWYER. ON
THERE IS A- ARTIFACT CALLED THE
SOUTHERN- CALIFORNIA
OBSERVATION- SENSING SYSTEM
SCREWS. THEY HAVE SOME CALL THE
HF RADAR WHICH IS VERY
EFFECTIVE AND WE USED IT DURING
THE SPELL AND REFUGIO. TO SEND
A PULSE OUT AND HELP BETTER
PROTECT TRAJECTORIES OF
ANYTHING THAT MIGHT BE OUT
THERE ALSO WHAT WATER CURRENCY
IN SURFACE WINDS- BUT THIS IS A
PRIORITY FOR US OUR CENTER TO
CONTINUE TO GO AND LOOK AT
TECHNOLOGIES THAT. CAN DETECT
OIL ESPECIALLY AT NIGHT. SIR I
THINK WE HAVE A GREAT YOU KNOW-
WE'RE KEEPING OUR LIST OF OTHER
THINGS WHERE WE WANT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT DOING BETTER I THINK AS
EXAMPLES. INSTEAD OF IT IN THE
EVENT TRAINING VOLUNTEERS IS
THERE A WAY TO CULTIVATE
VOLUNTEERS LIKE ANNUALLY SO
MORE PEOPLE ARE UP TO DATE ON
TRAINING. AS AN EXAMPLE I THINK
A PLACE WE CAN BE DOING BETTER
IS. INSTEAD OF HAVING THE
EVENTS AND THEN BEING ENGAGED
WITH A LOT OF EXTERNAL
SCIENTISTS. AT ALL THESE
LEADING INSTITUTIONS WHAT IF
WE'RE DOING THAT MORE REGULARLY.
THEY WAS THE FIRST I'M A OF
WHAT WE KILL ME PUBLIC HEALTH
INTO THE COMMAND I THOUGHT THAT
WAS OUTSTANDING. AT A STRATEGIC
LEVEL BUT MY GUESS IS WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO. PRACTICE THAT
WAS COUNTIES ALONG THE COAST TO
BE TACTICALLY. MORE ADEPT IN
RAPID IN BRINGING AND THEN THAT
WAY. AS OTHER EXAMPLES OF
IMPROVEMENTS. I'D LIKE TO BUILD
ON YOUR COMMENT ABOUT THE
VOLUNTEERS WE HAVE A MODEL
ALREADY IN PLACE WITH THE OIL
WHILE IT'S KERR NETWORK THEY
HAVE THE- A QUITE A NETWORK OF
AFFILIATED VOLUNTEERS THAT GOES
THROUGH RECURRING TRAINING.
OUGHT TO PREPARE THEM TO GO OUT
AND PERFORM THEIR WILDLIFE
MISSION SO WE CAN TAKE THAT.
CASCADEDINTO THE VOLUNTEER
EFFORT RESTAURANT THEM GIVE
THEM THAT RECURRING TRAINING SO
THAT THEY'RE BETTER PREPARED
AND POISED TO SURGE WHEN
SOMETHING HAPPENS. THANKS FOR
THOSE COMMENTS IN YOUR CHANGES
PAID MY FINAL QUESTION BY
VOLUNTEERS BECAUSE FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE IS GREAT BUT THREE
THOUSAND SIGNED UP IN. ONE AT
YOU KNOW FIVE FIVE EIGHT SIX OR
TURNED AWAY FOR VARIOUS
REASONS- YOU KNOW WE'RE DIDN'T
SEEM LIKE WE'RE TAKING FULL
ADVANTAGE OF THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
TO HELP BUT- WE CAN DIG MORE
INTO THAT LATER- MEMBERS ALL
ALL. AND LAGERALD JUMP IN WITH
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IF YOU
HAVE ANY AT THIS POINT- ARE YOU
BUT I CAN DO FOR. OKAY
CENTERMAN WHAT YOU START OFF.
THANK YOU I FIRST JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN ADMINISTRATOR
COLIN AND DIRECTOR BONHAM- YEAH
I MANY WAYS I THINK THAT THE
LESSONS YOU LEARNED FROM
REFUGIO JUST WITNESSING IT IN
ACTION THIS WAS AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW GOVERNMENT. CAN WORK
EFFECTIVELY IN RESPONDING TO
CRISES IN AND WAS VERY
IMPRESSED WITH YOUR OPERATION-
HOW QUICKLY RAMPED UP- THAT
DIDN'T THIS SIZE OF THE TEAM
THAT WAS ON SITE. YOUR RESPONSE
TO THIS SO THANK YOU BECAUSE I
KNOW YOUR YOUR EFFORTS WERE
CRITICAL IN PREVENTING US FROM
BECOMING A LARGER PROBLEM IN
ORANGE COUNTY- I SHOULD ALSO
MENTION I YOU MENTIONED
TRAINING. I REMEMBER TALKING
WITH THE PROPRIETOR OF THE
HUNTINGTON BEACH WETLANDS WHEN
WE WENT TO VISIT AND TODAY HAD
SAID THAT- ABOUT NINE MONTHS
EARLIER THAN ACTUALLY HAD A
TRAINING EXERCISE ON THE
REASONS THEY WERE ABLE TO GET
BOOMS DEPLOYED SO QUICKLY IS
BECAUSE THEY JUST ON THE
TRAINING EXERCISES. WHEN THE
BLOOMS ARRIVED THEY WERE- YOU
THEY KNEW EXACTLY WHAT TO DO
WITH THEM BECAUSE IT WAS FRESH
IN THEIR MIND I THINK THAT'S A
VERY- IMPORTANT ANOTHER GOOD
EXAMPLE OF HOW WE LEARN FROM
THE FUTURE- I HAD A COUPLE
QUESTIONS THOUGH ON TOP OF
THAT- I GUESS FOLLOWING ON-
CENTER STERN'S QUESTION EARLY
DETECTION- YOU KNOW WE'VE READ
AND THIS IS ALSO THE SOME OF
THE BACKGROUND MATERIALS
RECEIVED TODAY THAT. THERE ARE
NUMBER OF FAILURES OF-
REGULATION THAT THAT WE'VE
TECHNOLOGY FOR A LONG TIME
THAT- FEDERATIONS HAVE NOT KEPT
UP WITH TECHNOLOGY THAT WEIRD
AT EITHER END BOTH AT THIS SORT
OF- GOVERNMENTAL LEVEL BUT ALSO
AT THE PROPRIETOR OF THAT IS TO
SAY THAT THE OIL. DRILLING AND
EXTRACTION OPERATORS THEMSELVES
HAVE NOT KEPT UP WITH THE TYPES
OF MONITORING THAT MIGHT BE
HELPFUL IN DETECTING ALWAYS
SPELLS EARLIER ON AND THERE
HAVE BEEN REPORTS THAT THIS
PARTICULAR OUR OIL SPILL COULD
HAVE BEEN DETECTED MUCH
EARLIER- PERHAPS NOT JUST AT
THE ONSET OF THIS PRETTY. GOOD
SPELL BUT THAT. THE PROBLEMS
THE PIPE. MIGHT HAVE BEEN MONTH-EARLIER IF THEY HAD BETTER.
MIND SO. AND I GUESS I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO.
WHAT TYPES OF REGULATIONS
WHETHER FEDERAL STATE WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THAT LATER MIGHT
HAVE BEEN HELPFUL IN.
PREVENTING THIS PARTICULAR
SPELL FROM HAPPENING. SO
SENATOR. A COUPLE THOUGHTS HERE
FIRST- I'M GONNA SAY UP FRONT I
THINK MY ANSWER TO YOU WILL NOT
BE AS FULLY RESPONSIVE AS YOU
WANT AND THERE'S A REASON.
PRIMARILY THE LIKELY SOURCE FOR
THE LEAK IS IN FEDERAL WATERS.
FOR IF A PIPELINE WITH
PRIMARILY FEDERAL JURISDICTION.
AS YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT IT THIS IS THE
PIPELINE AND HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS SAFETY AGENCY WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. THEY ARE INVOLVED IN
THAT INVESTIGATION THAT'S
OCCURRING. THERE'S A FEDERAL A
CORRECTIVE ORDER IN PLACE
DEBATE OFF SHORE WE HAD A VERY
DETAILED APPROACH OF THE WORK
THAT HAS TO BE DONE. NO
RESTARTED THAT EFFECTIVE
PIPELINE MATT KERR IN LAST
UNTIL THE WHOLE SUITE OF
CONDITIONS PRECEDING DOORMAT
UNDER THAT FEDERAL WATER.
SIMULTANEOUSLY WE'VE GOT THE
NATIONAL TRANSPORTATION SAFETY
BOARD INVOLVED WE'VE GOT
SOMETHING AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE INTERIOR WHICH IS THE
BUREAU OF SAFETY ENVIRONMENTAL
ENFORCEMENT WHICH HAS
JURISDICTION EFFECTIVELY OVER
THE PLATFORMS AND THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. BY WARDENS ARE
IN THAT SPACE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
AN INTEREST IN PROTECTING THE
CHAIN OF CUSTODY AND
UNDERSTANDING THE COLLECTION OF
EVIDENCE FOR OUR OWN INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS POTENTIALLY. I REALLY
CAN'T COMMENT ON THE DYNAMICS
AROUND THE PIPE ITSELF. I WILL
ALSO JUST BLUNTLY SAY TO YOU I
REALIZED- WHO KNEW WHAT WHEN
WHO ACTIVATED WHAT REQUIRED
DISCLOSURE WHEN. IS OF EXTREME
IMPORTANCE AS WELL. BUT IT IS
CONNECTED TO THAT. EVIDENTIARY
AN INVESTIGATORY DYNAMIC AND I
JUST CAN'T COMMENT I MEAN I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT I KNOW IT'S
NON RESPONSIVE- IN THE SENSE OF
WHY YOU'RE ENQUIRING MAYBE I
DIDN'T ARTICULATE THE QUESTION
WELL ENOUGH I'M NOT TRYING
INTERESTED AT THIS MOMENT IN IN
THE WHO WHAT WHY WHEN. I'M MORE
THINKING ABOUT HYPOTHETICALLY-
ARE THERE REGULATORY CHANGES
AND RECOGNIZING THAT A LOT OF
THIS IN THIS INSTANCE WOULD
HAVE BEEN AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL-
BUT WHAT REGULATORY CHANGES
MIGHT HAVE HELPED WITH A SPELL
OF THIS TYPE- GOING FORWARD IN
OTHER WORDS WHAT CAN WE DO TO
TRY TO PREVENT- AND PERHAPS
FIND EARLIER DETECTION OF.
THESE TYPES OF SPILLS- YOU KNOW
WHAT. CAN WE TRY TO SEEK TO
IMPLEMENT- WHAT CHANGES CAN WE
AGAIN THINKING ABOUT THIS
GENETICALLY BETWEEN THE FEDERAL
AND STATE GOVERNMENTS- WHAT
WOULD HAVE HELPED PREVENT THIS
OR WHAT MIGHT HELP GOING
FORWARD UNFORTUNATELY. LET ME
PROJECT FORWARD AND JUST OFFER
MY OWN PERSONAL OPINION I THINK
AUTOMATION. IS A CORE VALUE
CORE STRATEGY TO THE EXTENT
WHERE NOT WE SHOULD BE. AND
WHERE WE ARE BUT COULD DO IT
BETTER. I THINK. I ENDED
DAUGHTER. PERSISTENT INSPECTION
AND AGAIN I'M NOT COMMENTING
LOOKING BACKWARDS ON THIS ON
WHETHER EITHER OF THOSE
VARIABLES FOR A PLAY BUT GOING
FORWARD I THINK AUTOMATION. AN
INSPECTION. AND DISCLOSURE
AROUND BOTH THOSE DYNAMICS ARE
THREE KEY VARIABLES AUTOMATION
INSPECTION AND DISCLOSURE.
THANK YOU. FIVE ADMINISTRATOR
CALLING YOUR METHODS. I'M THE
ONLY THING I WOULD ADD TO OUR
CENTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR KIND
COMMENTS BY THE WAY AND FOR
YOUR VISIT TO THE COMMAND POST-
WE REGULARLY HOLD A STATE OIL
SPILL REGULATOR GROUP THAT IS
COMPOSED OF THE VARIOUS
AGENCIES THAT HAVE PREVENTION
RESPONSIBILITY SO FOR ON DEMAND
PRODUCTION THEY'LL BE KILLED
CHOPS FOR- MARINE TERMINALS AND
OFFSHORE PLATFORMS THAT WOULD
BE STATE LANDS COMMISSION- RAIL
WOULD BE THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND THEN OF COURSE
PIPELINES. FOR THE INTER I'M
SORRY INTRASTATE PIPELINE
SERVICE STATE FIRE MARSHAL SO
YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE WHAT WE'RE
pOF WEEKS TO THAT GROUP WITH AN
EMPHASIS ON LOOKING AT
TECHNOLOGIES AND BETTER WAYS OF
COMMUNICATING. BETWEEN OUR
AGENCIES. THANK YOU. MY SECOND
QUESTION REVOLVES AROUND- NOT
THE TIMING OF THE SPILL BUT THE
TIMING OF NOTIFICATION TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND CITIES AND
COUNTIES- I WAS TALKING WITH
MAYOR KIM CARR EARLIER THIS
WEEK AND I DON'T WANT TO. GIVE
A SPOILER ON HER TESTIMONY BUT-
YOU KNOW SINCE SHE'S GONNA BE
SPEAKING LATER I JUST I JUST
WANTED TO ADDRESS SOMETHING HE
RAISED. THEY FELT LIKE THEY
WERE VERY FORTUITOUS AND I CAN
LET HER DESCRIBE THE EXACT
CIRCUMSTANCES LATER IN FINDING
ABOUT THAT OUT ABOUT THIS BILL
AS EARLY AS THEY DID- EVEN THAT
THAT BEINGSAID THEY THEY FELT
LIKE THEY COULD HAVE ACTUALLY
GOTTEN NOTICE MANY HOURS
EARLIER- THAT THE U. S. COAST
GUARD. HAD KNOWN ABOUT IT
EARLIER THAN WAS COMMUNICATED
HUNTINGTON BEACH- THEY ALSO SHE
ALSO EXPRESSED TO ME THAT. THEY
HAD A LOT OF EQUIPMENT BECAUSE
THEY HAD HAD A CARGO ACCIDENT A
CARGO SHIP ACCIDENT ACCIDENT
OFF THE COAST OF HUNTING BEACH-
LIKE MAYBE NINE MONTHS EARLIER
AND SO THEY- IN RESPONSE TO
THAT HAD GOTTEN A LOT OF
EQUIPMENT THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
IN AN INSTANCE LIKE THIS SO- H.
B. WAS WAS PARTICULARLY WELL
PREPARED WHAT WAS- I GUESS
NOTICED EARLIER THAN MIGHT HAVE
BEEN THE CASE OTHERWISE BUT- IT
THINKING ABOUT THIS GOING
FORWARD WOULD IT MAKE MORE
SENSE TO HAVE SOME KIND OF A-
FORMAL NOTIFICATION PROCESS. SO
THAT AS SOON AS THE U. S. COAST
GUARD FINDS OUT ABOUT SOMETHING
LIKE THIS THAT THEY'RE
COMMUNICATING IT TO- THE
AFFECTED LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AND AS WELL AS A COUNTY- SO
THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO RESPOND.
QUICKLY BECAUSE OURS OBVIOUSLY
MATTER IN AN INSTANCE LIKE THIS
AND THEN AS A SECONDARY
QUESTION. ARM WOULD BE HELPFUL
TO THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW HAVING
REGIONAL SITES OR REGIONAL
COLLECTIVE STATE TO GATHER SOME
OF THE EQUIPMENT THAT MIGHT BE.
USEFUL IN RESPONSE. TO THESE
TYPES OF SPILLS OR EVENTS. I
ANSWERED YES AND YES. SO ON THE
ROAD NO. DINA ONE OF THE THINGS
I PERSONALLY WANNA. BE INVOLVED
IN AND UTILIZE THE ASSESSMENT
FOR. IS THAT WHICH MOMENTS WAS
NOTIFICATION GOING WHERE IN
WHAT NOTIFICATION SYSTEM. AND
THEN BASED ON MY BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT ACROSS
THE SUITE OF INFORMATION CHAINS
ASK OURSELVES COLLECTIVELY AS
SHOULD WE ALL TAKE A LOOK AT
HOW NOTIFICATIONS HANDLED I
MEAN WE DO HAVE A NATIONAL
RESPONSE CENTER. BUT YOU KNOW
YOU'VE GOT COMMUNICATIONS GOING
ALL OVER THE PLACE AND I THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE- ASSESS
COLLECTIVELY IS THERE A SMARTER
WAY TO HANDLE OR IMPROVE UPON
NOTIFICATIONS EVERY HOUR DOES
MATTER. MY SECOND ANSWER YES ON
REGIONAL COLLECTIVES IS IN PART
BECAUSE IT KIND OF HAPPENS NOW
LAST FOR THE ADMINISTRATOR TO
WEIGH IN. ARE THE- CONTINGENCY
PLANS YOU SAW IN THE EARLIER
SLIDE IS THAT IDENTIFICATION IN
ADVANCE OF THE MOST SENSITIVE
WETLANDS AND OTHER SITES. IN
THE PLACES WHERE LOCALIZED
EQUIPMENT IS ALREADY PRE
COLLECTED. HOWEVER I THINK WE
CAN LOOK AT THAT AGAIN AND ASK
YOU FOR PUTTING ENOUGH WEAPONS
IN THE RIGHT PLACES EARLY
ENOUGH BEFORE EVENTS. TIME YOU
WANT TO WEIGH IN ON EITHER OF
THESE SHORT TRUCK AS WELL WELL
GO FIGURE LAST COMING AND THEN.
THE EARLIER ONE SO WITH A LOCAL
EQUIPMENT WE HAVE A GRANT
PROGRAM WHERE WE- AND THIS IS I
THINK CENTER WHAT YOU REFER TO
WIN SEATS ON EXERCISE OF
ROLLING OUT EQUIPMENT. THE END
AND EVALUATING IT SO WE PROVIDE
TRAILERS AND BOOM TO BOMB MANY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND WE CAN LOOK AT
ENHANCING THAT PROGRAM EVEN
MORE IT'S VERY SUCCESSFUL AND
THEY ARE OF COURSE REPOSITION
IN AREAS WHERE THERE ARE SOME
SOME SITES- AND DOG THING GOING
BACK TO NOTIFICATIONS- SO WHEN.
I FIRST. HEARD ABOUT. OFF EVENT
THAT SATURDAY MORNING DISSECT.
I AM USUALLY A AT MY I PAD AT
PULLS ON. WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
SURFACE WATERS AS BEST
SELECTIVITY AND ALSO ANOTHER
APP THAT YOU'RE ACTIVELY- I
NOTICED THAT THERE WERE SEVERAL
AIRCRAFT THEY WERE ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE OUTLOOK-
HELICOPTERS DOING CIRCLES ALL
SORTS RIGHT NOW IDEA OF WHERE.
THIS WAS HAPPENING BUT I WAS
ALSO TAKEN ABACK WITH HOW MANY
VESSELS WERE LINED UP CLOSE TO
THE SHORELINE AND I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT THE TIME THAT THERE WAS A
MAJOR AIR SHOW SCHEDULED FOR
THAT WEEKEND. AND MY IMMEDIATE
THOUGHTS WERE OH MY GOSH. WHAT
IF ALL THESE VESSELS START
GOING IN COLLECTING OIL ON
THEIR HOLES AND CARRYING IT
BACK TO THEIR- HOME PORTS AND
HARBORS AND MARINAS. AND ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY THAT DAY I CAN'T
TELL YOU EXACTLY WHEN IT
HAPPENED BUT ALTHOUGH THE COAST
GUARD STARTED ISSUING POSSIBLY
CALLED- URGENT MARINE FOR
BROADCAST NOTICE TO MARINERS.
ON VHF CHANNEL SIXTEEN. AND. IN
FACT- THEY CANCELED DAY OF THAT
IS SO- I KNOW WAS A- IMPACT TO
HELLO KIND OF BUT IT WAS THE
RIGHT IN THE IMPORTANT THING TO
DO TO MINIMIZE. THE- THE
TRANSPORT OF SOME THAT OIL- IN
FACT WE OVERHEARD SOME MOST
BROADCAST BE MADE AS WE FLEW
OVER SO. THESE ARE ALL GONNA BE
PARTS OF NOT ONLY OUR INTERNAL
ABSTRACTS RECORD BUT ALSO THE
INVESTIGATION LOOKING AT. WHEN
VARIOUS ENTITIES WERE MADE
AWARE OF THIS AND THE
SUBSEQUENT ACTIONS THAT WERE
MADE. THAT IN TURN ALERTED THE
PUBLIC. BUT IT. MY FINAL- AND
THEN YOU GET AGAIN FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- AT THIS POINT DO WE
HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF THE ALL IN
LIKELY COSTS OF THE SPILL BOTH
ECONOMICALLY AND THEN. TAKE
CENTRE CERTAIN NON ECONOMIC
DAMAGES WHERE I IMAGINE- HOW
LONG WILL THE DAMAGE CONTINUOUS
AND WHAT'S WHAT'S THE TIME LINE
GOING FORWARD AND WHAT'S ALL IN
COSTS GOING TO BE. I WOULD I'M
NOT GONNA. PREDICT THE ALL IN
COST I PERSONALLY DON'T HAVE A
REALLY GOOD FEEL FOR THAT AND
OF COURSE YOU CAN'T. EVER PUT A
VALUE ON THE- LOTS OF PART OF
NATURE. AND I WILL JUST GIVE
YOU A REFERENCE CENTER AND
AGAIN. EVERY SPELL IS DIFFERENT
BUT IT IS RELATIVELY RECENT IN
TIME AND A WAS OF A VOLUME OF
WHAT WE THOUGHT ORIGINALLY WAS
THE WORST CASE FOR THIS
PIPELINE SPILL. THE REFUGIO
CASE- THE EVENT HAPPENED IN MAY
OF TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. AND WE
SAW THE CRIMINAL CONVICTION-
ASPECT OF THAT RESOLVED AND THE
FALL OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
SO ABOUT THREE YEARS. WE SAW
THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT
RESOLVE ALL THE CIVIL CHARGES
IN DAMAGES IN THE SPRING OF
TWENTY TWENTY SO ABOUT FIVE
YEARS LATER WITH A SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR AWARD. AND YOU
SAW OR HEARD FROM THE MINISTRY
OR THE NATURAL RESOURCE DAMAGES
CASE. RESOLVED I THINK IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND THAT WAS A
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLAR
CONSENT DECREE AWARD ON THE
NATURAL RESOURCE DAMAGES SO.
ABOUT EIGHTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. THAT'S STILL INVOLVED
A WHOLE SUITE OF CIVIL CLASS
ACTION LITIGATION WHICH I THINK
IS STILL GOING ON- AND WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN A SERIES OF CLASS
ACTION LITIGATION CONNICK
CLAIMS BROUGHT HERE AND- THE
CURRENT EVENT. SO TO THE EXTENT
ANY FAIR REFERENCE POINT YOU
KNOW BY THIS YEAR'S. AND A LOT
OF THE DYNAMICS AROUND REFUGIO
AND SOME OF ITS STILL GOING.
EVEN THANK YOU SERMON CENTER
OVER. I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU DIRECTOR BOTTOM IN
ADMINISTRATOR CALLING- I
VISITED THE COMMAND CENTER
WITHIN THIRTY SIX HOURS I THINK
OF BEING NOTIFIED DEPEND UPON
HOW ONE DETERMINES THE
NOTIFICATION AND I THINK ALL
CALIFORNIANS WOULD BE IMPRESSED
WITH THE ALACRITY AND THE
PROFESSIONALISM IN WHICH- THE
JOINT. FORCES RESPONDED IT WAS
IT WAS QUITE IMPRESSIVE. NUMBER
ONE NUMBER TWO IS I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT OU
ARE GATHERING LESSONS LEARNED
FOR AN AFTER ACTION REPORT AT
SOME POINT IN TIME. AND WHILE
IT WAS CERTAINLY IMPRESSIVE TO
ME A NO DOUBT WE CAN ALWAYS DO
THINGS BETTER IN ORDER FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO LIVE LEARN AND
PROGRESS FROM THOSE LESSONS
LEARNED- I WOULD ASK THAT IF
YOU'RE COLLECTING THESE LESSONS
AND I GET THAT THE
INVESTIGATION CONTINUES I GET
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
LITIGATION PROBABLY FOR YEARS
TO COME- BUT WE ARE TASKED WITH
THE RESPONSIBILITY AS A CITY
OUTSIDE THE- ULTIMATE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR. HOW ALL OF
THESE BILLS ARE PREVENTED AND
HOW THEY CONTAINED AND HOW THEY
CLEAN UP THAT IF YOU COULD GIVE
US- IT MAY BE YOUR PRELIMINARY
THOUGHTS BUT YOUR PRELIMINARY
THOUGHTS BY. JANUARY AND I
WOULD SUGGEST I'M PULLING THE
STATES SOMEONE EARLIER JANUARY
SEVEN SO THAT THAT WE CAN BEGN
TO START TO. THINK ABOUT. BASED
ON WHAT YOUR EXPERIENCE HAS
BEEN AND HOW WE CAN DO THINGS
BETTER- SO LET ME LET ME ASK
BOTH OF YOU TO RESPOND TO IT
AND I GET. THAT THINGS WON'T BE
RESOLVED I GET THAT ALL
INFORMATION WILL BE GATHERED I
GET THAT. THE INVESTIGATION
WILL BE EXACTLY COMPLETE SO LET
ME START WITH YOU DIRECTOR
BOTTLE. SO SENATOR I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LONG COMMITMENT TO.
PUBLIC SERVICE AND I KNOW THAT
YOU ARE A MORE QUALIFIED
PROSECUTOR THAN I WILL EVER BE.
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT- SET UP
YES I WOULD OFFER YOU MY
PERSONAL WORD. THAT BETWEEN NOW
AND THE BEGINNING IN JANUARY
WE'D LIKE A CHANCE TO REFLECT
ON SOME OF OUR INITIAL
IMPRESSIONS. I THINK THROUGH
WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN IMPROVE
AND THEN COME BACK FOR A
CONVERSATION WITH LEADERSHIP IN
THE LEGISLATURE I. HOPE IN THE
TIME THAT I'VE BEEN DIRECTOR
THAT KIND OF OPEN DOOR POLICY
TO BE BETTER. IS A RELATIONSHIP
I'VE ESTABLISHED WITH MANY OF
YOU IN THOSE A FEW I DON'T KNOW
YET I THINK THIS BILL- IS A
PLACE IN WHICH I'D LIKE TO EARN
THAT TRUST. SO LET LET ME JUST
ASK A FOLLOW ON IT THEN I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU SAID BUT-
IF YOU COULD. LET US KNOW-
WHATEVER IT IS WE CAN COME
TOGETHER WHETHER IT'S BY JUNE
WE SEVEN OR JANUARY. FOURTEENTH
BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO DO THIS AT
LEAST I WOULD LIKE TO DO THIS
EARLY ON SO THAT WE CAN-
OPERATIONALIZE SOME SOME
LESSONS THAT HAVE BEEN LEARNED.
YES AND I THINK- STAYS APPROACH
WOULD BE PRUDENT. WE PROBABLY
WILL HAVE SOME INITIAL IDEAS WE
MAY HAVE BETTER IDEAS IN THE
SUBSEQUENT PHASES WE GO THROUGH
THE ENTIRE ASSESSMENT TIMELINE.
OR ANYTHING THANK YOU OF MR
CALL. THANK YOU SENATOR I
COULDN'T ADD ANYTHING MORE TO
WHAT THE- THE DIRECTOR SAID YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE- VERY
INTERESTED IN PROCEEDING
SMARTLY ON ON TRYING TO
IDENTIFY THOSE. THOSE ERRORS WE
CAN DO BETTER AND WE'LL HAVE
SOMETHING. FOR YOU BY JANUARY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND THEN
LASTLY AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT THERE'S- VARIOUS LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT- IN RESTORATION
THAT- ARE ENGAGED IN NEED TO BE
ENGAGED AND WILL BE ENGAGED. TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOUR
SUGGESTIONS- REFLECT UPON
THINGS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
COULD DO BETTER- WE WOULD
WELCOME THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE
TELEPHONES HERE AND WE SEE- VIA
EMAIL AND WE CAN COMMUNICATE
WITH OUR FEDERAL COLLEAGUES SO
THAT THAT WOULD BE. THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL THANK YOU INSTEAD OF
INSTEAD. THE GREAT THANK
CENTERBRIDGE CENTER THERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND- THANKS TO BOTH OF
YOU FOR INCREDIBLY
COMPREHENSIVE- PRESENTATION AND
I THINK I APPRECIATE AS WELL
THE CENTER I'M BURKE SAID THE
FACT THAT THEY'RE STILL MMHM SO
MANY MOVING PIECES IN EITHER
THE INVESTIGATION OF THE FOLLOW
UP THAT IT'S HARD TO ANSWER
CERTAIN THINGS NOW ADD OVER ONE
MORNING MOST OF THE THINGS I
WAS GONNA ASK BEEN ASKED BUT
THERE ARE FEW RESIDUAL ONCE AND
SO LET ME. JUST ASK AND- IT
ADMINISTRATOR COLIN POWELL ONE
THING YOU SAID IS THAT EVERY
THREE YEARS THERE'S A
TECHNOLOGY CONFERENCE IN THERE
TO LOOK OUT FOR THE UPDATE AND
AT THE LAST ONE WAS IN FEBRUARY
OF THIS YEAR- DID YOU FEEL IT'S
ALWAYS WHEN YOU HAVE A REAL
SITUATION IT RAISES QUESTIONS
THAT THAT IN THE ABSTRACT
WORKED OUT WITH DO YOU THINK
YOU WANNA. STEP UP TO THE NEXT
ONE TO USE SOME LESSONS FROM
THIS TO DECIDE IF THERE'S
TECHNOLOGY THINGS THAT MIGHT
ADDRESS THE SITUATIONS. BETTER
FROM WHAT YOU'VE LEARNED HERE.
THANK YOU SIR EARLIER IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU AGAIN AND IT'S
ACTUALLY EVERY TWO YEARS EVERY-
OTHER FEBRUARY- BUT THE VALUE
THAT WE CAME. FROM THAT ARM.
GROUP IT COMES TOGETHER
INSURANCE TECHNOLOGIES AND YOU
WOULDN'T THINK THAT THERE COULD
BE THAT MANY EMERGING.
KRUGMAN'S AND SAY CONTAINMENT
OR- OR SORTED SET ABSORBED OIL
BUT I'M ALWAYS IMPRESSED WITH
HOW MUCH IS INVOLVING IN.
REMOTE TECHNOLOGY IN OUR
COMMUNICATIONS AND BEYOND WITH
SAND AND SO FORTH AND SO I AM
GOING TO TAKE YOU BACK ON TO MY
TEAM AND I THINK CERTAINLY
GIVEN THIS TO THIS EVENT WE
PROBABLY SHOULD HOLD ANOTHER
ONE SOONER AND WE WOULD
PROBABLY BE WELL SERVED TO LOOK
AT AN ANNUAL LIST POSTED BY
DANIEL. GRAHAM THANK YOU AFTER
THAT THAT'S REALLY RESPONSIVE
AND THEN ARE PROBABLY
CONTINUING WITH YOU. BOB WE HAD
THE REFUGIO PIPELINE THING AND
THEN AS A RESULT THERE WAS SOME
LEGISLATION THAT CAME OUT OF IT
IN CENTER REALLY MOUNTED A BILL
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THAT REALLY
SAID IN THE EVENT OF AN OIL
SPILL SOME OF THE AGENCIES
WOULD BE REQUESTED TO DO PIECES
OF THE OF THE NATURAL RESOURCE
DAMAGE ASSESSMENT TO AN ART D.
A. THAT YOU REFERRED TO AND TO
BE HONEST THE BOXES IN THE
PRINT WERE SO SMALL I COULD SEE
IF MY QUESTION WAS ANSWERED.
BUT I KNOW THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND I THINK IF IT'S
IN THE BAY THE B. C. DC WERE
REQUIRED TO DO. A PIECE OF THAT
REPORT IN A WRITTEN ASSESSMENT
OF THE EXTENT VALUE AND LEVEL
OF DAMAGE OR INJURY HAVE THEY
BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS RESPONSE
AND ARE THEY WORKING ON THAT
PIECE OF THE. AND- R. DA. I'M
SORRY FIND MY BUTTON HERE- SO
OBVIOUSLY BASED ON DC DC WOULD
BE INVOLVED IN THIS RESPONSE
OUR COASTAL COMMISSION HAS BEEN
A PART OF OUR- INITIALLY DAILY
AND NOW I'M BI WEEKLY. AGENCY
CALLS ON THE I THINK IT WAS
SENT BILL FOR FOURTEEN IF
MEMORY SERVES WAS. INITIALLY
AFTER REFUGIO THAT ON THAT ASK
FOR MANY THINGS TO BE DONE-
AND- ONE OF THOSE WAS A- AN
EVALUATION ARE FIVE MAJOR
COURTS SO THAT WOULD BE OUR
HUMBLE THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY.
ON A PORT WHEN AMY SAN DIEGO
AND LA L. B. OF- OFFSHORE
TOWING CAPABILITIES FOR THEIR
ADDRESS WILL BECOME DISABLED
AND ARE WHAT WOULD BE THE
ORGANIC- HEAVY TOWING. R. K. W.
VESSELS TO GO OUT. AND. I
BELIEVE THAT THE- LL BE SEXIST
INTO DIEGO ARE AND ON A STILL I
BELIEVE. FOR COURT WILL NEED ME
AND- AND HUMBOLDT BAY- IT SAID
EARLIER SO ONE OF MY FIRST
PHONE CALLS. IN THE BEGINNING
PART OF THIS CURRENT SPELL WAS
BOTH- TO THE CURRENT CHAIR THE
COASTAL COMMISSION AS WELL AS
ITS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR I SEE.
DOCTOR UNCLE BRIDGE HAS COME ON
THE- WHETHER HAND RAISED. WHAT
WE ALSO LEARN FROM REFUGIO
DIFFERENT FROM THIS ONE WEEK
BUT THERE WAS NO EXECUTIVE
ORDER FROM THE GOVERNOR THAT-
YOU KNOW CREATED EITHER A REAL
OR PERCEIVED IMPINGEMENT ON
COMMISSION AUTHORITIES AND
THEY'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN THIS-
PROCEEDING. AND OVER IN THE
NATURAL RESOURCE DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT WORLD. WE NEED ALL
THE EXPERT SCIENTIFIC AND
OTHERWISE WHETHER THEY'RE
ACTUALLY DESIGNATED AS TRUSTEES
OR NOT. AND THE COMMISSION IS
ADVISING IN THAT SPACE I
BELIEVE AS WELL BUT- I SURE
START I DON'T I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CALL A DOCTOR OF
THE BRIDGE OR SHE COULD
PROBABLY TAKE THIS ON OUR PANEL
AT THE END OF THE DAY RELATIVE
TO SUNDERLAND'S QUESTIONS. HERE
DR MICHAEL BRIDGET DO SEE THERE
AND WELCOME I KNOW WE HAVE YOU
SAVED FOR THE THIRD PANEL IF
YOU A BRIEF RESPONSE THAT WILL
ALLOW YOU TO WEIGH IN AND THEN
WE CAN COME BACK FOR MORE.
THOROUGH QUESTIONING AFTERWARDS.
THANK YOU SENATOR I DID JUST
WANT TO CONFIRM AND THAT WE
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THAT AND
THEN- PROCESS FROM THE
BEGINNING WE GOT A CALL
IMMEDIATELY FROM CDFW AND I'D
LIKE TO THANK DIRECTOR VON AND-
MINISTER CALLING FOR THAT- WE-
HAVE BEEN PARTICIPATING IN
MEETINGS AS- WAS MENTIONED AND
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO. ADDING
HER EXPERTISE- BOTH ON THE-
WILDLIFE RESOURCES. BECAUSE THE
RESOURCE IS RUNNING PUBLIC
ACCESS. RIGHT THANK YOU MR THAT
WAS RESPONSIVE AND THEN TWO
MORE QUESTIONS AND LET ME GO. I
CAN'T REMEMBER WHO SAID IT BUT
SOMEBODY WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
BOYS SYSTEM AND WE HAD A BUDGET
ITEMS THIS YEAR. OF ABOUT STATE
POLICE THAT WERE IN DANGER OF
CONTINUING. AND WAS THERE
ANYTHING WITH REGARD TO THE
BELIEF SYSTEM THAT WAS A ST
LOUIS OR WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
AT RISK WE SHOULD FOLLOW UP ON
AN ORDER OF PROCESSES NEXT YEAR.
SEVERAL THAT I'M NOT. REALLY
BEST POSITION ON THAT IT CAME
UP I THINK IN ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS FROM EITHER SENATOR
MAN OR CENTER STAR JUST ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY OFF SHORE- BUT I
PERSONALLY AM REALLY NOT
TRACKING THE BILLY DYNAMIC- SO
WE WOULD BE GLAD TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOUR OFFICE. AFTER WE GET
A CHANCE TO REFLECT ON THAT
ASPECT R. ONE JURY JUST YOUR
COMMENT THAT YOU'RE NOT
PERSONALLY FOLLOWING UP WITH
THE BULLY DYNAMIC AND- WE WILL
GO WITH THAT N. LET'S FOLLOW UP
BEFORE NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET LAST
QUESTION. HAS BEEN ASKED IN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS AND
JUST HASN'T BEEN ASKED THIS
WAY. AND SO LET ME ASK BOTH OF
YOU WAS THERE ANY TOOL THAT YOU
WISH YOU HAD THIS RESPONSE THAT
THUS FAR YOU'VE ASCERTAINED YOU
DIDN'T HAVE THAT- MIGHT BE OF
ASSISTANCE TO YOU. A
LEGISLATIVELY BUDGETARY OR
OTHERWISE ONE FOR ME. AND THIS
IS IN THE SPIRIT F CANDOR. I
THINK THE RESPONSE. AND THIS IS
MY VIEW HAD CHALLENGES AND THAT
FIRST TEN DAYS. FINDING A HOME
FOR THE RESPONSE WHERE COULD
YOU PUT THE AND THEN FIFTY TONS
FOUR HUNDRED PEOPLE. IN THE
COMMAND I DON'T THINK IT WORKS
FOR THE PUBLIC TRUSTS TO HOW'S
THAT AND JUST SO THESE THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTY NO OFFENSE TO ANYONE'S
RESPONSIBLE PARTY. AND I THINK
WE CAN FIGURE OUT BEFORE SPELLS
WHERE MIGHT BE. READILY
ACCESSIBLE BY PUBLIC SPACE FOR
A COMMAND TO POSITION ITSELF
AND THAT WOULD HAVE SET ASIDE A
HECK OF A LOT OF HASSLE AND
THERE'S STILL. THEN IT MIGHT BE
GOOD. IN THE TIME WE HAVE TO
REFLECT. THAT IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROPOSALS ON THAT THAT WE COULD
WORK WITH THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. TO THE RESPONDING TEAM
THAT WE DO THAT AND I
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE IT IT MAKES
SENSE TO ME THAT EVEN IF THE-
RESPONSIBLE PARTY IS- IT IS.
NOT REALLY EVENTUALLY AT FAULT
IN SOME WAY IT IT APPEARS TO
TAKE TO THE RESPONSE IF THAT'S
WHAT COMES OUT OF FRONT. AND SO
PLEASE OUR WORK WITH US IN A-
AND ONE THING TO MENTION- I
MEANT TO MENTION IN THE OPENING
STATEMENT- I DID A BILL WHEN I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY BECAUSE
THERE WAS ORIGINALLY AN OIL
SPILL RESPONSE LEGISLATION. OF
THE FIRST 50% OF THE RESPONSE
WOULD BE PAID FOR JUST RIGHT
OUT OF THE POCKETS AND THEN THE
SECOND FIFTY PERCENT. WOULD BE
PAID FOR BY THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTY EVEN THOUGH THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY MIGHT NOT
HAVE BEEN DETERMINED TO THAT.
IN IT WAS POTENTIALLY HAMPERING
THE RESPONSE. TO BUILD THESE
WHERE THEY WERE BUT SAID THAT
THE STATE WOULD STEP UP AND NOT
LET ANY ARBITRAGE WILL BURY OR-
DELAY OR IMPINGE THE RESPONSE.
OKAY AND I THINK THAT THERE'S
JUST BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE- THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTY AND HOW IT
FITS AND HOW IT ALL WORKS AND
ANIMAL WAS JUST IN THE ANSWER
BOX OR TIES TO THAT SO- AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU DON'T WANT TO
LEGISLATE EVERYTHING. BUT IT
WOULD BE NICE TO FACILITATE
ASSISTANCE SO THAT YOU'RE NOT
IN THE MOMENT APPEARING TO ME
MAKING A DECISION THAT REFLECTS
ON SOMEBODY ELSE AND IF WE CAN
MAKE A DECISION THAT USES THAT.
ARE THEN OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS THAT'S WHAT WOULD BE
GOOD TO GET FEEDBACK ON SO THAT
WE CAN ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR
CONCERN. I THANK THE WITNESSES
AND I REALLY THANK THE CHAIR
FOR THE INDULGENCE OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK VERY THOROUGH
QUESTIONING AND APPRECIATE ALL
THE INCREASE I GUESS I WOULD
JUST ADD TO WRAP THIS UP- IN
THAT- WHAT WE'RE CALLING I
GUESS A FEAST- BIT OF
ASSESSMENT- OF SELF ASSESSMENT
THAT WE'RE LOOK WILL BE LOOKING
FOR IN JANUARY. I WOULD ALSO
OFFER- AS SOME KIND OF REVIEW
IN TERMS OF THE ADEQUACY OF
THE- OF THE OSCAR FEE- I
BELIEVE WE INDEXED IT AT EIGHT
AND HAVE SINCE- IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- ON A PER BARREL FEE SO
EIGHT TO HALF CENTS PER BARREL
AND THERE'S A CAP AT THIS POINT
OF FIFTY FIVE MILLION. HI HEY I
DID NOT GET A SENSE AT ALL FROM
THE COAST GUARD THAT THEY WERE
SPARING ANY EXPENSE AND WERE
QUITE VIGILANT AND THROWING IN
THEIR LEADERSHIP OF THE UNIFIED
COMMAND. BUT BUT I AT THE YOU
KNOW IN THIS CASE THE RATE OF
RELEASE- WASN'T NEARLY AS BAD
AS WE EXPECTED AND YOU KNOW
BACK IN THE ENVELOPE MATH IF WE
HAD A MORE THAN JUST THAT
THIRTEEN INTERLINE FRACTURE
THAT BAD DAY WHENEVER THIS
HAPPENED- AND IF WE HAD BEEN AT
THE RATE SAY OF HORIZON. AT THE
BP SPILL- WHICH IS POSSIBLE
STILL IN OUR OFFSHORE WATERS-
IS OUR CURRENT FUNDING LEVELS
SUFFICIENT TO COVER THE SCOPE
OF THAT SORT OF WORST CASE
SCENARIO- WE MAY HAVE HAD SOME.
SOME LUCK ON OUR SIDE SOME
WEATHER ON OUR SIDE SOME OTHER
THINGS WORKING IN OUR FAVOR IN
ADDITION TO A LOT OF SWEAT AND
HARD WORKING COORDINATION BUT I
WOULDN'T EVEN IF YOU DON'T HAVE
A IMMEDIATE REACTION TO THAT I
WOULD. I WOULD ASK THAT- YOU'LL
TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT AND
YOU'RE SORT OF PHASE. ONE OF
THIS INTERFACE HERE. WE WILL
LOOK AT THAT. THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH- WILL WRAP UP
THIS PANEL THEN AND- THANK YOU
BOTH FOR. YOUR WORK AND MOVE ON
WITH- OUR STAKEHOLDER
PERSPECTIVES- SO I SEE WE HAVE
MAYOR KERR HERE- AND AS WELL AS
CHAIR FLETCHER WAS INDIA COUNTY
BOARD SUPERVISORS- BRENDA WIKI
PETE STAUFFER AND ANDREA LEON
GROSSMANN- MAYOR KERR WHAT
WE'LL START WITH YOU AND I
WOULD JUST ASK WITNESSES- IF
YOU CAN LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
FIVE MINUTES I KNOW. MEMBERS
WILL HAVE I'M SURE QUESTIONS
FOR YOU IN SOME BACK AND FORTH
SO- IF YOU CAN TRY TO KEEP IT
IN THE FIVE MINUTE RANGE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. THEIR CAR
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND I JUST REALLY
WANTED TO THANK THE COMMISSION.
FOR PUTTING THIS TOGETHER AND
THE TICKET LITERALLY I WANT TO.
EXTEND MY HEARTFELT THANKS TO
SENATOR MEN AND SENATOR- BURKE
THEY HAD BEEN WITH US EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY. AND THEIR
LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN GREATLY
APPRECIATE IT SO- KNOWING THAT
I HAVE A LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME
I DO WANT TO WALK EVERYBODY
THROUGH- THE- POWER POINT
PRESENTATION THAT I HAVE FOR
YOU TODAY AND BASICALLY I JUST
WANTED TO GIVE EVERYBODY. A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF WHAT WE WERE
EXPERIENCING HERE IN HUNTINGTON
BEACH AND- AND A VERY SMALL
WINDOW SO STARTING FF ON.
SATURDAY OCTOBER SECOND IT'S
BEEN BROUGHT UP THAT YES WE DID
HAVE A VERY LARGE AIR SHOW
HAPPENING THAT DAY ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE WERE
ON THE BEACH THAT DAY. TO SEE
THE PACIFIC AIR SHOW AND AROUND
NINE O'CLOCK THAT MORNING- AND
THERE WERE C. PERSONNEL THAT
HEARD AN ANNOUNCEMENT ON VHF
CHANNEL SIXTEEN BY THE COAST
GUARD.A POSSIBLE OIL SPILL IN
THE AREA BUT NOTHING VERY
SPECIFIC AT THAT TIME NO MAJOR
DETAILS IT WASN'T ANYTHING TO
REALLY WORRY ABOUT. BY TEN
THIRTY IN THE MORNING THE COAST
GUARD HAD ADVISED US THAT THE
SPELL WAS LARGER THAN
ORIGINALLY THOUGHT. HOWEVER WE
DIDN'T HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF
INFORMATION AS TO WHERE THE
LOCATION OF THE- OF THE SPELL
WAS. NOR OF THE SCOPE OF THE
SITUATION. BY ELEVEN O'CLOCK
THAT SAME DAY THE COAST GUARD
ADVISED US THAT IT WAS NOW
GOING TO BE A MAJOR SPILL AND
THAT THE INCIDENT MANAGEMENT
TEAM WAS BEING ACTIVATED- BUT
ONCE. AGAIN NOT A WHOLE LOT OF
INFORMATION WAS GIVEN TO US
EXACTLY WHERE THE SPELL WAS THE
SIZE OF IT- BUT WE KNEW THAT
THIS WAS DEVELOPING RATHER
QUICKLY. AND AGAIN WE HAVE ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE ON
THE BEACH- DOZENS OF BOATS OUT
THERE ACTUALLY I THINK IT WAS
PROBABLY CLOSER TO A HUNDRED
BUCKS OUT WATCHING THE. AIR
SHOW THAT DAY I'M SO WE WERE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE SINCE
WE BEGIN TO. RALLY THE TROOPS
TOGETHER TO SAY LOOK IF THIS
BECOMES A REAL THING AT FOUR
O'CLOCK TODAY WE'RE GOING TO
DEPLOY A SOME OF OUR- MARINE
OIL SPILL PROTOCOLS. WHICH MAY
BE TO. PROTECT SOME OF OUR MOST
ECOLOGICALLY SENSITIVE AREAS
AND I MEAN TEN BEACH INCLUDING
THE TALBERT INLET CHANNEL WHICH
WE REFER TO AS THE TECH. THE
BOLSA CHICA WETLANDS ENTERED
SAYS NEAR THE WARNER FIRE
STATION AND THE TALBERT MARSH
WHICH IS AT THE VERY SOUTH AND-
HUNTINGTON BEACH. NEAR
BROOKHURST ST P. C. H. SO THEN
BY TWO O'CLOCK THE COAST GUARD
ADVISED THE CITY THAT. I DON'T
KNOW A THING NOT TO WORRY AND
AGAIN THIS IS NOT TO THROW
ANYBODY UNDER THE BUS BUT THIS
IS JUST REALLY AGAIN FIRST. TO
GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
IT WHAT WE COULD HAVE DONE
BETTER. AND SO AT THAT TIME AT
TWO O'CLOCK THE COAST GUARD HAD
ADVISED US THAT THE OIL SPILL
WOULD NOT BE REACHING THE
SHORES OF HUNTINGTON BEACH AND
SOME MONDAY OCTOBER FOURTH- AND
AGAIN WE DIDN'T HAVE A WHOLE
LOT OF INFORMATION AS TO. WHERE
THE SPILL WAS WE KNEW IT WAS
OFF OUR COAST AND WE DIDN'T
KNOW EXACTLY WHERE OR EXACTLY
HOW LARGE THE STILL WEST. BUT
THEN INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH. JUST
A HALF HOUR LATER. WE STARTED
TO RECEIVE MESSAGES THAT THERE
WERE BOATS THAT WERE
EXPERIENCING OIL DAMAGE JUST
OUTSIDE OF THE AIR SHOWS LIGHT
BOX. AND SO THAT BECAME A
CONCERN FOR OUR CITY SO THEN WE
ACTIVATED OUR FIRE CREWS ARE
HAS NOT SEEN OR ORAL OUR DEEP
OIL SPILL RESPONSE TRAILER. AND
STARTED TO DO THE MITIGATION.
EFFORTS UP TO TECH. THIS IS WHY
IT GETS TO ME A VERY
INTERESTING AT TWO FORTY FIVE
THE CITY WAS NOTIFIED BY THE
NEWPORT BEACH RESCUE BATTLE.
BUT THERE WERE PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS CONDUCTING OIL
SPILL CLEANUPS. OUTSIDE AT THE
AIR SHOW FLIGHT BOX. NOW AGAIN
WE WERE BEING TOLD THAT THIS
BILL WOULD NOT ARRIVE ON OUR
SHORES UNTIL MONDAY OCTOBER
FOURTH BUT THERE WAS ACTIVE WE
HAVE GOING ON AT THAT TIME AT
TWO FORTY FIVE JUST SOUTH OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH- AND SO AGAIN
THIS IS GOING TO BE. FOR FALL
DOWN BY FOUR O'CLOCK WE HAD
LAID- SOFT LOANS AT THE BOLSA
CHICA WETLANDS- AGAIN MORE
BLOOMS AT THE WARNER BRIDGE T.
C. H. ADDITIONAL BOMBS AT THE
WARNER FIRE STATION AND THEN AT
THE TOP OR MARCH. BY FOUR FORTY
FIVE- THE CITY HAD MADE A
DECISION TO CLOSE THE
HUNTINGTON BEACH BEACHES FROM
THE PIER ALL THE WAY SOUTH TO
THE RIVER JETTY AND THEN THE
STATE PARKS ALSO MADE THAT
SIMILAR CLOSURE. FOR THE STATE
PARK IN HUNTINGTON BEACH- BY
FIVE THIRTY THE STATE PARKS HAD
REPORTED THAT OIL WAS BEING
SEEN THREE HUNDRED YARDS OFF OF
THE SERVICE LINE NEAR MAGNOLIA
AND BROKERS. AND THEN AT THIS
TIME WE REACHED OUT TO SOME OF
OUR NEIGHBORING CITIES AND
AGENCIES FOR ADDITIONAL HELP
INCLUDING ANAHEIM AND ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY. BY SIX
TEN- THE CITY CONDUCTED AN
AERIAL SURVEILLANCE WITH OUR
POLICE OFF- HELICOPTERS AND WE
WERE ABLE TO DETERMINE THAT
THERE WAS AN OIL SPILL STRETCH-
FROM THE BIBLE APPEARED TO
HUNTINGTON BEACH IN NEW LYNCH
STREET- AT THAT TIME IT WAS
ESTIMATED THAT THE OIL SPILL
WAS AROUND TWO POINT EIGHT
NAUTICAL MILES OFF THE COAST
AND STRETCHED BY POINT EIGHT
NAUTICAL MILES IN LENGTH- AND
THEN. FINALLY BY SEVEN O'CLOCK
THAT EVENING AND AGAIN THIS IS
LESS THAN TWELVE HOURS OF
KNOWING THAT THERE WAS AN OIL
SPILL SOMEWHERE OFF THE COAST
OIL WAS HITTING THE SHORES AT
HUNTINGTON BEACH. AND SOI KNOW
THAT A PICTURE SPEAKS MORE THAN
A THOUSAND WORDS I WANTED TO
GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT OF WHAT
WE WERE SEEN. THIS WAS AGAIN ON
SATURDAY NIGHT ABOUT AND CLOCK
WE COULD SEE THE- COMING UP ON
THIS. OF TO. YEAH THIS IS IT
ANOTHER NIGHT TIME PICTURE OF
THAT TAR BALLS THAT WE RE
SEEING. THIS WAS THE NEXT
MORNING SATURDAY MORNING AND
YOU CAN SEE OUR ICONIC HERE
THEY ARE WITH THE OIL SHEEN.
AGAIN SOME MORE PHOTOS THAT WE
TOOK FROM OUR POLICE
HELICOPTERS. THIS IS WHAT WE
WOKE UP TO ON SATURDAY MORNING-
AGAINWE WERE HOPING TO HAVE
OUR EXCUSE ME SUNDAY MORNING WE
WERE HOPING TO HAVE A REPEAT
PERFORMANCE OF THE AIR SOW
WITH ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE ON THE BEACH BUT WE HAD
CANCELED IT THE NIGHT BEFORE.
AT AROUND ELEVEN O'CLOCK AT
NIGHT- KNOWING THAT THIS WAS.
GOING TO BE VERY IMPACTFUL- AND
I AM SURE THE DIRECTOR BONHAM
HAS SEEN THIS PICTURE A
THOUSAND TIMES. THE BIRDS THAT
THE WILDLIFE THAT WE SAW. AND
THEY HAD MORE EXAMPLES THIS IS-
SOUTH MORE THIS IS CLOSER TO
NEWPORT BEACH WHERE WE SAW THE
SOME WASHING UP ON THE SHORES.
AGAIN MORE EXAMPLES OF WHAT WE
WERE EXPERIENCING AND THEN THIS
IS- APART AND HE- TAYLOR MARSH.
AGAIN MORE WAVES COMING AND- SO
STOP SHARING MY SCREEN NOW. AND
SO BASICALLY FOR US WE I THINK
THAT THE TAKE AWAY FOR US AND
WHAT WE WERE EXPERIENCING WAS
THAT IT REALLY FOR US THE
NOTIFICATION OF SORTS THAT
WE'VE HAD SOME TIME TO REFLECT
ON THIS WHAT WE COULD HAVE DONE
BETTER WHAT WHAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN- AN OPPORTUNITY WHAT IS
PERHAPS IF THE COAST GUARD HAD
SOME SORT OF AWARENESS- THE
NIGHT BEFORE OR- TO LET US KNOW
SO WHEN AT NINE O'CLOCK. A
NOTIFICATION CAME THROUGH WE
COULD HAVE BEEN EVEN MORE
PROACTIVE BECAUSE AS IT SAID IT
BEFORE- EVERY HOUR COUNTS
DURING THE- DURING THIS CRISIS
BUT I AGAIN I JUST REALLY WANT
TO EXTEND MY HEARTFELT THANKS
TO EVERYBODY OUT THE COAST
GUARD THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
FISH AND WILDLIFE OSCAR IS
TRULY HAS BEEN AN ALL HANDS ON
DECK EXPERIENCE- WELL IT WAS
REALLY CHAOTIC FOR THE PROBABLY
THE FIRST THIRTY SIX HOURS ONCE
EVERYBODY WAS MOBILIZED AND PUT
INTO PLACE. THE RESPONSE HAS
BEEN TREMENDOUS WE WENT FROM
HAVING MAYBE A HUNDRED PEOPLE
ON THE BEACH CLEANING OUR
SHORELINES AND THEN IT QUICKLY
JUMPED TO THREE HUNDRED AND TWO
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THEN TO
FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND SO WE SAW
WHAT WAS HAPPENING AND WE WERE
ABLE TO RE OPEN OUR BEACHES
WITHIN EIGHT DAYS- FORTUNATELY
THE WATER WAS CLEAN WE WERE
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL
OF THE RESOURCES THAT WE HAD.
TO MITIGATE THE DAMAGE- THE
ALSO SHE GOT LIKE A LOGICAL
RESERVED WAS SPARED BUT TALBERT
MARSH DOES HAVE OIL DAMAGE- AND
AGAIN LOOKING BACK IF WE COULD
HAVE HAD MAYBE A FEW MORE HOURS
NOTICE WE PROBABLY COULD HAVE
MITIGATED THAT DAMAGED EVEN
MORE THAN WHAT WE DID BUT- I AM
VERY VERY GRATEFUL TO YOU IS
THIS COMMITTEE FOR TAKING SUCH
TIME AND ENERGY TO REALLY LOOK
AT. ALL. OF THE ELEMENTS THAT
WENT INTO THE HE- A HOW WE
MAYBE BETTER BECAUSE- AS
SENATOR MENDEZ. OUT IT'S NAIVE
TO THINK THAT THE SPELLS WON'T
HAPPEN AGAIN- I HOPE IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN IN YOUR BACKYARD- IT IS
INCREDIBLY PAINFUL FOR OUR
COMMUNITY TO GO THROUGH THIS.
BUT THE OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT
THAT I'VE SEEN MY RESIDENCE-
COMMIT TO HAS BEEN
OVERWHELMING. TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE JUST IN TWO DAYS WE
WERE ABLE TO RAISE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
WETLANDS AND WILDLIFE CARE
CENTER- OUR OUR RESIDENTS ARE
PASSIONATE ABOUT THEIR BEACHES-
I LIKE TO SAY THAT WE HAVE SALT
WATER THAT CONTINUALLY RUNS
THERE ARE GAMES. AND AS FAR AS
DEPICTING YOU KNOW- I KNOW THEY
CAME OUT THE WEATHER WHICH SIDE
OF THE BEACHES IS PREFERENTIAL-
BETWEEN SENATOR MEN AND
CENTERED AROUND ART I CAN TELL
YOU A LOT OF SERVERS HAVE THAT
SAME DIALOGUE WHETHER IT'S
CLIFFS DOG BEACH. NORTH SIDE OF
THE PIER SOUTH SIDE OF THE PIER
AND SENATOR LAYERED WE WILL GET
INTO WHICH SERVER CITY IS
BETTER BUT I'LL JUST SAY I MEAN
TENS. BUT NEVER THE LESS I
THINK THAT- WHAT WE CAN LEARN
FROM THIS AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO
BE EVEN BETTER- IS REALLY
REALLY VALUABLE- AND IF I HAVE
TIME I JUST WANT TO. SAY ONE
QUICK SENTENCE ARE OF LOW QUICK
STORY THAT SENATOR MAN HAD
TOUCHED UPON BEFORE AS FAR AS
BEING PREPARED AND YOU KNOW YOU
CREATE YOUR OWN LUCK AND WE
WERE VERY LUCKY WITH THIS. OUR
CITY WAS UNIQUELY PREPARED FOR
THIS- IT. IN TWENTY TWENTY WE
HAD A BOAT SINKING HUNTINGTON
HARBOR WHICH REQUIRED US TO RE
EVALUATE OUR OIL SPILL
RESPONSE. AS A DIRECTOR BONHAM
HAD MENTIONED WITH EVERY OIL
SPILL YOU GET BETTER WELL WITH
THIS PARTICULAR MANY STILL IN
OUR HUNTINGTON HARBOR WE
RECOGNIZE IS THAT WE HAD
DEFICIENCIES WITHIN OUR OWN
RESPONSE. SO OVER THE COURSE OF
THE YEAR WE DID APPLY FOR
GRANTS. AND WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THE EQUIPMENT TWO MORE READILY
RESPOND TO THE OR SPILL THAT
HAD. AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS.
BUT WE WERE HAVE THAT EQUIPMENT
IF THIS WAS A YEAR AGO WE
LITERALLY JUST GOT THAT TRAILER
AND A LOT OF THE PROTECTIVE
BONE WITHIN THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS. SO I'M GRATEFUL FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT I THINK IF
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
MORE OUTREACH TO MAKE THESE
PROGRAMS MORE READILY
AVAILABLE- SO THAT CITIES LIKE
MINE THAT. CAN PRETTY MUCH
EXPECT THAT THIS WILL HAPPEN
AGAIN WE'LL BE MORE PREPARED IN
THE FUTURE. AND WITH THAT I
WILL LET THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE A PART OF
THIS AND TO SHARE WHAT IT WAS
LIKE- RIGHT HERE IN REAL TIME
WHAT WAS HAPPENING. THANK YOU
MAYOR KERR AND- WE- LET YOU GO
OVER TIME BECAUSE WE KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN TIP OF THE SPEAR ON
THIS AND DEEPLY ENGAGED OUT
FROM THE GET GO SO. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FIRST HAND ACCOUNTS
AND ALL YOUR- YOUR BRIEF
LEADERSHIP ON BEHALF OF YOUR-
CONSTITUENTS- I SEE CHAIR
FLETCHER ON THE LINE- MISTER
CHAIR- YOU WANNA. WEIGH IN HERE
AND GIVE US A LITTLE SAN DIEGO
PERSPECTIVE ON THINGS.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING INVITING
DISRESPECT INTENDED TO GO WE'VE
GOT A OBVIOUSLY A VERY
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE IN ORANGE
COUNTY. WHILE WE WERE SEPARATED
BY DISTANCE FROM THIS BUILT. IN
BY TIME AND NOT SIGN IS WHAT
GAVE US THE- THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO REALLY START ACTIVATING
EARLY- WE ARE ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY UPON THE INITIATION
OF THE SPELLING BATTED COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES STOPPING. IN
THE UNIFIED COMMAND STRUCTURE
ALONG BEACH- WE ARE ABLE TO
CLOSELY MONITOR THE WEATHER OUT
THERE STATE THAT THE TRACKING
OF THIS DIRECTION AND NOT
HEADING UP TE SPILL. BUT WE
ALSO PUT AN EARLY REQUEST FOR
OUR MOST SENSITIVE WILL GO
INSTEAD AT THE END HABITAT
AREAS EARLY REQUEST FOR BOMBING
OFF FIVE DIFFERENT WHEEL GUNS
WE WERE ABLE TO GET BOMBS. WERE
PROTECTING SOME OF OUR MOST
VITAL WETLANDS INCLUDING. ONE
OF THE START ONLY APPLY TO WHAT
WHEN BUT IS ALSO THE INTAKE
SITE FOR DESALINATION PLANT
WHICH PROVIDES ABOUT 7% OF OUR
REGION'S WATER- AND WE'RE
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL- IT'S YOU
COAST GUARD CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE- RESPONDED VERY
QUICKLY TO OUR REQUESTS OFTEN
TWO OR PROPHYLACTIC BEFORE WE
EVEN. HAD AN AWARENESS IT WAS
HERE BUT THEY WERE WILLING TO
ENGAGE WITH US WE ACTIVATED OUR
COUNTY EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER WHICH BROUGHT IN ALL OF
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE THE
CITIES ALONG THE COASTLINE. OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS OUR STATE
PARTNERS OUR COUNTY GOVERNMENT-
AND CAN BE IN THE DAILY
TRACKING THE CALLS AND UPDATING
OUR PARTS ARE ALSO BROUGHT
TOGETHER VERY EFFECTIVELY OUR
COASTAL ELECTED OFFICIALS ALONG
WITH RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES.
AND SO IN GENERAL WHAT WE WERE
IMPACTED WITH MARBLES- WE DID
HAVE- SOME PRETTY LARGE NUMBERS
FOR US IN SAN DIEGO SIGNIFICANT
TROUBLES COME UP ON OUR
BEACHES- WE DID NOT SEE THE OIL
SHEENS ARE WE DIDN'T SEE THE
SAME. ARE DEVASTATING IMPACTS
THAT THAT ORANGE COUNTY GET-
BUT THERE ARE STILL ROCK
CONCERTS- THERE'S A REAL
CONCERN. ONGOING THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERN WINDS ARE
CERTAINLY WILL TERM CONCERNS
FOR FISHERY. OUR BEACH. CONCERN
FOR YOU OVERALL TO ECONOMY IT'S
A WHAT IT MEANS FOR OCEAN I
THINK. YOU THOUGH WE NOT SEE AS-
IMPACT IN INSTEAD COUNTY. WE
HAD ANOTHER INSTANCE OF ANOTHER
OIL SPILL OFF FORCING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONFRONT THE
REALITY OF POLLUTION IN OUR
BEACHES AND BAYS THAT SHOULD
NOT BE THERE- AND I THINK THIS
IS A POWERFUL REMINDER OF. THE
REALITY THAT THE RISK IS NEVER
BEEN BURKE. THE REWARD FOR
OFFSHORE DRILLING- AND YOU KNOW
TIME AND AGAIN WE SEE. AS LONG
AS OFF WE'RE DOING THIS ALL OUT
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO SEE.
ALL THESE TYPES OF WEEKS THESE
TYPE OF ACCIDENTS YOU START.
ACTS ARE ARE BORING LIFE. OUR
FISHERIES ON OUR ECONOMY ON OUR
BEACHES AND BAYS- AND I KNOW
THAT THERE WILL BE SOME
MECHANISM FOR REIMBURSEMENT AS.
IT RELATES TO THE FUNCTION OF
THIS. BUT I'D BE HARD PRESSED
TO SHOW YOU EVER- ECOLOGICAL
DISASTER READY ACTUAL PROPERTY
INTO T. TRULY PAID FOR THE FULL
COST OF THE RECOVERY. ARE WE
HAVE THIS ONGOING TENDENCY TO
PRIVATIZE PROFIT AND
SOCIALIZED. THE COSTS.
ASSOCIATED WITH WITH ON THAT
PROFIT GENERATING ENTERPRISE
GOES WRONG. AND SO YOU KNOW AS
WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD I'M
HOPING THIS DOESN'T BECOME
ANOTHER ANGLE ON WHAT JUST
YOUNG. DEEPWATER HORIZON EXXON
VALDEZ ON AND ON AND ON WITH
THE COMMUNITIES IMPACTED. ARE
NOT PROPERLY COMPENSATED TAKE
ACCOUNT AND THE PROFIT
GENERATED YOU GET OUR PRICE
GOES ON TO CONTINUE TO REAP.
TREMENDOUS PROFITS AT THE
EXPENSE OF OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND SO I THINK.
THAT THE UPPER YOU'RE DOING
HERE I THINK THE LEADERSHIP
THAT'S BEING SHOWN- TO REALLY
DIVE INTO THE SMALL TOWN OF
BILL IS REALLY IMPORANT I'LL
TELL. YOU MY FINAL POINT SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. ARE WE ARE A RE
DECARBONISE. PLAN TO ACHIEVE A
CARBON ZERO ECONOMY BY BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. AND A PART
OF THAT IS MOVING OFF OF THE
OIL. AND I THINK A PART OF THAT
IS GOT TO BE ASSISTED
CONTINUING EVERYTHING WE CAN'T
ALL THOSE FEDERAL LEASES
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY'RE
DISTINCT FROM STATE GOVERNMENT-
BUT YOU WANT TO FREEZE OUT OF
THESE- AND THEN AS WE DO THAT
BEING VERY MINDFUL. OF HELLO.
IT WILL IMPACT ON WORKERS AND
AS WE SEGMENT OUT OF ONE
INDUSTRY IN INTO ANOTHER DUE
DATE THAT BURDEN THAT IS ON ALL
OF US. TO ENSURE THAT THOSE ARE
GOOD JOBS GOOD MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS- SO THAT AS WE GO ON THE
PATH TO TACKLING ISSUES OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
CLIMATE CHANGE. WE ARE NOT
EXACERBATING ISSUES OF ECONOMIC
JUSTICE. THE DECLINE OF THE
MIDDLE CLASS WORKER ISSUES
REALLY PROTECTING US COULD YOU
JOB SO. AGAIN SERIOUSLY NOT
IMPACTED NEARLY AS SEVERE
ANYWAY AS FAR AS COUNTY- BUT-
YOU KNOW WE DID. HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A NUMBER OF ACTIONS WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE TROUBLES- IT
CLEAN UP TEAMS DEPLOYED ALONG
THE SHORE ONCE CLOSE TO SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. ARE RESPONDING TO
THIS MORE LIKELY TO FACE OFF
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
THANK YOU FOR USFOR LETTING ME
JOIN YOUR I LOOK. FORWARD TO
WHAT YOU'RE INTERESTED IN. IN
THANK YOU YOUR FIRST. ED AND-
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP NOT JUST ON
THE ISSUE BUT- ON. INDEED
GENERALLY ST- REMARK PRAGUE IN
THE PAST YEARS HERE- MR NO WIKI
ARE YOU WITH US I THINK WE HAVE
YOU NEXT ON THE AGENDA HERE
THAT THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
POLICY DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
DIVERSITY BRIAN THE WIKI IF
YOU'RE WITH US- PLEASE TRY I'M
HERE. WELCOME TO ME. YES ALL
RIGHT WE GOT JOB. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARES NUMBERS OF
MANY IT IS GREAT TO SEE YOU ALL
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THIS A
THOROUGH DISCUSSION RIGHT AWAY
HE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY- THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THE HEARING ON THIS.
ISSUE LIKE ALL OF YOU AT THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
ARE HEARTBROKEN BY EVERY OILED
SEABIRDS WERE ALARMED AT THE
MILES OF MARCHES AND COASTLINE
THAT WILL BE PRESENT FOR YEARS
BY THE SPELL WE WERE ANGRY THAT
YET AGAIN THE OIL INDUSTRY HAS
PROVEN ITS INABILITY TO CONTAIN
ITS TOXIC POLLUTION. THE
STRUCTURE QUITE QUITE OFTEN IN
THE FUTURE CREWS YET AGAIN THAT
EVERY PIECE OF FOSSIL FUEL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS YET ANOTHER
DISASTER WAITING TO HAPPEN. AND
THERE IS A LOT OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA.
RECENTLY OLD UPDATED IN
DISREPAIR AND POORLY LOCATED
LIKE THE FORTY YEAR OLD
PIPELINE THEY GIVE US THIS MOST
RECENT SPELL. ALL OF WHICH
MAKES IT INCREASINGLY
DANGEROUS. LOOKING BEYOND THE
NINE OIL PLATFORMS AND ISLANDS
AND STATE WATER. THERE ARE
TWENTY THREE PLATFORMS IN
FEDERAL WATERS OFF CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE FACT THAT THIS TWENTY
THREE PLATFORMS ARE A LITTLE
FARTHER FROM SHORE SHOULD NOT
GIVE US MUCH COMFORT FIRST
BECAUSE OIL SPILLS FROM THOSE
OPERATIONS STILL END UP IN OUR
WATER OUR BEACHES AND OUR
WILDLIFE. BUT ALSO AS WE'VE
HEARD TODAY FURTHER FROM SHORE.
ALSO MEANS UNDER STRETCHES OF
AGING AND DANGEROUSLY
VULNERABLE INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE
THE SEVENTEEN MILE LONG
PIPELINE WE'RE DISCUSSING TODAY.
MARK WE RELY ON FEDERAL
REGULATIONS TO PROTECT US FROM
OIL SPILLS IN FEDERAL WATERS.
FEDERAL REGULATORS CONTINUE TO
PROVE THAT THEY ARE PERFECTLY
WILLING TO ALLOW THOSE
PLATFORMS TO CONTINUE OPERATING
THE LAST DROP OF OIL. DESPITE
THE MOUNTING DANGERS OF
DECAYING INFRASTRUCTURE WELL
BEYOND ITS INTENDED LIFESPAN.
OUTDATED DRILLING PLANS
NUMEROUS VIOLATIONS AND
INSUFFICIENT FUNDS THE PAPER
DECOMMISSIONING. JUST THIS YEAR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY OFFICE ISSUED A
SCATHING REPORT BUT FEDERAL
REGULATORS LACK ROBUST SYSTEM
OF DETECTING LEAKS. FROM EIGHTY
SIX HUNDRED MILES OF ACTIVE
OFFSHORE PLATFORMS. THE ONLY
WAY TO PROTECT OURSELVES AND
OUR COAST FROM THIS DANGEROUS
ON LIVING INDUSTRY IS THAT
SHOPPERS OFFSHORE OPERATIONS
DOWN. BUT I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM
UNIQUE OFFSHORE PLATFORMS. AT
THE EXACT SAME TIME ENDS UP
THOUSANDS OF GALLONS OF OIL
WERE ROLLING UP ON COULD
BEACHES AND MARSHES. IN ORANGE
COUNTY. THERE WAS AN OIL SPILL
IN CURRENT COUNTY THAT IS NOW
APPROACHING FIVE MILLION
GALLONS OF FLUID A MIXTURE OF
CRUDE OIL. EXIT WASTE WATER
THAT INCLUDES. SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND GALLONS OF CRUDE. YEAH
IN JUST LAST YEAR. THERE HAVE
BEEN NO OIL IN HELP BRING
GREATER THAN THE STOCK I THINK
IF. IN THE SUMMER YOU KNOW THE
LOAN THERE WERE THREE HUGE
SALES IN TWENTY NINETEEN FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND GALLONS.
EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND ONE POINT TWO MILLION
GALLONS ACTIVELY. HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE THOUSAND MIDWAY TWENTY
NINETEEN TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND ETHNIC HATRED COMPLAIN
PLANNING. THERE IS ANOTHER
ONGOING. SPELL THE SEPARATOR
PLANT IN SUMMER. THAT HAS BEEN
LEAKING SINCE TWO. THREE AND IS
REPORTEDLY RELEASED AS MUCH AS
EIGHTY FOUR MILLION GALLONS OF
WITHIN DAY. BUT THESE NUMBERS
REFLECT TOTAL COMBINED VOLUMES
GREW IN PRODUCED WATER AND MUD
WHICH CONSTITUTE TOXIC MIXED.
THE STATE. AGENCIES ARE
TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THE PAST THESE
DANGEROUS ON SHORE OIL
OPERATIONS HAVE CONTAMINATED
GROUND WATER LAND WILDLIFE.
AFTER MORE THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY
YEARS OF THE AUTO INDUSTRY
DRILLING AT WILL IN CALIFORNIA
THESE YOUR LIST ON THE BOTTOM
OF THE BARREL THAT'S LEFT IS
FAR MORE DANGEROUS EXTRACT. IS
ALSO SOME OF THE MOST CARBON
POLLUTING ROUTE IN THE WORLD.
THE EASY STUFF TAKEN THE OIL
INDUSTRY IS IN DECLINE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT PRODUCTION DOWN
60% SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE.
THE ONLY QUESTION IS HOW MUCH
MORE DAMAGE WELL THIS DYING
INDUSTRY GIL ON ITS WAY OUT. WE
APPLAUD GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT OF A DRAFT
RULE THE BAND KNEW BOYLE WELLS
NEAR HOUSES AND SCHOOLS. IT'S A
GREAT STEP TOWARD PROTECTING
THOSECALIFORNIANS BURDENED
WITH SOME OF THE GREATEST
POLLUTION CALIFORNIA'S OIL
INDUSTRY. BUT THE STATE HAS
ISSUED PERMITS FOR MORE THAN.
FIVE THOUSAND WELLS IN THE PAST
TWO YEARS. FIVE OF THOSE NEW
WELLS- INTERSTATE OFFSHORE
WATERS. ALONG WITH UNDER OVER
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY ADDITIONAL
PERMITS TO REWORK WELLS IN
STATE WATERS TO KEEP THEM
GOING. THERE IS ONLY ONE
SOLUTION TO THIS MASSIVE AND
GROWING THREAT. STOPPED ISSUING
NEW PERMITS. AND REQUIRING OIL
COMPANIES T CAPTURE. CLEAN UP
AND REMEDIATE OIL SITES AS THEY
ARE LEGALLY OBLIGATED TO DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CHANCE TO SPEAK HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU MR NIKE- NEXT WE HAVE
STUFF FOR- THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION WELCOME. SHARE STERN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY MY NAME IS PETE
STOPPED WORKING I MEAN FIRE
MENTAL DIRECTOR OF SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION. THE SURFRIDER IS A
GRASSROOTS ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO THE
PROTECTION AND ENJOYMENT OF
OCEAN WAVES AND BEACHES FOR ALL
PEOPLE. THE APPLE PIE ENERGY
OIL SPILL THAT OCCURRED OFF
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA ALSO
KNOWN AS THE ANCESTRAL
HOMELANDS THE AUSSIE MEN IN
TONGA PEOPLE'S RESULTED IN A
THIRTEEN SQUARE MILE OIL SLICK.
CONTINUES TO DAMAGE THE MARINE
AND COASTAL ENVIRONMENT AS WELL
AS COMMUNITIES BUSINESSES AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AS THE
NGO LIAISON TO THE UNIFIED
COMMAND SURFRIDER HAS BEEN
DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN SUPPORTING
THE CLEAN UP AFTER. WE EXPRESS
OUR SINCERE GRATITUDE TO THE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES THE TRAIN
PROFESSIONALS AND VOLUNTEERS
WHOSE QUICK AND DECISIVE
RESPONSE HAS PREVENTED IT IT IS
ASTOR FROM BEING MUCH WORSE.
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OIL
SPILL HAS PRESENTED A TOXIC
HAZARD TO MARINE WILDLIFE AND
OCEAN HEALTH WHILE ALSO
PENETRATING TALBERT MARSH ALSO
CHICA WETLANDS AND OTHER
ECOLOGICALLY IMPORTANT
HABITATS. NOW WITH OIL DEPOSITS
SEEN AS FAR SOUTH AS THE MEXICO
BORDER THEIR CONCERNS THAT SAN
DIEGO WEAPONS. ARE ALSO BEING
IMPACTED. MOREOVER WALDBURG
FISH MARINE MAMMALS HAVE BEEN
THE MOST VISIBLY IMPACTED. THE
FULL SCALE OF THE ECOLOGICAL
DAMAGE WILL TAKE SOME TIME TO
BECOME CLEAR. IN THE WEEKS
SINCE THIS BILL OF AN OIL SLICK
IS TRANSFORMED INTO AN
INCALCULABLE NUMBER OF TAR
BALLS IN THE OCEAN. PAUL TAR
BALLS TYPICALLY FLOWS THEY CAN
ALSO FIND THEIR WAY INTO
UNDERWATER SEDIMENT OR NEAR
SHORE HABITATS WEATHER IMPACTS
ON ECOLOGICAL HEALTH AND
WILDLIFE MAY PERSIST FOR YEARS
OR EVEN DECADES. TO ASSIST WITH
THE TRACKING OF TAR BALLS
SURFRIDER LAUNCHED A SMARTPHONE
APP TO ALLOW USERS TO EASILY
SUBMIT PHOTOS INTO A CROWD
SOURCED MAP. THIS DATA IS BEING
SHARED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
TO INFORM UNIFIED COMMAND
RESPONSE. THE TOOL ALSO
PROVIDES A TANGIBLE WAY FOR
THOUSANDS OF INTERESTED
VOLUNTEERS TO SAFELY TAKE
ACTION. YES THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OIL SPILL WITH NOT
JUST AN ENVIRONMENTAL
CATASTROPHE IT WAS A HUMAN ONE
AS WELL. THIS BILL HAS CAUSED
DAMAGING IMPACTS THE
COMMUNITIES AND ECONOMY IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND BEYOND. IN
THE IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF THE
SPELL IT IS CENTRED KERR SHOW
AND THE HUNTINGTON BEACH SURF
CONTESTS EVENTS THAT DRAW ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE TO
THE COAST. OR CANCEL. IT'S
STILL ALSO RESULTED IN THE
IMMEDIATE CLOSURE OF BEACHES
HARBORS AND FISHING GROUNDS OFF
HUNTINGTON BEACH NEWPORT BEACH
LAGUNA BEACH IN DANA POINT.
THESE THESE BEACHES REMAIN
CLOSED FOR UP TO NINE DAYS
UNTIL OFFICIALS COULD CONDUCT
SUFFICIENT WATER QUALITY
MONITORING TO DETERMINE IT WAS
SAFE FOR THE PUBLIC. THE
CLOSING OF MILES OF BEACHES AND
FISHING GROUNDS HAS BEEN A
DEVASTATING BLOW TO ORANGE
COUNTY'S OCEAN RECREATION AND
TOURISM ECONOMY WHICH IS VALUED
AT MORE THAN TWO POINT SIX
BILLION ANNUALLY. ACCORDING TO
THE NATIONAL OCEAN ECONOMICS
PROGRAM. FROM RESTAURANTS AND
HOTELS TO SURF SHOPS LOCAL
BUSINESS OWNERS I FELT THE
IMMEDIATE EFFECTS OF BEACH
CLOSURES AND EVENT
CANCELLATIONS. AMONG THE
BUSINESS LEADERS WHO HAVE
SPOKEN OUT IS PAUL NOT DAY
PRESIDENT OF THE SURF INDUSTRY
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION OR
SEMA. SEMA MEMBERS COLLECTIVELY
EMPLOY OVER FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE WITH NEARLY 90% OF THE
SURF INDUSTRIES MANUFACTURES
BASED IN ORANGE COUNTY. SEND
OUT A FOLLOWING THE OIL SPILL
IS THE REST OFFSHORE DRILLING
POSES TO THE CALIFORNIA BEACH
LIFESTYLE AND MANY PEOPLE AND
BUSINESS SECTORS THAT RELY ON
IT INCLUDING TOURISM REALLY
WORTH IT. IN MY OPINION
ABSOLUTELY NOT. MEANWHILE THE
FISHERIES CLOSURES STILL
REMAINS IN EFFECT AT THE
SEAFOOD SAFETY UNIT CONTINUES
TO CONDUCT FISH SAMPLING AND
ANALYSIS. THE CLOSURE IS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED FISHING
TOUR OPERATORS ALONG WITH GAS
STOCKS THAT HAVE SEEN LARGE
DROPS IN FUEL SALES. BEASTIES
HARBOR IMPACTS HAVE ALSO
EXTENDED TO WHALE WATCH TOUR
OPERATORS AND OTHER BUSINESSES
ACCORDING TO CAPTAIN DAVE'S
DOLPHIN AND WHALE WATCHING
SAFARI LOSSES FROM TRIPS AND
BOOKINGS INTO NOVEMBER COULD BE
DOWN AS MUCH AS SEVENTY FOUR
PERCENT. BECAUSE OF THE OIL
SPILL. SADLY THIS DEVASTATING
OIL SPILL IS PART OF A LARGER
PATTERN OF OFFSHORE DRILLING
HARMING OUR COASTAL ENVIRONMENT
AND COMMUNITIES ACCORDING TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ERIC VAN
AT LEAST FORTY FOUR OIL SPILL
SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY NINE. AT
EACH RELEASED MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND BARRELS OF OIL INTO U.
S. WATERS. IT'S NO SURPRISE
THAT OFFSHORE DRILLING IS
OVERWHELMINGLY OPPOSED BY
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITIES THE
BUSINESS ALLIANCE FOR
PROTECTING THE PACIFIC COAST OR
BAIT PACK WAS FOUNDED IN ORANGE
COUNTY TO DEMONSTRATE BUSINESS
OPPOSITION TO OFFSHORE DRILLING.
JACK IS JOINED BY BUSINESS
ALLIANCES ON THE EAST COAST AND
GULF COAST COLLECTIVELY
REPRESENT MORE THAN FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND BUSINESSES. ON OCTOBER
NINETEENTH SEVENTEEN DAYS AFTER
THE SPILL BEGAN THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH PASSED A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT RESOLUTION IN
OPPOSITION TO OFFSHORE DRILLING
MARKING THE ONE HUNDREDTH LOCAL
RESOLUTION PASSED ON THE WEST
COAST. THIS SENDS A CLEAR
MESSAGE FROM COMMUNITIES
UNDERSCORES IT'S TIME FOR OUR
FEDERAL LEADERS TO PASS
LEGISLATION TO BAN NEW OFFSHORE
DRILLING. LEADERSHIP AT THE
STATE LEVEL IS ALSO CRITICAL
SPECIFICALLY STATE LEADERSHIP
IS NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE SAFE
AND SWIFT DECOMMISSIONING OF
EXISTING OIL RIGS OFF
CALIFORNIA. THE LEADERSHIP IS
ALSO NEEDED TO END OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS ON LAND AS WELL TO
PROTECT FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TO THAT. THANK YOU MR ROBERT-
NEXT WE HAVE A MUSLIM GROSSMAN
DIRECTOR OF CLIMATE ACTION FOR
US WHO ARE YOU WITH US HERE.
YES I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WELCOME. HI HELLO MY NAME IS
ANDREA LEON GROSSMANN AND THE
CLIMATE ACTION DIRECTOR WITH A
SOUL A GRASSROOTS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION WORKING TO
PROTECT OUR COASTS AND OCEAN I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR HOSTING
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING. WHEN I
ARRIVED IN HUNTINGTON BEACH ON
SUNDAY OCTOBER THIRD. I COULD
SMELL THE OIL. AND AS I GOT OUT
OF THE CARD NEXT TO THE LAGOON
I COULD SEE THE BALLOONS THAT
WERE DEPLOYED. THE HOUSE BUT
WERE CONSTRAINED TO SCAN SOME
OF THE OIL BUT THE MOST
HEARTBREAKING PART WAS WATCHING
THE FISH. AND THE FIRST LANDING
ON TOP OF THE CONTAMINATED
MARSH. AFTER SPEAKING TO THE
FIRST TV REPORTER WHO WAS THERE
REPORTING IN SPANISH. I WENT TO
THE COASTLINE TO SEE HOW BAD
THIS BILL WAS THERE. I SAW THE
TAR BALLS WASHING ASHORE
EVERYWHERE. AND THE BEACH THE
BEACH WAS NOT FULLY CLOSED.
SINCE IT WAS A SOFT SOFT
CLOSURE THERE WERE STILL
FAMILIES SPENDING THE DAY AT
THE BEACH. AND GOING INTO THE-
THE WATER. I KNEW THAT THAT
WAS- I WAS ONLY SEEING A
FRACTION OF THE OIL AS MUCH OF
THE OIL EXTRACTED IN CALIFORNIA
IS HAVING AN- ANY SINKS TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE OCEAN. MANY OF
THOSE TITLES ARE STILL WASHING
ASHORE AT THIS VERY MOMENT AND
MANY MORE WILL REMAIN AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE OCEAN POISONING
AND KILLING SEA LIFE. AND THE
TECHNIQUES WE USE TO CLEAN UP
HAVE NOT REALLY CHANGED IN
DECADES. WELL THE TREE DWELLING
AND ENHANCE RECOVERY TECHNIQUES
TO GET TO THE HYDROCARBONS ARE
EVOLVING EVERY DAY. THEY STILL
DO NOT HAVE TO HAPPEN. WE
ALREADY HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
GO A 100% RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
LEAVE THE OIL IN THE GROUND.
THIS MAN MADE DISASTER FURTHER
HURTS DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AS HE BEACH IS ONE OF THE FEW
PLACES LOW INCOME FAMILIES CAN
GO FOR FREE OR LOW COST
RECREATION. WIESER STILL
FIGHTING THE GROWING INEQUITIES
THAT THE BUTTON THAT MAKES US
SO DEEPLY EXACERBATED. AND MANY
BUILDABLE COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
HURT BY THE OIL INDUSTRY BY
ALLOWING THEM TO DRILL NEXT TO
WHERE THEY LIVE WORK OR PLAY OR
THE REFINING OR TRANSPORTATION
OPERATIONS TAKE PLACE. THIS
BILL TOOK AWAY A PLACE. TO
ACCESS NATURE AND MANY REMAIN
WORRIED ABOUT THE- ONGOING
ISSUES AT THE BEACH. WELL WE
HAVE A GREAT NEW PROPOSAL TO
STOP NEW TRAILING BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM THERE'S STILL A LOT THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE WITH EXISTING.
WELLS BOOK ON SHORE AND OFF
SHORE. THESE WELLS SHOULD HAVE
NEVER BEEN BUILT AND WE MUST BE
COMMISSIONED THEM AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE MANY CORPORATIONS KEEP
DRILLING BECAUSE THEY ELECTIONS
TOO EXPENSIVE THAT THE
COMMISSION. EVEN WHEN OIL THE
OIL THAT IS EXTRACTED IS LOW
QUALITY AND EXPENSIVE TO
REFINE. BUT THAT DISCUSSION
DOES NOT CONSIDER THE TOTAL
COST TO THE PUBLIC OF DRILLING
OPERATIONS FROM CLEAN UP COSTS
TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH COSTS ESPECIALLY
WHEN CORPORATIONS WORK HARD TO
MAXIMIZE PROFITS BY CUTTING
CORNERS EXPLOITING LOOPHOLES.
AND MANY MANY MANY END UP THE
CLAIM BACK FROM SEA TO AVOID
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SOCIALIZE
THE LOSSES THE CLEANUP. HEALTH
AND THE COMMISSIONING COSTS.
PUBLIC HEALTH MUST COME FIRST
AS WELL AS BIO DIVERSITY BUT
RIGHT NOW CORPORATE PROFITS ARE
TAKING PRIORITY AND THAT HAS
GOT TO STOP. ALEX FRACTION
REFINING AND BURNING
CONTRIBUTES TO THE CLIMATE
CRISIS AND CREATES HAS
SACRIFICED STORMS BUT LOW
INCOME PEOPLE OF COLOR NEXT.
THE OCEAN IS NOT A PROFIT
CENTER AND IT'S NOT A JOB IT'S
AN ECOSYSTEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
PROTECTED FROM DESTRUCTIVE
ECONOMY TO ENSURE THAT IT CAN
BE ENJOYED BY ALL CALIFORNIANS
FOR GENERATIONS TO COME. THE
ACTIONS THAT WE TAKE TODAY WILL
DEFINE WHAT KIND OF FUTURE WE
HAVE FOR GENERATIONS TO COME.
THE BOX UP WITH US RIGHT HERE
AND RIGHT NOW WE CAN BE AND
MUST BE PART OF THE SOLUTION.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR INVITING ME
TO BE PART OF THE SPARROW AND
I'LL TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- BUT THAT CONCLUDES OUR-
FORMAL TESTIMONY FROM ALL THE
STAKEHOLDER PERSPECTIVES-
MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE INITIAL
QUESTIONS. HER FOR ANY OF OUR
PANELISTS ARE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LEADERS OR OTHERWISE YES CENTER
AMBER ANOTHER QUESTION BUT BUT
JUST TO COMMENT WITH RESPECT
TO- AMERICORPS- CINNAMON A
NIGHT OF PERSONALLY OBSERVE MER
CARS- MARSHALLING RESOURCES
WHETHER IT WAS A QUICK MINT OR
VOLUNTEERS INEFFECTIVE
COMMUNICATION DURING THIS
CRISIS AND I WANT TO COMMEND
HER. FOR DOING SO OFTEN TIMES
THINGS CAN GET BOTH CHAOTIC AND
SOMETIMES- ACCURATE
COMMUNICATION IS A CHALLENGE
BUT I WANT T COMMEND MAYOR
KERR FOR DOING BOTH ACCURATELY
COMMUNICATING THE LEVEL OF THE
CHALLENGE. AS WELL AS
MARSHALING RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THEM SO THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
THE SENTIMENT. ARIZONA ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES' COMMENTS ON THE
LEADERSHIP OF MAYOR KERR AS
WELL AS OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
CITY COUNCIL WHO ARE NOT ABLE
TO ATTEND TODAY- AND- I KNOW
THAT ORANGE COUNTY WAS DEEPLY
INVOLVED AS WELL BUT- I GUESS
LIKE MY QUESTION FOR. REALLY
ANY OF YOU AND I THINK I THINK
THAT- P. YOU SPOKE BRIEFLY TO
THIS ON THE SOME OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE IT SEEMS
THAT- MAYBE PREMIER KERR OR
SUPERVISOR FLETCHER- IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK TO THE ECONOMIC
COSTS OF THAT YOU'VE SEEN IN
YOUR CITIES OR COUNTIES- OF THE
OIL SPILL THE SHUT DOWN OF OUR
BEACHES LHASA TOURISM I THINK
MAN KERR YOU SPOKE ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
LEAVING OBVIOUSLY THAT COSTS A
LOT OF MONEY BUT- DO WE HAVE
ANY INITIAL ESTIMATES. OF WHAT
THE COST OF THIS OIL SPILL IS
GONNA BE. WELL NOT ON THE- WHEN
IT COMES TO THE TOURISM BUT I
CAN TELL YOU I'M REALLY
GRATEFUL THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
THE SBA LOANS NOW BECAUSE WE
HAVE. AN OUTCRY AND FROM OUR
LOCAL BUSINESSES TO REALLY
STOCKED UP- THAT FOR THAT
PARTICULAR WEEKEND. WITH FOOD
SUPPLIES- LABORER TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY COULD ACCOMMODATE ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
COMING. ON AN ADDITION WE- HAVE
HEARD FEEDBACK FROM THE HOTELS.
CANCELLATIONS PEOPLE CANCEL.
THEIR TRIPS- AS WAS MENTIONED
THE FOLLOWING WEEKEND WE HAD TO
COUNSEL. OTHER EVENTS SURF
CONTEST- AND OTHERACTIVITIES
PLANNED. WE HAD A FEW DIFFERENT
PLANS AND SO ALL OF THE HOTELS-
EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT
CANCELLATIONS WITH THAT. BUT I
DON'T THINK THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FULLY SEE THE FULL ECONOMIC
IMPACT OF ALL OF THIS FOR QUITE
SOME TIME. GIVEN THAT- YOU KNOW
OUR COMMUNITY TOOK A REAL HIT
ON ITS REPUTATION. AND SO WORD
TRAVELS FAST WHEN THERE'S AN
OIL SPILL IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. PEOPLE MAY LOOK
ELSE WISE TO BOOK THEIR TRIPS
SO. IT'S GONNA BE SOMETIME AND
I KNOW HERE IN THE CITY WE ARE-
KEEPING RECEIPTS FOR EVERYTHING
THAT WE'VE SPENT SO FAR. I KNOW
WITHIN THE FIRST WEEK WE HAD
SPENT OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON. THE
RESPONSE TO THE OIL SPILL SO I
KNOW THOSE NUMBERS KEEP. ADDING
UP IT. IT'LL BE SOME TIME
BEFORE WE SEE THE FULL IMPACT
AND HAVE YOUR HOTEL I MEAN I
KNOW THE BEACHES ARE REOPENED
AND I UNDERSTAND THINGS COULD
BE BACK TO NORMAL. ARE YOU
SAYING HOTELS BACK TO CAPACITY
AND NORMAL SEASONAL LEVELS OR
ARE YOU STILL EXPERIENCING SOME
KIND OF A DROP OFF TO THE
HOSPITAL NOW THERE THERE'S
DEFINITELY BEEN A DROP OFF- AND
IT IS THAT TIME OF THE YEAR
WHEN THINGS DO YOU TYPICALLY
DROP OFF BUT- WE CERTAINLY TOOK
A HIT. FROM THIS OIL SPELL IT'S
LOWER THAN NORMAL AND JUST A
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO BUT- THE TOT TAX.
ANOTHER TAX REVENUES THAT
YOU'RE LOSING- IS THAT IS
THAT'S- FROM THE LEVEL THERE'S-
PARTY. THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
AND I HOPE THAT IT IS- BUT JUST
TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF HOW MUCH
T. O. T. WE DO RECEIVE AND
HUNTINGTON BEACH WE RECEIVE
ABOUT SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR- WE DON'T RECEIVE ANYTHING
FROM THOSE. OFF SHORE
PLATFORMS. I THINK I'M GONNA
START IS THE DRILLING THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE HERE IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH IT'S LESS THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR SO EVEN THOUGHOUR
MASCOT AT THE HUNTINGTON BEACH
HIGH SCHOOL AS THE OILERS THIS
TOWN HAS REALLY PIVOTED FROM
BEING AN OIL BOOMTOWN WHERE
MUCH MORE OF A TOURIST TOWN WE
RELY ON VISITORS COMING TO AN
AGENT BEACH- IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF OUR GENERAL
FUND. SO- MAKE A FRIENDLY
SUGGESTION PERHAPS YOU MIGHT
CHANGE THE MASCOT OF THE
SERVICE. IT HAS BEEN. BEEN
SUGGESTED THANK YOU SENATOR
ANYWAYS- INTENSIVE RISER
FLETCHER AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
SIMILAR COMMENTS I KNOW THAT
YOUR COUNTY WAS NOT HIT AS HARD
AND I THINK REPUTATION HE
PROBABLY WAS NOT AS AFFECTED
BUT IF YOU HAVE ANY.
OBSERVATIONS ON ANY ECONOMIC
IMPACT- BEFORE THE COUNTY I'D
BE INTERESTED IN THAT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR MEANT FOR
THE QUESTION AGAIN WE WERE NOT
IMPACTED NEARLY AS EARLY ON ANY
ORDER BACK TO THE STORE. AS
WHAT FOLKS IN ORANGE COUNTY
EXPERIENCE. BUT IT'S NOT
POSSIBLE. THERE'S NOTHING
POSITIVE THAT COMES OUT OF THIS
FOR ANY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY. AND SO YOU KNOW
WE'LL HAVE SOME MODEST COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ACTIVATING
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER
WITH STAFF BEING. IS OBVIOUSLY
SOME CROSSING COURT BY STATE
AGENCIES AND OTHERS FOR THE
DEPLOYMENT OF BONES THE CLEANUP
TEAMS WERE DOWN HERE. BUT AGAIN
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE YOUR
YOUR BEST BEACH. ARE YOUR
BEACHES THAT PEOPLE TRAVEL FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD TO COME AND
WHILE WE ARE. IN CARLSBAD AND
ITS NEED IT'S UNTIL MARCH I DID
IT BETTER ARE NATIONALLY
BROADCAST WITH HARDBALL'S
WASHING UP ON THE SHORE- THAT
THAT DOES NOT HELP. IT DOESN'T
HELP AT ALL AND SO I THINK AND
THAT DOESN'T EVEN TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. ON KNOWN LONGER TERM
DAMAGE OFF WORK MARINE LIFE FOR
HABITATS FOR ALL THOSE OTHER
THINGS THAT ARE THERE AND SO
IT'S JUST AN INDUSTRY WHERE.
FROM A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
STANDPOINT THERE IS NOTHING
POSITIVE. ARE THERE WE EVER
GET. OUT OF THE OFFSHORE OIL
INDUSTRY IT IS ONLY NOW. AND IT
ALWAYS TENDS TO COME OUT SO
AGAIN NO WHERE NEAR WHAT ARE
FOLKS OR SHOUTING WENT THROUGH-
AND THE WAY THEY- REACTED AND
DEALT WITH THIS IS ADMIRABLE
AND REALLY TO BE COMMENDED- BUT
BUT CERTAINLY NOTHING NOTHING
POSITIVE CAN COME TO SAN DIEGO
BECAUSE OF THIS. THANK YOU
ROGER AND THEN FOR A MISTER
NOBODY MISTER STUFFER AND
MOSTLY GROSSMANN- I ACTUALLY
LET ME LET ME JUST ONE MOMENT
MR NO WIKI- IF YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THE ECOLOGICAL
IMPACTS. ARE BASED ON OUR
EXPERIENCES WITH VERY REFUGIO
OR. OR OTHERWISE I MEAN HOW.
WHAT DO WE KNOW YET WE HAVE A
SENSE OF HOW BAD THIS WILL BE-
AS FAR AS THE BIO. ENVIRONMENT
IMPACTS. NO I'M DEFINITELY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
QUESTION AND IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S
CRITICAL- THAT THESE IMPACTS.
IN MY **** FOR YEARS BUT I NEED
TO REMIND OTHER. I COLLEAGUES
HERE THAT OTHER FOLKS ON THIS
CALL BECAUSE- I'M LOOKING AT
THIS VERY MUCH FROM THE STATE
LEVEL AND WAS NOT ON THE GROUND
BUT I CAN'T SAY THOUGH. FOR
SURE IS THAT IS GOING TO TAKE
LONGER THAN ONE SEASON TO SEE
WHAT THE FULL IMPACT ARE YOU
THE LOCAL WILDLIFE AND OF
COURSE. IT IS WETLANDS AND
MARSHES BUT OFTEN ARE THE MOST
DIFFICULT AND TAKE THE LONGEST
TO RECOVER FROM THE START OF
IMPACTS BUT- BUT I AS FAR AS
THE SPECIFICS OF THIS SO NOW I
HAVE TO DEFER TO OTHERS IRAN IS
A MAJOR KERR REFERRED TO WE
HAVE A SERIES OF- SOMEWHAT
CONNECTED- PRESERVES- IN
NEWPORT BEACH AND- HUNTINGTON
BEACH THAT YOU KNOW WE'LL HAVE
TO SEE IF YOU SET THE
SUGGESTION IS THAT OKAY. I
GUESS MY LAST QUESTION FOR MR
STAFFERS- HAVE WE SEEN ANY KIND
OF RELUCTANCE BY SURFERS TO GET
BACK INTO THE WATER- BECAUSE OF
THE OIL SPILLS WHAT SORT OF
YOUR OBSERVATION. ON THE IMPACT
ON THE SURFING COMMUNITY. YEAH
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- CENTER
MAN I MEAN THERE'S BEEN- WE'VE
BEEN FLOODED WITH CALLS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE BEGINNING OF
THE SPELL- NOT ONLY ABOUT YOU
KNOW SAFETY OF SURFING BUT-
ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS- I
DO WANT TO RECOGNIZE JUST THAT
THE QUICK CAFFERTY THE UNIFIED
COMMAND. TO GET THE WATER
QUALITY TESTING UP AND RUNNING
AND- YOU KNOW I THINK FOR
GROUPS LIKE SURFRIDER THERE'S
SORT OF A BALANCE BETWEEN. WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH IS PROTECTED BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO FIGHT FOR
PUBLIC ACCESS AND SO. THIS WAS
A CHALLENGING SITUATION I THINK
COLLECTIVELY WHEN THE WATER
QUALITY DATA WASN'T THERE
DURING THAT FIRST WEEK AND SO.
I YOU KNOW I THINK ONE THING
THAT COULD MAYBE BE APPLIED FOR
FUTURE SPELLS. IS TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET THAT TESTING UP AND
RUNNING MORE QUICKLY- YOU KNOW
MEASURING SAMPLING WATER
QUALITY FOR OIL CONTAMINATION.
IS A WHOLE DIFFERENT THING THAN
SAMPLING FOR BACTERIAL
CONTAMINATION. STAR TYPICAL
BEACH MONITORING PROGRAMS IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND BEYOND. THEIR
TESTING FOR ENTEROCOCCUS WHICH
IS WHAT OUR OUR SURFRIDER
VOLUNTEER WATER QUALITY LABS
TESTS FOR. SOIL CONTAMINATION.
T'S A DIFFERENT BEAST IT'S
MORE COMPLICATED TO TEST FOR.
AND FRANKLY THERE AREN'T A
CLEAR SET OF GUIDELINES ARE
THRESHOLDS FOR. PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SO IT. HAS CREATED SORT OF-
A MORE SET A LESS KLAY STAND
FOR WHAT'S ARE NOT- I THINKTHE
SURFING COMMUNITY THOSE OF US
WHO YOU KNOW WANT TO SEE THE
DATA AND WHATNOT. WE HAVE SORT
OF DEFERRED TO THAT THE
COLLECTIVE EXPERTISE OF THE
AGENCIES ARE AND THAT DOES LOOK
THE PART PUBLIC HEALTH LOCAL
AGENCIES. TO SAY THAT THEY'RE
DOING THE TESTING AND THEY'RE
NOT FINDING DETECTABLE LEVELS
OF OIL AND SO. I THINK FOR MOST
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY IN
INCLUDING ME THAT'S BEEN ENOUGH
TO SAY YOU WANT TO GO SURFING
BUT- BUT THOSE QUESTIONS REMAIN
AND- AND WE'RE TELLING PEOPLE
JUST TO CAST. YOUR CHECK BEFORE
YOU GO AND CHECKTHE WEBSITES.
IN YOUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RESOURCES. THANK YOU I GUESS MY
LAST COMMENT IS IT MAYBE MORE
COMMENT THAN A QUESTION BUT-
TIM ISLEY ON GROSSMAN- I'VE
PERSONAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FOCUS ON ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
A LOT WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T REALIZE IS WHILE THE
BEACHES THAT I REPRESENT AND
THEN GOING TO NEWPORT AND
HUNTINGTON. ARE OFTEN THOUGHT
OF AS VERY WEALTHY. AREAS THEY
ACTUALLY PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE
BEACHES AND COASTS FOR.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE COMING FROM
OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
LOWER INCOME THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- SO THE
TICKET LOSS OF THESE BEACHES
FOR ANYBODY'S IS A REAL ACCESS
ISSUE BUT- I DON'T IF YOU HAVE
ANY CLOSING THOUGHTS OR
COMMENTS ON THAT POINT IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF. BEACHES AND
BEACH ACCESS TO- EVERYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT SENATOR I MEAN.
ESPECIALLY THE PANDEMIC WE SAW
HOW ACCESS TO NATURE. IT IS. SO
IMPORTANT AND YOU SHOULD NOT BE
A PRIVILEGE IS A NECESSITY. AND
THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW. THE
BEACHES WERE CLOSED FOR TWO
WEEKS THAT. THAT IS A BIG DEAL
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
REALLY. CRAMPED YOU KNOW
QUARTERS AND THAT'S THE ONLY
RECREATION THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO SO IT'S A BIG DEAL
FOR MANY MANY. PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY IN THE
LATINO COMMUNITY SO THAT'S-
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
PREVENT IN THE FUTURE ALL THESE
TYPE OF MAN AND HE- MADE
DISASTERS- AND THAT'S WHY WE
ALSO NEED TO AND- OIL DRILLING
BOTH A MAN AND OFF SHORE-
DETAILS OF. OUR COMMUNITIES A
LOOK AT. A DISPROPORTIONATE
EFFECTED BY THE SUB OF
EXTRACTIVE ECONOMIES SO- THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR REMARKS.
THANK YOU- OTHER MEMBERS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BEFORE WE
WRAP THIS PANEL ON SAND THERE
NO MISS VICE CHAIR ALL RIGHT-
BUT I'LL GET ON THIS ONE A WRAP
UP QUESTION FOR- FOR THE ENTIRE
PANEL IF ANYONE HAS A COMMENT
BUT JUST- WHETHER THERE ARE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN STATED THUS FAR ON CHANGES
IN STATE LAW- THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS- OFFSHORE
OIL RISKS EITHER FROM. ARMS IN
FEDERAL WATERS THAT THEN
IMPACT- STATE WATERS AND STATE
LANDS- OR FOR THOSE- IN STATE
WATERS. HOW WE CAN TAKE A
WRITTEN TESTIMONY AS WELL IN
THE FUTURE BUT IF ANYONE HAD A
COMMENT THERE WE'D WE'D
APPRECIATE. YOUR INPUT HE WILL
BE TAKING. I WAS IS IT IT IS
OKAY FOR ME TO GO YES PLEASE
OKAY SO- AS- I THINK THAT IF
THERE WAS AN OPPORTUNITY AND I
SPOKE WITH SENATOR MAN EARLIER
TODAY ABOUT THIS- IF THERE WAS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO BE NOTIFIED MORE
QUICKLY THAT WOULD BE ONE OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE I'M AS WELL
AS SOME SORT OF COLLABORATIVE
OPPORTUNITY- TO HELP OTHER
CITIES- WHEN THEY DO HAVE THESE
OIL SPILL RESPONSES- ARE ALL
STILL INCIDENTS- WE IN
HUNTINGTON. OR BLESSED IN THAT
WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST MARINE
SAFETY DIVISION AND WE HAVE
BOATS WE HAVE JET SKIS WE HAVE
A VERY EXTENSIVE OPERATION. BUT
I KNOW JUST TO THE NORTH OF US
YOU KNOW BEACH DOES NOT. AND SO
IF THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY THAT
WE CAN BUILD WHAT SENATOR MAN
HAD MENTIONED EARLIER THIS
MORNING REGIONAL RESPONSE TO IT
BUT IF WE GET NOTIFIED MORE
QUICKLY AND THEN. BE MORE PRO
ACTIVE WHILE THE- COAST GUARD
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE WERE BEGINNING TO GET
THEIR- PROGRAMS IN PLACE SO
THAT WE'RE RIGHT THERE MEDIA WE
ARE READY TO TAKE ACTION- I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF THERE WAS
AN OPPORTUNITY THAT WE COULD DO
SOMETHING LEGISLATIVELY TO
PROMOTE. THAT AND TO ENCOURAGE
THAT. THANK YOU FOR THAT MAYOR
KERR- OTHERS. I KNOW INITIALLY
HEARD FROM MR UEKI AND STUFF
FOR ABOUT- SOME LONG TERM
CLOSURE QUESTIONS- REMEDIATION-
I DIDN'T KNOW IF ANYONE HAD A
COMMENT ABOUTTHE ENERGY A
PROCESS TO THAT'S SOMETHING THE
COMMITTEE IS INTERESTED IN IN
TERMS OF THE TIMING OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCE DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT WE KNOW WITH REFUGIO
TOOK ABOUT FIVE YEARS TO GET
FUNDS MOVING AND THAT. OTHER
PROCESS HASN'T BEEN
PARTICULARLY EXPEDITIOUS AND
IT'S SOMEWHAT DIFFICULT TO
QUANTIFY AS CHAIR FLETCHER
POINTED OUT- THE YOU KNOW EXACT
MATH OF HOW BAD THE IMPACT'S
BEEN- SO. IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
TODAY BUT IT WILL BE LOOKING
INTO THAT WHAT YOU DO YOU HAVE
A QUICK COMMENT JUST JUST SUPER
QUICK CENTER I MEAN I THINK I
THINK YOU NEED IN YOUR.
COMPUTER SUPPORT REGIONAL-
DISASTER RESPONSE ALWAYS
APPRECIATED YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
REASONS WE ACTIVATED SO EARLY
WAS GOT A LOT OF VERY SMALL
JURISDICTIONS WERE BEING
IMPACTED BY THIS MAY BE JUST A
DOCTOR ASK YOUR PROFESSOR. TO
COORDINATE WITH THEM AGAINST
YOU SO WE JUST ACTIVATED IT
COUNTY WIDE. SECOND I'LL JUST
NOTICE GENERALLY ON ONGOING
WATER TESTING TO STAY AS A
LOCAL AGENCY. AND COUNTY WERE
GENERALLY GOING BACK TO YOUR
GUESTS AND WE GENERALLY ARE NOT
TESTING FOR. SOME OF THESE
OTHER PETROLEUM BASED THINGS
AND SO THERE'S YOU KNOW
POTENTIAL EXPANSION AROUND. YOU
DON'T WHAT COUNTIES ROUTINELY
DEALS RUNNING WATER QUALITY IT
COULD CERTAINLY BE SOMETHING.
THAT MAY BE WORTH CONSIDERING
YOU KNOW WE JUST DIDN'T HAVE
THE TECHNOLOGICAL. CAPABILITY
OF TESTING FOR PETROLEUM BASED
THINGS WE HAD TO BRING IN OTHER
FOLKS TO WHAT TO DO THAT. SO
THERE COULD BE SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD OUT THERE
JUST BE INHERENT IN YOUR.
PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES DOWN THE
COST. THERE HAVE THANK YOU.
TURN ME YES THERE'S A WIKI I
CAN BE VERY IN THE COURSE HAPPY
TO SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY AS
WELL BUT- I AM SURE. THAT A
REVIEW OF THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OPERATIONS
IS GOING TO TURN OUT MANY MANY
OPPORTUNITIES. TO SEE WHERE
THERE ARE- ITEMS AND PARTS OF
THE INSTRUCTIONS THAT ARE OUT
OF DATE. BOTH IN THEMSELVES
COMPARED TO THEIR EXPECTED LIFE
SPAN AS WELL AS THE OPERATIONAL
PLANS UNDER WHICH THEY WERE
ORIGINALLY- BIRD BURCHILL
CONSTRUCTED. AND THAT THAT
WOULD PROVIDE MANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM TO FIVE
SPECIFIC PIECES THAT ARE KNOWN
TO BE EXISTING HAZARDS THE
DOWNSIDE OF THAT THE FLIP SIDE
OF THAT WHICH I'M SURE YOU ARE
VERY WELL AWARE IS THAT. ANY
INCREASED ANY ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT BY THESE COMPANIES
IT'S GOING TO BE. UP IT'S GOING
TO GO ALONG WITH AN EXPECTATION
OF EVIL TO- CONTINUE OPERATING
IN ORDER TO RECOUP THOSE
INVESTMENTS AND I THINK THIS IS
EXACTLY THE POINT THE POINT AT
WHICH CALIFORNIA IS NOW ONE OF
THE PROBLEMS IT'S LANDING. IN
YOUR LAP WHICH IS HOW DO WE
DEAL WITH THIS- BALANCE RIGHT
NOW OF THE EIGHTY- COLLAPSING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S POSING A
DANGER TO US NOW AND THE
FINANCIAL DEMANDS OF THE
INDUSTRY. SO IT'S A DOUBLE
EDGED SWORD BUT- WHAT PART OF
THE PART OF THE- A BIG PROBLEM
THAT WE'RE ALL TRYING TO DEAL
WITH IT I GOT. THANKS FOR THE
AND I THINK WITH MORE IN THAT
ISSUE ON THE NEXT PANEL
ACTUALLY SO IT'S GOOD G. U. T.
THOSE ISSUES UP ON TALK TO
STATE LANDS AND COASTAL
COMMISSION HERE- ANY OTHER
FINAL COMMENTS BEFORE WE WRAP
UP THIS PANEL. GROSSMAN SURE
START OUT AT THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION AND I WOULD JUST NOTE
BRIEFLY- YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT TEAMS ARE AT THIS
HEARING TODAY HAS BEEN LESSONS
LEARNED FROM REFUGIO AND OTHER
PAST OIL SPILLS AND WE'VE
REALLY FROM STARFIGHTERS
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW THE AGENCY
RESPONSE HAS BEEN-
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED FROM
FROM APPLYING THOSE LESSONS
LEARNED AND AS YOU KNOW THERE
WAS ALSO A LEGISLATION PASSED
AT THE STATE LEVEL FOLLOWING
THAT TO IMPROVE- YOU KNOW SORT
OF SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
OVERSIGHT BASED ON THE FINDINGS
OF THE INVESTIGATION AND
LESSONS LEARNED SO. I WOULD
JUST EMPHASIZE THAT I THINK
WE'RE STILL EARLY IN THE
PROCESS OF REALLY UNDERSTANDING
WHY THINGS HAPPENED AND YOU
KNOW HOW THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED AND SO- YOU KNOW I
THINK IT WILL BE IMPORTANT TO
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION
OFFLINE AND SURFRIDER WILL BE
OFFERING- YOU KNOW OUR IDEA
CERTAINLY IN THE UPCOMING
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. OKAY LET'S THERE ANY
OTHER FURTHER COMMENTS WE JUST
WANT TO SAY REAL QUICK YES
PLEASE THINK THIS IS THIS IS
PRONE TO HAPPEN AGAIN UNLESS WE
REALLY. PUT A PATH TO THE
COMMISSION ON THE ARTS AFTER
WELLS AND- SO IT WILL BE. GREAT
TO SEE A BILL TO PUT A PASS ON
TO THE COMMISSION DOES WELLS.
OUT BECAUSE WE CAN HAVE ALL THE
SAFEGUARDS IN AND TRY TO
MITIGATE ALL WE WANT BUT- I
HAVE A SAYING THAT THE ONLY
PIPELINE THAT DOESN'T MAKE IT
THE ONE THAT HE'S NEVER BUILT.
AND WE SEE HOW THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS FAILING US
AND- A LOT OF THESE WELLS ARE
NOW FORTY FIFTY YEARS OLD AND-
LIKE MY OTHER COLLEAGUE WAS
SAYING IF THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION OF RETROFITTING
THESE. GUIDELINES THERE WILL BE
AN EXPECTATION OF HAVING PROFIT
FROM THEM. SO HOW DO WE MEET
THE EXPECTATION OF PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PROTECTING.
THE ENVIRONMENT AND PROTECTING-
IN DELETING ON CLIMATE SO I
THINK IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO. PUT FORTH SOME LEADERSHIP
IN ENSURING THAT WE'RE GOING
TO. BE PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I THINK
THAT THAT VERY NICELY WRAPS UP-
A CRITICAL TAKEAWAY FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER GOING FOR
ITS APPRECIATE THAT. THAT
TESTIMONY- I WITH THAT WILL
WRAP UP OUR SECOND PANEL AND
MOVED TO OUR FINAL PANEL- JUST
TWO PARTICIPANTS- DOCTOR HUCKLE
BRIDGE. A DEPUTY DIRECTOR IN
TRIBAL LIAISON TO THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
AND MISS JENNIFER THE TRACY AT
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION- MRS
LUCE C. I THINK WE HAVE YOU
DOWN HERE FIRST IF YOU DON'T
MIND KICKING OFF. FIRST I'M
HAPPY TO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JENNIFER LOPEZ IN THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU ALL TODAY AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE DISCUSSION ON
THE FUTURE OF OFFSHORE OIL. IN
THE SHORT TIME I HAVE A HOPE TO
SUMMARIZE THE POLICY AND LEGAL
FRAMEWORK FOR OFFSHORE OIL AND
GAS PRODUCTION AND PIPELINE
LEASE MANAGEMENT IDENTIFIED
EXISTING LEASES THE COMMISSION
MANAGES. AND DISCUSS OUR OIL
SPILL PREVENTION AND
DECOMMISSIONING ACTIVITY. THESE
OFFSHORE FACILITIES. THE
STATE'S OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS
LEASING HISTORY IS COMPLEX AND
NUANCED. AND TO STATE THE
OBVIOUS THE ENERGY POLICIES
FROM THE FIFTIES AND SIXTIES
ARE VERY DIFFERENT FROM
CALIFORNIA'S VALUES AND
PRINCIPLES AND OUR POLICY
PRIORITIES OF TODAY. HOWEVER
THESE LEGACY I GUESS THE
DECADES OLD ENERGY POLICIES ARE
WHAT CREATED THE LEGAL
CONSTITUTIONAL AND CONTRACTUAL
FRAMEWORK THAT DICTATES THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE OIL AND GAS
LEASE MANAGEMENT FRAMEWORK. TO
THIS DAY I WILL MISS
NECESSARILY INFORM YOUR
DISCUSSION AND DELIBERATION ON
HOW TO ADVANCE OUR SHARED CLEAN
ENERGY AND DRESSED TRANSITION
OBJECTIVE. IS COMPLEX BUT NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO ADDRESS. FIRST AS
BACKGROUND THE COMMISSION
MANAGES- THE ESTATE SOVEREIGN
PUBLIC TRUST LANDS WHICH
INCLUDES APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY RIVERS AND
LOSE FORTY LAKES AND LANDS
ALONG THE OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
MILES OF COASTLINE. AND
UNDERLINE THE PACIFIC OCEAN OUT
THREE MILES TO THE STATE
FEDERAL BOUNDARY. TOGETHER THIS
A COMPASS IS APPROXIMATELY FOUR
MILLION ACRES. THE COMMISSION
ALSO EXERCISES OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY OVER THE STATE'S
PUBLIC LANDS GRANTED IN TRUST
BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. THIS INCLUDES
THE OFFICE FOR A LONG BEACH OIL
PRODUCTION OPERATIONS OPERATED
AND MANAGED BY THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH. WHILE THE COMMISSION HAS
SOME REGULATORY FUNCTIONS IT IS
PRINCIPALLY A LAND AND RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT AGENCY NOT A
REGULATORY AGENCY. AND AS SUCH.
WE WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
SISTER REGULAR. A LIKE COASTAL.
CAL J. SESSION WHILE BY. OSCAR
FAT THE FIRE MARSHAL AND OTHERS
TO LEVERAGE OUR AUTHORITIES AND
JURISDICTION TO ADVANCE STATE
POLICY OBJECTIVES. IN NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE THE LEGISLATURE
CREATED THE FIRST THAILAND'S
OIL AND GAS LEASING PROGRAM.
THE EXISTING OFFSHORE LEASES
THE COMMISSION IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR MANAGING TODAY OR ISSUED
OVER A THIRTY YEAR PERIOD
BETWEEN NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT.
AND NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
IMPORTANTLY I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
A SPECIFIC ACT IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE THE CUNNINGHAM
SHALL ACT WHICH SERVES AS A
FOUNDATIONAL LAW FOR THE
EXISTING LEGACY OIL AND GAS
LEASES THE COMMISSION CURRENTLY
MANAGES. IMPORTANTLY THIS ACT
REQUIRED THE COMMISSION TO
ISSUE OIL AND GAS LEASES FOR A
TERM NOT BASED ON YEARS BUT FOR
SO LONG AS OIL AND GAS IS
PRODUCED IN PAYING QUANTITIES.
ESSENTIALLY THIS MEANS THAT
UNLESS HE CAN PRODUCE OIL AND
GAS PURSUANT TO THEIR STATE
LEASE AND DEFINITELY. AS LONG
AS IT IS ECONOMIC FOR THEM TO
DO SO. THE SPECIFIC TERM IS
INCLUDED IN ALL THE REMAINING
ACTIVELY- REMAINING ELEVEN
ACTIVELY PRODUCING OFFSHORE
LEASES THE COMMISSION MANAGES.
THESE LEASES WERE ENTERED INTO
OVER FOUR FIFTY YEARS AGO AND
PRIOR TO THE NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR COASTAL SANCTUARY ACT.
THROUGH THE COASTAL SANCTUARY
ACT THE LEGISLATURE.
CALIFORNIA'S COAST OFF LIMITS
TO NEW OIL AND GAS LEASES. HAVE
YOU PREVIOUSLY HEARD THE
LIBERTINES SEASTRAND OIL SPILL
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE ACT WAS
PASSED IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
THIS ACT GAVE THE COMMISSION
ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO PREVENT OIL
SPILLS IN THE STATE'S OFFSHORE
PLATFORMS AND ISLANDS THROUGH
MONTHLY AND ANNUAL INSPECTIONS
AND COMPREHENSIVE SAFETY AUDITS
CONDUCTED ON ALL OFFSHORE
PLATFORMS AND ISLANDS EVERY
FIVE YEARS. THE COMMISSION ALSO
IMPLEMENTS A ROBUST PIPELINE
SAFETY PROGRAM IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE FIRE MARSHAL AND THE
FEDERAL PIPELINE AGENCY MS THAT.
MORE RECENTLY THERE'VE BEEN A
NUMBER OF LAWS PASSED AT BOTH
PROHIBIT THE COMMISSION FROM
ISSUING NEW EXTREMELY SAYS FOR
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE
PIPELINES THAT WOULD FACILITATE
NEW OIL AND GAS DEVELOPMENT IN
FEDERAL WATERS AND ON FEDERALLY
PROTECTED LAND IN CALIFORNIA.
IMPORTANTLY THERE WILL ALSO BE
IN A NUMBER OF LIVES THAT HAVE
ADDED TOOLS TO THE COMMISSION'S
TOOLBOX AND CAL JAM'S TOOLBOX
TO BETTER MANAGE AND REGULATE
EXISTING STATE OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS AND PROTECT THE
STATE FROM LIABILITY. THE
COMMISSION MANAGES
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN ACTIVELY
PRODUCING OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS
LEASES I'M GOING TO SHARE MY
SCREEN- TO HELP PROVIDE SOME.
ADDITIONAL CONTEXT TO WHERE
THESE ARE LOCATED SO. HOLD
TIGHT. I'M HOPING THAT YOU CAN
SEE THIS NOW. SO AS I MENTIONED
THE COMMISSION MANAGES
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN ACTIVELY
PRODUCING OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS
LEASES MOST OF THESE LEASES ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THREE PLATFORMS
OFTEN ORANGE COUNTY THE
COMMISSION MANAGES EIGHT
OFFSHORE PIPE FINALLY SAYS
CONNECTING FEDERAL PLATFORMS TO
ONSHORE PROCESSING FACILITIES
BOTH IN THE SANTA BARBARA
CHANNEL AN OFFSHORE ORANGE
COUNTY. SO THE MAP WE'RE
LOOKING AT NOW THIS IS THE
SANTA BARBARA CHANNEL THE
COMMISSION HAS TO ACTIVELY
PRODUCING LEASES REFERRED TO AS
THE WESTMONT ALTHOUGH LEASES
THESE ARE ON THE BOTTOM RIGHT
HAND OF YOUR SCREEN. THEY ARE
WELLS THAT ARE DRILLED FROM
ONSHORE DIRECTIONALLY OUT THE
OFFSHORE RESERVOIR. THERE ARE
SIX ACTIVE HI FINALLY SAYS
CONNECTING BETTER ALL PLATFORMS
TO ONSHORE PROCESSING
FACILITIES. AND CURRENTLY ON
THE SITE AS WELL AS THE
LOCATION OF THE COMMISSIONS TWO
ACTIVE DECOMMISSIONING
PROJECTS- PLATFORM HOLLY AND
RINCON ISLAND. PLATFORM HOLLY
IS THE LAST PLATFORM IN STATE
WATERS AND ISN'T AND HASN'T
BEEN PRODUCING FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS NOW AND THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IS ACTIVELY PLUGGING
AND ABANDONING THOSE THIRTY
WELLS WE HOPE TO BE COMPLETED
WITH THAT OPERATION AND. TWELVE
TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS. AND THEN
MOVING ON TO. FOUR MINUTES
ENTIRE. THE NEXT FLIGHT-
INCLUDED. AND THAT AT LOS
ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY AREA-
THE COMMISSION MANAGES ONE
LEASE OFF SHORE- LA OR ORANGE
COUNTY CLOSE TO THE LA COUNTY
BORDER THIS- AND- IS OPERATED
BY CALIFORNIA RESOURCES COMPANY
CORPORATION AND INVOLVES ISLAND
CHAFEE. MOVING DOWN TO ORANGE
COUNTY THE COMMISSION AND
MANAGES AT ONE LEAST ASSOCIATED
WITH PLATFORM ASTOR. THE
COMMISSION ALSO MANAGES CHILE
SAYS ASSOCIATE WITH PLATFORM
ABBA I SHOULD BACKTRACK
PLATFORM PASTOR AND OTHER- BOTH
OPERATED BY D. CORE. AND
FINELY- THE COMMISSION MANAGES
FIVE LEASES ASSOCIATED WITH
PLATFORM AND ME OPERATED BY
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
CORPORATION. IN ADDITION THE
COMMISSION MANAGES TO ACTIVE
PIPELINE LEASES CONNECTING
FEDERAL PLATFORMS TO SHORE AND
TWO PIPELINE LEASES CONNECTING
ASTOR AN ENEMY TOP STORIES
WHILE. FARM ALLEY- THE PLATFORM
ALLEY PIPELINE AT ISSUE OF THAT
RECENT OIL SPILL THE COMMISSION
HAS A LEASE ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT PIPELINE IS HIGHLIGHTED AS
STATELESS D. SIX THIRTY SIX.
AND COVERS- A LITTLE OVER FOUR
MILES OF THE PIPELINE- LUSH.
ORANGE COUNTY BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL STATE OFF FOR A
BOUNDARY AND WHEN THAT PIPELINE
CROSSES INTO LA COUNTY WHERE
IT'S MANAGED BY THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH. LET'S STOP SHARING
MY SCREEN- AND MOVE ON. DEALT
LARGEST- OPERATION IN STATE
WATERS FOR OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION INVOLVES THE
WILMINGTON FIELD OFFICE FOR A
LONG BEACH THIS IS ACTUALLY THE
FOURTH LARGEST OIL FIELD IN
NORTH AMERICA. AND THROUGH A
SERIES OF STATUTES AND
AGREEMENTS THE STATE RECEIVES A
SIGNIFICANT SHARE OF THE NET
PROFITS GENERATED ASK BEFORE
WELL ISLANDS AND THE WEST
WILMINGTON OPERATIONS WHICH ARE
LOCATED- UNDER THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH. UNDER VARIOUS STATUTES
AND AGREEMENTS THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH IS CONSIDERED THE
OPERATOR OF THOSE OPERATIONS
AND CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
CORPORATION IS THE CITY'S
CONTRACTOR. THE COMMISSION DOES
NOT SERVE AS M. AS IN A ROLE AS
LESSOR LIKE ANY OTHER LEASES.
AND HAS ACTUALLY VERY LIMITED
AUTHORITY OVER THE DAY TO DAY
MANAGEMENT OF THESE OPERATIONS.
AS PART OF THESE OIL AND GAS
LEASES. AN EXCUSE I'M GONNA GO
BACK TO MY NOTES REAL QUICK. AS
PART OF THESE OIL AND GAS
LEASES IN THE PIPE FINALLY SAYS
THE COMMISSION REQUIRES
OPERATORS TO MAINTAIN BONDS
INSURANCE AND OTHER LIABILITY
PROTECTION INSTRUMENTS TO
PROTECT THE STATE THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO- TENNEY BONDS
REQUIRED BY CAL JAM. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE STATE
LEGISLATURE BEGINNING IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR PROHIBITED
THE COMMISSION FROM ENTERING
INTO ANY NEW OIL AND GAS. FOR
THAT POLICY HAS SET THE
FOUNDATION FOR WHERE THE
COMMISSION FINDS ITSELF TODAY.
AND TO COME INTO THE
DECOMMISSIONING PHASE AND MANY
OF THE STATE'S OFFSHORE
FACILITIES AND THIS LEADS ME TO
THE FINAL PART OF MY
PRESENTATION. THE COMMISSION
RECOGNIZES THAT THE EFFECTS AND
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CLIMATE CRISIS REQUIRE THE
STATE TO DRAMATICALLY CHANGE
THE WAY IT PRODUCES AND
CONSUMES ENERGY AND THERE IS A
BRIDGE TO THE SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE. AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
DOING OUR PART IN BUILDING THAT
BRIDGE AS THE LAND OWNING
AGENCY THAT OVERSEES OVER FOUR
MILLION ACRES OF PUBLIC LANDS
WE ARE WORKING HARD TO DIVERSE
THE FIRE LEASING AND REVENUE
GENERATING PORTFOLIO AND
POSITION OURSELVES TO BE
PARTNERS IN FACILITATING OUR
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE. THIS
INCLUDES PURSUING PARALLEL
TRACKS OF FACILITATING
GEOTHERMAL SOLAR AND WIND
DEVELOPMENT ON LANDS WE MANAGE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DESERT. AND
WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO FACILITATE
OFFSHORE WIND DEVELOPMENT IN
FEDERAL WATERS WELL ACTIVELY
WORKING WITH CAL JAM AND OUR
OIL AND GAS LESSEES TO ABANDON
IDLE WELLS AHEAD OF THE
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS. AND
SURE THE STATE IS ADEQUATELY
PROTECTED THROUGH BONDS SINKING
FUNDS PROPERTY LANES AD OTHER
MECHANISMS. ACTIVELY
DECOMMISSIONING OFFSHORE
FACILITIES REMEDIATING OFFSHORE
ORPHAN LEGACY WELLS AND
CONTINUING TO IMPLEMENT ROBUST
AND COMPREHENSIVE SPILL
PREVENTION AND INSPECTION
PROGRAMS. IN FACT IN THE LAST
SIX YEARS. HELLO THE TERM. OF
TEN OFF OIL AND GAS LEASES
RETURNING OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
EIGHT THE COASTAL SANCTUARY. IN
CONCLUSION THE COMMISSION
UNDERSTANDS ITS PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND ITS
FUTURE OF FOSSIL FUEL SUPPLY
INDEPENDENCY THE COMMISSION IS
COMMITTED TO A JUST A
RESPONSIBLE TRANSITION TO
RENEWABLE ENERGY FUTURE WHILE
RESPONSIBLY MANAGING THE
STATE'S EXISTING OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS CONSISTENT WITH THE
LAW. AND ENSURING THE STATE IS
PROTECTED FROM LIABILITY
ASSOCIATED WITH IT KLEIN OF
THESE OFFSHORE OPERATIONS.
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE RIGHT TIME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE WILL
COME BACK TO YOU BUT- DOCTOR
HEALTH COVERAGE DID YOU WANT
TO- SOME BRIEF TESTIMONY HERE
AND THEN WE CAN HAVE SOME
MEMBER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
YES THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE STERN- AND DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
KIM HOW BRIDGE AND I'M THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR ENERGY
OCEAN RESOURCES AND FEDERAL
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE
COMMISSION. TODAY I'LL PROVIDE
A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
COMMISSION'S ROLE AND
JURISDICTION OVER OIL AND GAS
ACTIVITIES IN STATE AND FEDERAL
WATERS. IN OUR MOMENT WILL
SPILL RELATED ACTIVITIES. THE
COASTAL COMMISSION IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE A
CERTIFIED LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAM. DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING
OIL AND GAS WITHIN THE COASTAL
ZONE TO ENSURE CONSISTENCY WITH
THE POLICIES OF THE COASTAL
ACT. THE GIRLS ON CAMPUS IS THE
ENTIRE CALIFORNIA SHORELINE
EXCEPT FOR SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AND. INCLUDE STATE WATERS OUT
TO THREE MILES OFFSHORE. IN
ADDITION TO OUR DIRECT COMPANY
ROLE INTO THE COASTAL ACT WE
ARE ONE OF THE STATE AGENCIES
CHARGED WITH IMPLEMENTING THE
FEDERAL COASTAL ZONE MANAGEMENT
ACT. AT THIS POINT LET ME SHARE
MY SCREEN A FEW POWER POINT
SLIDES. BEAR WITH ME. OKAY
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN SEE THE
SCIENCE- SO CONGRESS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO THE CCMA
PROVIDES FOR MANAGEMENT OF THE
NATION'S COASTAL RESOURCES
THROUGH FEDERAL AND STATE
PARTNERSHIP. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN THE NATIONAL
OCEANIC AND ATMOSPHERIC
ADMINISTRATION OR NOAA
CERTIFIED CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. CERTAINLY
THE CERTIFICATION GRANTED
REVIEW OF THE COMMISSION A
FEDERAL PROJECTS AND FEDERALLY
PERMITTED PROJECTS OUTSIDE OF
THE COASTAL ZONE INCLUDING
ACTIVITIES PROPOSED IN FEDERAL
WATERS. THESE REVIEWS CALLED
FEDERAL CONSISTENCY REVIEWS ARE
TRIGGERED WHEN A PROJECT OR
ACTIVITY COULD HAVE SPILLOVER
EFFECTS ON CULTURAL RESOURCES
WITHIN THE COASTAL ZONE AND
ASSESS WHETHER THE ACTIVITY IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE
CERTIFIED COASTAL MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM SH THE CHAPTER THREE
POLICIES OF THE COASTAL ACT
SERVICE THE ENFORCEABLE
POLICIES. OF CALIFORNIA'S
COASTAL MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. SO
ARE THESE POLICIES. TRYING. TO
CHANGE MY SLANG HERE. HOLD ON
ONE SEC. SO THE COST INCLUDES
COASTAL RESOURCE PROTECTION
POLICIES RELATED TO MARINE
RESOURCES AND WATER QUALITY
COMMERCIAL AND RECREATIONAL
FISHING ARCHAEOLOGICAL
RESOURCES SCENIC AND VISUAL
RESOURCES PUBLIC ACCESS AND
RECREATION. GIVE ME- AND
COASTAL HAZARDS AMONG OTHERS IN
ADDITION THE COASTAL ACT
INCLUDES POLICIES SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT THAT REQUIRE
CONSOLIDATION OF NEW OR
EXPANDED FACILITIES AND REQUIRE
PIPELINE TRANSPORTS OIL FROM
OFFSHORE PLATFORMS TO ITS
REFINERY DESTINATIONS. BECAUSE
ALL INCLUDE POLICY THAT ALLOWS
FOR COASTAL COMMISSION APPROVAL
OF NEW OR EXPANDED BECAUSE
INDEPENDENT INDUSTRIAL
FACILITIES LIKE OFFSHORE OIL
AND GAS PLATFORMS AND
ASSOCIATED PIPELINES. EVEN IF
THOSE FACILITIES ARE NOT
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER POLICIES
AND COSTS LACKS IS ALRIGHT
POLICY WAS INCLUDED IN THE
COASTAL ACT WHEN OFFSHORE OIL
AND GAS. IN COASTAL POWER
PLANTS THAT RELY ON SEA WATER
FOR COOLING PLAYED A BIG ROLE
IN THE STATE'S ENERGY PORTFOLIO
AND THIS POLICY WAS DEEMED
NECESSARY COMPROMISE. GIGI
PASSAGE OF THE COASTAL ACT.
SEVERAL THANKS BRIAN. EXECUTIVE
OFFICER BECAUSE HE PROVIDED A
THOROUGH OVERVIEW OF EXISTING
OIL AND GAS FACILITIES OFFSHORE
CALIFORNIA SO I WON'T REPEAT
THAT HERE- I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
HOWEVER MISSIONS HISTORY AND
ROLE OR LACK THERE OF IN
REVIEWING AND AUTHORIZING USE
EXISTING FACILITIES ALL THE
OFFSHORE FORMS WERE PROPOSED
DURING THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES AS A
RESULT OVER HALF OF THE
EXISTING FACILITIES WERE
APPROVED EITHER BEFORE THE
COASTAL ACT WAS PASSED OUT OR
BEFORE CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM CERTIFIED BY
NOAH. AND THUS WERE NOT
REVIEWED. OR APPROVED BY THE
COASTAL COMMISSION. THE CALLS
ACT REVIEWS THAT ARE BECAUSE
LIKE REVIEWS AND APPROVALS THAT
DID OCCUR TOOK PLACE DURING THE
EARLY DAYS OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND WE'RE NOT AS
ROBUST AS WE AS WOULD BE
UNDERTAKEN TODAY. THIS MEANS IS
THAT THERE ARE SOCIALLY NO
CONDITIONS OF APPROVAL AND
THOSE INITIAL COMMENTS FOR
CONSISTENCY TO. ASIANS PROVIDE
FOR ONGOING OVERSIGHT MISSION.
FOR OIL AND GAS FACILITIES ON
FEDERAL WATERS WE WILL HAVE A
FEDERAL CONSISTENCY ROLE IF AN
OPERATOR PROPOSES SIGNIFICANT
REPAIRS NEW FACILITIES OR
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN
PRODUCTION THAT COULD IN FACT.
BECAUSE THE RESOURCES AND
REQUIRES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
OVER THE YEARS BECAUSE OF
MISSION HAS REVIEWED PIPELINE
REPAIRS AND REPLACEMENTS OUR
CABLE REPLACEMENTS AND NEWLY
PROPOSED PLATFORM JUST CHARGES.
ZEROING IN ON PLATFORM ELLIE
THIS PLATFORM WAS PROPOSED
PRIOR TO CERTIFICATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM AND THIS CONSTRUCTION
AND OPERATION OF THE PLATFORM
AND A PORTION OF PIPELINE IN
FEDERAL WATERS WAS NOT REVIEWED
BY THE COMMISSION. AND THE
COMMISSION DID HOWEVER PROVIDE
THE PORTION OF THE PIPELINE IN
STATE WATERS. FINALLY I'D LIKE
TO PROVIDE. A BRIEF RUNDOWN OF
THE COMMISSION STAFF
INVOLVEMENT IMPOSED OIL SPILL
ACTIVITIES. SO MY ROLE IS
MOSTLY GOING TO SUPPORT ONGOING
CLEANUP. ACTIVITIES DIRECTED BY
UNIFIED MAN'S WE PARTICIPATED
IN MULTI AGENCY CALLS
IMPREGNATED WITH UNIFIED
COMMAND ON ISSUING EMERGENCY
AUTHORIZATIONS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. FOR CONSTRUCTION
SAND BERMS TO PROTECT SENSITIVE
HABITATS. AS AVERAGE SHIFT
TOWARDS ADDRESSING A BROKEN
PIPELINE IN FEDERAL WATERS. THE
COMMISSION MAY HAVE A LITTLE
CONSISTENCY ROLE UNDER CDM
ANCHOR ANY PIPELINE REPAIR OR
REPLACEMENT WORK THAT COULD
HAVE AN EFFECT ON COASTAL
RESOURCES. AND LASTLY IS
PROVIDED FOR US AND WE BUILT
TWENTY SIXTY FOUR AND I SPOKE
ABOUT EARLIER. THE COMMISSION
HAS BEEN INVITED TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE NATURAL RESOURCE DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT ORDER PROCESS. AND
TO THAT END WE ARE WORKING WITH
THEIR COUNTERPARTS FROM OTHER
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES TO
CONTRIBUTE THE COMMISSION'S
EXPERTISE IN COASTAL HABITATS
AND SPECIES. PUBLIC ACCESS AND
RECREATION IN. SUPPORT ABOUT
ONGOING OR AS FOR. SO WILL
THAT I WILL CONCLUDE BUT OF
COURSE I AVAILABLE FOR ANY. YOU
MAY HAVE- THANK YOU DOCTOR HAVE
DOCTOR HAVE A BRIDGE- MEMBERS
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR- FOR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CASEY YOUR
DOCTOR HALF BRIDGE- RIGHT I'LL
JUST START OFF BRIEFLY- I'M
HOPING-ONE OR BOTH OF YOU CAN
COMMENT ON THIS. THE SORT OF
WHAT SEEMS TO BE A MISMATCH
BETWEEN THE LIABILITIES THE
RISKS AND THE- THE
CAPITALIZATION- OR FUNDING SET
ASIDE CURRENTLY TO DEAL NOT
JUST WITH- POLLUTION EVENTS
LIKE THE ONES WE'VE SEEN BUT-
ALSO DECOMMISSIONING COSTS- I'M
I'M CURIOUS- IF PARTICULARLY
WITH RESPECT TO- THE
PLATFORMING QUESTION- WE'VE
SEEN REPORTS THAT- PROXIMITY.
TWO HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR
DECOMMISSIONING COSTS ON ON
THOSE PARTICULAR OPERATIONS
BUT- WE KNOW THAT AMPLIFIES
BEEN RECENTLY RE CAPITALIZE AT
A BANKRUPTCY- AS WELL AS BEING
CITED FOR NUMEROUS VIOLATIONS
BY FEDERAL REGULATORS IN THE
MEANTIME. WHAT HAPPENS IF
AMPLIFY- DECIDES TO DECLARE
BANKRUPTCY. I'M HAPPY TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THAT- THAT- FOR
PLATFORMS- ARE THE THREE THAT
AMPLIFY OPERATES IN FEDERAL
WATERS- OBVIOUSLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THROUGH AND BESSIE-
AND BONE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENSURING THAT THERE IS ADEQUATE.
BONDS AND OTHER- LIABILITY
PROTECTION MECHANISMS IN PLACE
AS PART OF THE FEDERAL LEASING
LEASE AND LEASING PROCESS. AT
LEAST FROM THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND- WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY JURISDICTION OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE'S THREE MILE- BOUNDARY
HOWEVER OBVIOUSLY THAT PIPELINE
DOES CROSS INTO STATE WATERS
AND AS PART OF OUR LEAST- WITH-
SAN PEDRO BAY PIPELINE COMPANY
A SUBSIDIARY OF AMPLIFY. WE
RECENTLY A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO
INCREASED OUR BOND AMOUNT-
POWER AT THAT THEY ARE REQUIRED
TO MANAGE AND HOLD ON TO EIGHT
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS PLUS
THERE IS A PARENTAL GUARANTEE-
FROM AMPLIFY- IN ADDITION TO
THAT THERE IS A FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLAR SINKING
FUND- TO COVER PIPELINE AND-
DECOMMISSIONING IN THE ENTIRETY
OF STATE WATER SO THAT WOULD
COVER NOT ONLY AND THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION LEASE BUT THAT
PORTION OF THE PIPELINE- IT.
LONG BEACH MANA. NOW OBVIOUSLY
A PARENTAL GUARANTEE- ONLY GOES
SO FAR WHEN THAT- PARENT
COMPANY DROPS INTO BANKRUPTCY
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
RECENTLY UNFORTUNATELY WITH OIL
AND GAS COMPANY'S DROPPING INTO
BANKRUPTCY AND- AND ABANDONING
THEIR OBLIGATIONS TO RESTORE
THE LEASED PREMISES- I HAD
BECAUSE- IT SUITS OUR ECONOMIC
AND BUSINESS NEEDS- WE ARE.
ACTIVELY PURSUING- AT DEAD.
TRUSTEES ASSOCIATED WITH-
PLATFORM HOLLY AND RINCON
ISLAND- AS WELL AS OTHER
OPERATORS ASSOCIATED WITH- SOME
FEDERAL LEASES WHERE WE
RECENTLY TERMINATED THE
PIPELINE IN STATE WATERS AND-
IT'S IT IS- VERY VERY
CHALLENGING THAT FEDERAL
BANKRUPTCY LAWS- DO NOT OPERATE
IN FAVOR OF CREDITORS- OR- NON
SECURED CREDITORS INCLUDING THE
STATE. AND SO AS PART OF OUR
EXPERIENCE OF THE LAST FIVE
YEARS- WE HAVE APPROACHED OUR
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS LESS FEES
TO INCREASE THAT LIABILITY
PROTECTION NOT JUST WITH BONDS-
WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT COVER. ALL
THE DECOMMISSIONING- AND
PLUGGING AND ABANDONMENT COSTS
BUT ALSO THROUGH OTHER CREATIVE
MEASURES LIKE SECURING-
PRIORITY LANES ON- PRIVATE LAND-
SEEKING FUNDS WHERE WE CAN
ACCESS ACTUAL CASH TO COVER-
OBLIGATIONS AND OTHER
MECHANISMS- SO WE ARE
DEFINITELY LEARNING FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE OVER THE LAST. FIVE
YEARS AND TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE A DIVERSITY OF
LIABILITY PROTECTION MEASURES
TO PROTECT THE STATE AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND JUST TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT WE KNOW SHELL
WAS THE ORIGINAL DEVELOPER FOR
THIS BETA UNIT IN THE OIL
FIELD- PRECEDING CCMA BUT- IT
SHALL ULTIMATELY. LIABLE FOR
THOSE DECOMMISSIONING COSTS IN
THE EVENT THAT AN AMPLIFIER OR
OR SUBSIDIARY- YOU KNOW IT
WOULD IT WOULD DECLARE
BANKRUPTCY IS THAT IS THERE
DOES IT DOES THEIR RECOURSE TO
THE ORIGINAL OPERATOR OR- OR
NOT. AND THAT IS A QUESTION
THAT IS- CAN BE MORE COMPLETELY
ANSWERED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- I DO KNOW THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES HAVE
CERTAIN LAWS ON THE BOOK AND
IT'S REFLECTED IN CERTAINLY
SAYS WHERE THEY CAN GO BACK TO
PRIOR PRIOR OPERATORS. TO COVER
DECOMMISSIONING COSTS BUT I'M
NOT SURE HOW FAR BACK THEY CAN-
THAT GRAB THE PRIOR OPERATOR SO
I CAN'T ANSWER THAT DIRECTLY
FOR THIS UNIT BECAUSE IT IS A
FEDERAL WATERS AND GOVERNED BY
FEDERAL LAW ONLY SAYS- BUT WE
DO HAVE SIMILAR- SITUATIONS
AND- FIRST. APPSWARM SO FOR
EXAMPLE- WITH PLATFORM AND- D.
CORE IS THE CURRENT OPERATOR
BUT AS PART OF THEIR
ACQUISITION OF THOSE LEASES.
FREEPORT MAC MORAN WHO WAS THE
PRIOR ART OPERATOR IS STILL ON
THE HOOK FOR DECOMMISSIONING
COSTS. SO EVERY- SITUATION IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT DEPENDING
ON THE BUSINESS DEAL THAT WAS
STRUCK BETWEEN THE VARIOUS
OPERATORS AND ASSIGNING A
LEASEHOLD INTEREST- BUT- THAT'S
THE SITUATION OUT PLATFORM
ASTOR SIMILARLY AND THE SANTA
BARBARA CHANNEL WITH THAT ARM
HOLLY- WHEN DENICO ACQUIRED THE
LEASEHOLD- INTEREST FROM EXXON
MOBIL. AND EXXON AS A CONDITION
OF THE COMMISSION'S APPROVAL OF
ASSIGNMENT EXXON MOBIL IS STILL
RESPONSIBLE FOR BOTH. PLUGGING
AND ABANDONING AND
DECOMMISSIONING PLUGIN BANNING
THE WELLS AND DECOMMISSIONING
THE PLATFORM SO WHILE THE STATE
HAS AND IS RESPONSIBLE FOR-
THAT DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE AND ESSENTIALLY-
MANNING THEPLATFORM. EXXON
MOBIL IS RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING
FOR AND IMPLEMENTING THE
PLUGGING AND ABANDONMENT-
PROGRAM AND ULTIMATELY
DECOMMISSIONING THAT PLATFORM.
SO IT'S REALLY A CASE BY CASE
BASIS DEPENDING ON THE HISTORY
OF THE LEASE ASSIGNMENTS AND
THE PRIOR OPERATORS AND THE
BUSINESS DEALS ASSOCIATED
ABOUT. THANKS FOR THE VERY LAST
QUESTION IN THIS ON THIS LINE
OF- INQUIRY- YOU'D MENTIONED
THAT THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE
SINKING FUND THAT HAVE BEEN SET
ASIDE UNDER IT I RECENTLY GO
SHE ATION OF BELIEVES IN TWENTY
NINETEEN- THAT. THAT SET ASIDE
WAS WAS UNDERTAKEN FOR- FOR THE
PARTICULAR FIELD WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE TODAY IN THE
PIPELINE SPECIFICALLY THAT'S IN
STATE WATERS. DO YOU HAVE AN
ESTIMATE OF THE DECOMMISSIONING
PORTION OF. THAT FACILITY THE
PIPELINE IS FROM US TO WE HAVE
A TO HAVE A COST ESTIMATE AT
THIS POINT FOR WHAT WHAT
DECOMMISSIONING WOULD COST AND
THAT'S. IN SAN PEDRO BAY AREA.
YEAH THAT'S SO IN TERMS OF THAT.
PIPELINE AS OF OUR- AND- THE
COMMISSION INCREASING THE BOND
REQUIREMENT- AT AS WELL AS-
THAT SINKING FUND. WE ESTIMATED
FOR THE STATE'S PORTION
SUGGESTS THAT FOUR POINT FOUR
MILE PORTION OF THE PIPELINE
THAT THE DECOMMISSIONING COSTS
WOULD BE- ABOUT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS SO BETWEEN- THAT. EIGHT
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLAR BOND
AND THEN ARE PROPORTIONAL-
ALLOCATION OF THAT SINKING
FUND- WE CURRENTLY HAVE ENOUGH
FOR THE DECOMMISSIONING OF THE
PORTION OF PIPELINE UNDER LEASE
FROM THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION- THAT QUESTION ABOUT
THE OTHER SECTION OF THE
PIPELINE THAT'S MANAGEDBY THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH. THEY DO
HAVE ACCESS THE REMAINING
PORTION OF THAT SINKING FUND-
AT THIS MOMENT IN TIME WHAT
OTHER LIABILITY PROTECTIONS
THEY MAY HAVE IN THE EVENT OF
DECOMMISSIONING. OKAY THANKS-
THE MEMBERS FOR THE QUESTIONS
IF YES MR MAJORITY LEADER
CENTERS FOR WELCOME. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN APOLOGISES LATER
AIRPLANE AIRPLANE AIRPLANES-
YEAH I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
CHAIRMAN'S QUESTIONS WITH
RESPECT TO MONEY THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE BECAUSE YOU KNOW WITH
THE WITH SOME YEARS AGO WHEN WE
HAD THE CHALLENGE WITH PLATFORM
HOLLY. LIKE WE'VE NOW
INTRODUCED IN THE LAST THREE OR
FOUR YEARS I USED TO BUILD SOME
YEARS AGO ON PLATFORM HOLLY. TO
INCREASE THE SIZE OF THE BOND
BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS OUTSIZED
EXPOSURE. AND NOT ENOUGH MONEY
IN THE BONDS I KNOW THAT
SENATOR JACKSON SAID AND I
THINK IT WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
THE MOMENT THE TIME DID A
SIMILAR THING. AND WITH JUST
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE PLATFORM
HOLLY FOR A MINUTE I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE WHOLE
ARCHITECTURE OF WHAT WE DO TO
GET RID OF OFFSHORE OIL. BUT
BUT I REMEMBER READING THE
ANALYSIS THAT WAS HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF EXPOSURE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
IT YOUR- DID I UNDERSTAND YOU
CORRECT THAT EVEN THOUGH WE
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO THAT MONEY
WE'VE BEEN PAYING FOR IT. AND
THERE'S BEEN A REQUEST IN THE
BUDGET TO HELP SUPPLEMENT THESE
COSTS. THESE DOLLARS ARE GOING
TO BE REIMBURSED THROUGH A
GUARANTEE BY EXXON MOBIL WITH
RESPECT TO THAT PROJECT. I AM I
WILL CLARIFY- SO. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT ELEMENTS-
IN TERMS. DOING THE TALKING AND
ABANDONMENT AND DECOMMISSIONING
FOR PLATFORM HOLLY. DENICO
DROPPED INTO BANKRUPTCY GIVING
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION A
COUPLE OF DAYS NOTICE AND SO WE
HAD TO MOBILIZE QUICKLY TO
ESSENTIALLY STAFF THE PLATFORM
BECAUSE OF THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND THE RISKS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT ASSOCIATED WITH
LEADING EDGE AND STAFF. THAT
REQUEST THAT WE HAVE MADE AND
THE LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROPRIATED OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS REALLY FOCUSES
IN ON COVERING THE COST OF-
STAFFING THE PLATFORM AND
STAFFING ON YOUR- PROCESSING
FACILITY. WHICH PROCESSES THAT
THAT REALLY RISKY AND DEADLY
HYDROGEN SULFIDE GAS- THAT IT
ALSO PRODUCED FROM PLATFORM
HOLLY HOW MUCH MONEY IS THAT-
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS I
THOUGHT I SAW SOMETHING IN THE
BUDGET FOR HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS REALLY TO THAT
PROJECT IN MY WRONG. I MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT SO- THAT OVER THE
PAST COUPLE YEARS WE HAVE BEEN
REQUESTING AN APPROPRIATIONS
NOT JUST TO- ADDRESS PLATFORM
HOLLY BUT ALSO TO PLUG AND
ABANDON THE SEVENTY FIVE WELLS
ASSOCIATED WITH RINCON ISLAND
AND DECOMMISSIONING THOSE
FACILITIES WHICH IS AWESOME AND
DERRICK COUNTY. AND A LOT OF
TIMES THOSE APPROPRIATIONS HAD-
HAPPENED- IN A BUNDLE SO THAT
THAT WOULDN'T GET YOU ABOVE A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
THOSE FUNDS REIMBURSABLE FOR
THOSE OPERATIONS AND THE GAS IS
THAT BY VIRTUE OF THE GUARANTEE
THAT YOU REFERRED TO IN RESPECT
EXXON MOBIL. NO I'M GONNA GET
TO THAT- SO. WE DO NOT HAVE AND-
RT THAT IS- AT VALIDLY AND
STILL LIVE ASSOCIATED WITH FROM
KHAN ISLAND THAT- BAT LEFTY HAS
COMPLETELY LIQUIDATED. AND
THERE ARE NO- OPPORTUNITIES
REALLY TO SECURE ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THROUGH THE BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDINGS. WITH PLATFORM
HOLLY EXXON MOBIL THROUGH THE
ASSIGNMENT TO- PROCESS DID
RETAIN RESPONSIBILITY FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY AN OBLIGATION TO
FUND THE PUB IN AN ABANDONMENT
OF THE THIRTY EIGHT WELLS. AS
WELL AS FUND THE
DECOMMISSIONING. AS PART OF- A
SETTLEMENT WITH EXXON MOBIL
THAT EXXONMOBIL HAS- AGREED TO
COMPLETELY FIND THOSE
OPERATIONS AND IMPLEMENT THAT.
IN ADDITION- AT THIS STATE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR STAFFING THE
PLATFORM AND CONDUCTING
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
ASSOCIATED- TO SUPPORT AGAIN
AND ABANDONMENT- AND
DECOMMISSIONING OPERATIONS AND
SO- EXXON MOBIL I THINK THEIR
LAST. ESTIMATE WHICH IS A
COUPLE YEARS AGO PRIOR TO THAT
AND DOMINIC- ESTIMATED PLUGIN
AND- DECOMMISSIONING OF THE
PLATFORM AT ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. THAT
COST HAS ONLY INCREASED-
BECAUSE OF THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE WELLS AND- BECAUSE OF THE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH A
PANDEMIC IN TERMS OF- TRYING
OUT THIS ENTIRE PROCESS
DURATION CONCERN FOR JUST
BECAUSE- I'M TRYING TO TAKE IN
WHEN I CHAIRED THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE. TRYING TO TAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE VIEW. AS TO HOW
WE CAN INTELLIGENTLY. ELIMINATE
I THINK IT WAS A TWENTY THREE
OFFSHORE WELLS AND WE'VE GOT
THE FEDERAL ISSUES AND THE LIKE
HOW DO WE MAKE THAT HAPPEN. HOW
DO WE MAKE IT HAPPEN THE WAY
THAT REMAIN THE MINUSES RICH TO
TAXPAYERS. BECAUSE IT SOUNDS
LIKE WE HAVE THESE ONE OFF
DEALS THAT WE MIGHT HAVE A
GUARANTEE OR NOT. IT YOU WHAT
WHAT I EXPERIENCED BEFORE IN
THIS COMMITTEE WAS THAT WE HAD
SITUATIONS. WHERE THESE BIG
COAST SOUL LAW OFF. THESE WELL
TO GET THE LAST DRAW OF OIL TO
A SMALL OP WHO THEN FILED. AND
THEN THAT WE HAVE NO RECOURSE
SO WHAT ARE WE TO SHOW UP AT
THE AND THEN WE HAVE EMINENT
DOMAIN ISSUES IF WE TRY TO JUST
TAKE ON. THE QUESTION THAT
WE'VE BEEN GRAPPLING WITH IS
HOW DO WE- MINIMIZE RISKS TO
TAXPAYERS MAXIMIZE THE SPEED
WITH WHICH WE CAN GET THESE
THINGS GONE RIGHT IT MAKES SOME
SENSE. BUSINESS PEOPLE ARE
GONNA TAKE EVERY NICKEL OUT OF
THE OCEAN OF THE GLOBAL OIL
THEY POSSIBLY CAN YOU CAN YOU
KNOW THAT'S JUST WITH THE WAY
THE BUSINESS WORLD WORKS. HOW
DO YOU MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
SPEAKER PEROT'S WHEN. YOU WERE
A CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. CENTER LAYERED I
BELIEVE HAD A HAD A THING ON
THE ON THE- RIGS TO REEFS FROM
SOMETHING THAT I SAW IN THE
NORTH SEA WHEN I WAS OVERSEAS
IN IN IN IN MY BUSINESS
EXPERIENCE. AND I ALSO SAW IN
THE GULF OF MEXICO THAT WAS
WILDLY EFFECTIVE. AND AGAIN
TRYING TO DELIVER WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND WHAT WAS SO
GREAT ABOUT THESE IDEAS WAS. WE
COULD TAKE THESE WELLS CHOPPED
WHERE THERE WAS A X.
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT. THAT WAS
THE TEST IN THE BLOG THE JOHN
PRESS PUT IN AND I FOLLOWED HIS
ADVICE ON. WAS A SPEAKER PRESS.
CHOPPING OFF A HUNDRED FEET SO
SHIPS CAN GO OVER. IS LONG AS
IT IS IN THE PHARMACY BENEFIT
THAT YOU CAN HAVE A REFORM
MODES BELOW THEN YOU HAVE THE-
COMPANIES GIVE THE STATE AN
ENDOWMENT THE LARGE WE ESTIMATE
THAT THE ENDOWMENT THE QUESTION
FOLLOWING UP ON THE GERMAN.
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THE
LARGEST ENDOWMENT FOR OCEANS IN
THE WORLD A DOLLAR OF TAXPAYER
MONEY INCENTIVIZES THESE PEOPLE
TO SHUT THEM DOWN WE HAVE NO
RISK. IT'S A IT'S AN
OCEANOGRAPHIC BENEFIT WE SEE IT
HAPPEN ALL OVER THE WORLD.
JENNIFER A BUNCH OF REASONS WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET THAT
DONE. BUT AGAIN IT'S TRYING TO
HAVE A RATIONAL APPROACH
BECAUSE HERE WE ARE THAT
ANOTHER PROBLEM EVERYBODY'S
GOING CRAZY IT'S ON THE FRONT
PAGE OF THE NEWSPAPER. AND
WE'RE GOING TO GET BACK IN THE
MORASS OF LIABILITY OF NEW
BUDGET REQUESTS OF WHO YOU'RE
GOING TO SUE IT'S A FULL
EMPLOYMENT ACT FOR LAWYERS NO
DISRESPECT TO LAWYERS BUT- IT
DOESN'T ACHIEVE THE
DELIVERABLES IN THE DEFINITION
OF SUCCESS IN MY JUDGMENT FOR
ALL OF US LANCE COMMISSION
COASTAL COMMISSION THE
LEGISLATURE. IS SHUT HIM DOWN.
GET AS MUCH EITHER NO COST TO
TAXPAYERS. RISKS TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND IS MUCH MONEY
INTO A FUND TO PROTECT THE
OCEAN THAT NO TAXPAYERS COST AS
POSSIBLE SO I THINK WE JUST PUT
THIS BACK OUT THERE BECAUSE
THIS COMMITTEE'S BEEN
DELIBERATING THESE THINGS AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S SOME ISSUE.
THAT NO ONE WANTS TO DO WITH
THE- COMPANIES BUT THE REALITY
OF THE SITUATION IS. YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO CREATE A
STRUCTURE THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYBODY OTHERWISE WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE LEE. BE IN THIS
SITUATION THERE WILL BE ANOTHER
SPILL THERE WILL BE ANOTHER
PROBLEM THERE WILL BE ANOTHER
BANKRUPTCY. AND WHAT ARE WE
DOING AS A GOVERNMENT. TO GET
IT DONE BECAUSE I WOULD
SUSPECT. THAT IF WE DONE WHAT
PRINCE HAD DONE WHAT I FOLLOWED
UP ON PRINCE WHEN I FIRST GOT
HERE. A LOT OF THESE THINGS
WOULD BE IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING DECOMMISSIONED TODAY AND
WE HAVE A LOT LESS RISK AND WE
DID WE'D BE A MUCH BETTER
POSITION TO TRY TO GO ON SO
LONG BUT- IT WILL WORK ON THIS
ISSUE FOR SEVEN YEARS AND I
JUST THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND I THINK. MAYBE
NOW WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING WE
CAN DRAW THE ATTENTION I LIKE
MR CHAIRMAN. IT TO YOUR
COMMITTEE INTO YOUR LEADERSHIP
KIND OF CORE OF A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH. TO JUST GET IT DONE.
THANK YOU. PRETTY SURE THE
COMMON IN THE HISTORY OF
LEADERSHIP- THAT THIS ENTIRE
COMMITTEE BENEFITS FROM. THE
TWEEN YOU AND FORMER SECRETARY
LAYERED HERE WE'VE GOT. GOOD
KNOWLEDGE BUILT TO BUILD ON WE
STILL HAVEN'T MADE PROGRESS TO
YOUR POINT- DR HAWKING BRIDGER.
IS THE NEW CASEY ANY QUICK
FEEDBACK OR COMMENTS. TO THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S. CHARGE. I
CAN GO FIRST KATE OR DATE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO LOGO OKAY I- I WANT
TO- I THINK- CENTER HERZBERG
FOR HIS COMMENTS I THINK THAT-
YOU KNOW THAT ADDING TO THE
TOOLS TOOL CHEST OF- STATE
AGENCIES- TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
FROM ALL DIFFERENT SIDES- IS
THE BEST APPROACH BECAUSE WHAT
A ONE SIZE FITS ALL MAY NOT
WORK- FOR EVERY SINGLE STATE
FORMER STATE LEASE OR OR EVEN
IN THE FEDERAL WATERS I WILL
SAY THAT- YOUR BILL A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WHICH- REQUIRES CAL
JAM TO UPDATE ITS FUNDING
REQUIREMENTS FOR OFFSHORE-
OPERATIONS- IS SUCH A TOOL AND-
WE ENJOYED WORKING WITH CAL JAM
ON- SOME OF THE INITIAL
RESEARCH THAT. WAS CONDUCTED AS
PART OF THAT WE ALSO THINK
THAT- AT EXPLORING THE END
BRAINSTORMING ABOUT INCENTIVES-
TO HELP. I AND- WHILE I'M- AND
MAKING RIGHT DECISIONS IT IS
ALSO A GOOD APPROACH AS WELL
SO- WITH THAT WHAT WHAT CAN I
DO WANT TO JUST ADD ONE
CLARIFICATION- WE DID HAVE
RECEIVED AN APPROPRIATION
RECENTLY A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IT ESCAPE MY HAVE
MINDED I'M APOLOGIZE FOR THAT
FOUR PLATFORM HOLLY AND THAT
WAS- DUE TO THE INCREASED COSTS
ASSOCIATE WITH THE PRATT- WITH
THE PANDEMIC. AS WELL AS
PURSUING LEGAL. REMEDIES
AGAINST THE TRUSTEE. I DON'T
HAVE MUCH TO ADD- MS LOOK HAS
HE JUST JUST TO SAY THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO BE WORKING AND
PUSHING OUR FEDERAL COLLEAGUES
AS WELL TO MOVE DECOMMISSIONED
FORWARD THERE THERE'S
CURRENTLY- THEY'RE WORKING ON
A- PROGRAMMATIC III ASKED FOR
DECOMMISSIONING AND WE NEED TO
BE. PUSHING THAT FORWARD AS
MUCH AS WE CAN- AND WILL BE
WORKING TO DO SO- THANKS FOR
THAT I WOULD ALSO JUST NOTE IN
THAT IN THAT SAME VEIN THE
GOVERNOR I BELIEVE DID PROPOSE
A TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR-
WELL REMEDIATION FUND IN THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR- THE-
LEGISLATURE DID NOT- C. A. THE
CD THAT REQUEST AND- THAT. THAT
ITEM HAS BEEN PULLED OVER- SO
THAT MAY BE AN AREA TO LOOK
INTO HOWEVER I DO KNOW THAT
THERE WERE CONCERNS RAISED.
ABOUT SIMPLY PUTTING UP FRONT
PUBLIC DOLLARS IN PLACE- EVEN
IF THOSE FUNDS MAYBE WERE TO BE
MATCHED BY FEDERAL FUNDING
WHICH APPEARS TO BE IN THE
BUILD BACK BETTER PLANNED. A
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
REMEDIATION FUND- WITH THE SORT
OF MATCHING COMPONENT I THINK
THAT THE MISSING PIECE HERE IS
WHAT. WHAT WILL THE OIL
INDUSTRY'S PEACE BE- IT FEELS
LIKE THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE WILLING TO COME
TO THE TABLE BUT- HOPEFULLY IN
THESE MORE COMPREHENSIVE
DISCUSSIONS WE CAN. START TO
CHART THAT PATH AND FIND A WAY
THROUGH THIS- SENATOR MEN DID
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER. COMMENTS
THERE YEAH I HAD A FEW
QUESTIONS- SO I SAID FROM THE
DECOMMISSIONING I WAS JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT THE SCOPE OF THE
STATE'S POWERS- OVER PIPES THAT
CAME INTO STATE WATERS. AND I
KNOW THAT- I BELIEVE IT'S NOW
LIKE CONSIDER THE FACT THAT-
THE- HEIGHT BEING MAY HAVE BEEN
AN ISSUE THAT. IS NOT CLEAR
WHEN THE PIPING WAS LAST
INSPECTED AND I GUESS MAYBE
THAT'S THE FIRST QUESTION IS DO
WE KNOW. WHEN THE PIPING WAS
LAST INSPECTED OR REPLACED-
WHAT'S THE APPROXIMATE LIFETIME
OF A FIGHT LIKE THIS AND I
REALIZE THAT. THIS MAY HAVE
OCCURRED FROM AN ANCHOR
DRAGGING ALONG THE OCEAN FLOOR
BUT I BELIEVE IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE SPILL IN HUNTINGTON
BEACH. WAS DUE TO AGING PIPES
AND I'M JUST AS I WE START TO
THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT MOST
OF THE STUFF WAS BUILT IN
NINETEEN SIXTIES AND NINETEEN
SEVENTIES. I THINK I'D BE GOOD
TO KNOW HOW MUCH OF THIS HAS
BEEN UPDATED HOW REGULARLY IT
IS REFURBISHED OR FIXED OR
WHATEVER THE CORRECT TERM IS-
AND WHAT LEVERS WE AS A STATE
HAVE TO OVERSEE THAT A
REQUIREMENT- SINCE- YOU KNOW
I'M NOT OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- ENDING
OFFSHORE DRILLING ANYTIME. SOON.
WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO WITH THE
STATEMENT. AT A CERTAIN SO I
CAN I CAN- ADDRESS THAT FIRST
THEN TURN IT OVER TO DR VOCAL
RANGE AND- WELL THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION- MANAGES LEASES- FOR
PIPELINES WITHIN STATE WATERS-
WE ARE NOT THAT A PIPELINE
REGULATORY AGENCY THAT IT DOES
LIE WITH THE FIRE MARSHAL AND
CERTAIN RESPONSIBILITIES ALSO
LIVE WITH CAL JAM. SO SAY WITH
THAT FOR- PIPELINES THAT ARE
SOLELY WITHIN- STATE WATERS-
AND UNDER A LEASE WITH THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION WE
REQUIRE THE PIPELINES TO BE
EXTERNALLY AND INTERNALLY
EXPECT- INSPECTED ANNUALLY. AND
WE HAVE ENGINEERS ON STAFF THAT
REVIEWS THOSE INSPECTIONS- AND
CONSULT WITH THE FIRE MARSHAL
AS WELL WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS- ON ANY TYPE OF
REMEDIAL ACTION THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN BASED ON THE RESULTS OF
THOSE. INSPECTIONS FOR THOSE
PIPELINES- THAT- CROSSBOWS
FEDERAL AND STATE WATERS
INTEREST- STORY- IS MORE
LIMITED BECAUSE- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S REGULATORY
AUTHORITY TAKES- PRECEDENT. AND
THINGS THAT IS THE PRIMARY
FEDERAL AGENCY THAT REGULATES
THOSE INTERSTATE PIPELINES.
THEY REQUIRE- INSPECTIONS
EXTERNALLY AND INTERNALLY EVERY
TWO YEARS- AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
PIPELINE AT ISSUE WAS SUBJECT
SUBJECT INTO SO THAT- THAT
PLATFORM ALLEY PIPELINE. AT THE
TOP OF THAT PIPELINE WAS
INSPECTED AT INTERNALLY IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AN EXTREMELY
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY- THE
INTERNAL INSPECTION WAS SET TO
HAPPEN AGAIN AT THE END OF
OCTOBER- BASED ON THE LAST
COUPLE OF INSPECTION REPORTS-
FROM OUR ENGINEERS. THERE
WEREN'T ANY- ANY EVIDENCE- THAT
HAVE PROMPTED- ANY NEED TO DO
ANY REMEDIAL ACTIVITIES AT THAT
TIME. GOT IT IN JUSTICE THIS IS
THE UNDERSTAND- YOU HAVE A
RIGHT OF WAY PERMITTING OVER
ALL OF THE PIPES RIGHT SO IT
WOULD FIT AT THIS POINT WE
DON'T ISSUE AND I THIS IS JUST
FOR CLARIFICATION PURPOSES FOR
ME BUT- WE HAVE NOT ISSUED NEW
PIPING PERMITS- SINCE. FOR
SOMETIME IS THAT CORRECT. WELL
I AM WE ARE HIGH PLAINLY SAYS
ARE DIFFERENT THAN OUR ALL.
ACTUALLY SAYS THAT THE OIL AND
GAS PRODUCTION LEASES AS I
MENTIONED I MIGHT- PRESENTATION
THOSE DON'T HAVE A FIXED TERM
OF YEARS THEY CONTINUE AS LONG
AS IT'S ECONOMIC FOR THE
OPERATORS TO PRODUCE THE
PIPELINE LEASES OR THE RIGHT OF
WAY LEASES- DO YOU HAVE FIXED
TERMS- AND THERE ANYWHERE
BETWEEN TEN. AND FORTY YEARS
DEPENDING ON WHEN THEY WERE
ISSUED SO WHEN OUR COMMISSION
WAS ISSUING PIPELINE LEASES IN
STATE WATERS- YOU KNOW IN THE
EIGHTIES AND NINETIES THEY
ISSUED FAIRLY LONG TERM LEASE
SAYS- BETWEEN THIRTY AND FORTY
YEARS YEAH. NOW OUR PRACTICE IS
TO ISSUE MUCH- SHORTER LEASES
SO THAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REVIEW AND REASSESS- BASED
ON THE STATE'S PRIORITIES AND
POLICY OBJECTIVES JUST SO THAT
I UNDERSTAND. IS IT RIGHT THAT
YOU ALSO ISSUE THE RIGHT WAY
PERMITS FOR PIPES THAT LEAD TO
FEDERAL WATERS YES WE HAVE
EIGHT CURRENTLY CURRENT- LEASES
FOR PIPELINES THAT- ORIGINATE
FROM FEDERAL OFFSHORE
OPERATIONS SO LET ME JUST ADD
IT BY MYSELF LET'S SAY YOU HAVE
A PIPE AND- IT NEEDS TO BE I
DON'T I DID THE LEASE TERM AND
SOUL. WHAT WHAT POWERS DO YOU
HAVE LIKE ONE OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS YOU HAVE TO
FOLLOW EITHER STATUTORY OR
CONTRACTUAL WAIT TO RENEW THOSE
LEASES ISSUE NEW PERMITS OR
RENEW THOSE PERMITS ISSUE NEW
PERMITS OR ALTERNATIVELY DO YOU
HAVE ANY LEEWAY CONTRACTUALLY
STATUTORILY. TO END THOSE
PERMITS PREMATURELY AND SAY YOU
KNOW WE DON'T THINK THAT YOU
KNOW THE UPKEEP IS A PROPER
YOU'RE VIOLATING CERTAIN
PROVISIONS WE WE'RE JUST GONNA.
TAKE AWAY YOUR PERMIT
PREMATURELY DO YOU HAVE ANY
LEEWAY LIKE THAT'S I UNDERSTAND
I CAN SENSE YOUR FLEXIBILITY
BOTH IN ISSUING NEW RIGHT AWAY
PERMITS BUT ALSO. IN YANKING
AWAY EXISTING PERMITS.
CERTAINLY- SO I CAN GIVE ANY.
OF ARE LEE COMPLIANCE AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS MOST
RECENTLY WITH- I HAVE A
PIPELINE THAT SERVES THE
PLATFORM'S HOGAN AND HOW CHIN-
IN THE SANTA BARBARA CHANNEL
THOSE ARE TWO FEDERAL. FORMS IN
FEDERAL WATERS THE PIPELINE
THAT SERVE THOSE- PLATFORMS DID
CROSS INTO STATE WATERS AND
CONNECTED ON SHORE. THAT UP
PIPELINE LESSEE OF OURS- WAS
NOT COMPLIANT WITH OUR LEASE
TERMS AND THE COMMISSION TOOK
ACTION TO TERMINATE THOSE
LEASES BASED ON NONCOMPLIANCE.
AND DEFAULT IN BREACH OF THE
LEASE TERMS AND- ESSENTIALLY
THAT DID TERMINATE UP
PRODUCTION ON THOSE TWO
FEDERAL. TAX FORMS AND THEY ARE
PART OF THE EIGHT FEDERAL
PLATFORMS THAT. PHONE JUST
ANNOUNCED THEY WERE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT AS PART OF A
PROGRAMMATIC EIS FOR
DECOMMISSIONING. I THE
COMMISSION DOES NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY- AT UNILATERALLY
TERMINATE AN EXISTING VALID
LEASE- ABSENT ANY EVIDENCE OF A
BREACH OR NON COMPLIANCE. AS I
MENTIONED OUR PIPELINE LEASES
DO HAVE FIXED TERMS SO- THEY DO
COME UP FOR RENEWAL AND AS PART
OF THAT APPLICATION PROCESS
STAFF REVIEWS THAT FOR A
COMPLIANCE- AND CONSIDERATION
UNDER C. CLASS AS WELL AS
CONSISTENCY WITH THE COMMON
PUBLIC TRUST DOCTRINE AND
CONSISTENCY WITH WHAT'S IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE STATE- AND
AT. STAFF MAKES RECOMMENDATIONS
THE COMMISSION ON WHETHER TO
ISSUE A NEW LEASE AND UNDER
WHAT TERMS NOW WITH THAT SAID-
THIS IS WHERE WE GET INTO A
COMPLEX AREA OF THE LAW THAT-
BECAUSE THESE ARE FEDERAL-
THESE ARE PIPELINES THAT SERVE
FEDERAL OPERATIONS WE DO HAVE
TO BE. AWARE OF AND TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT- CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS- INCLUDING THE
COMMERCE CLAUSE AND OTHER
ELEMENTS- THAT WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES HAVE
PREEMPTION AUTHORITY- NOW THAT
DOESN'T ISN'T THE PRIMARY.
FOCUS OF THE COMMISSION BUT IT
IS SOMETHING TO BE CONSIDERATE
OF AS WE LOOK INTO THE FUTURE
AND- HOW TO STRUCTURE THE LEGAL
AND POLICY RAMEWORK FOR MOVING
FORWARD TO ACHIEVE OUR POLICY
GOALS NOT SHIPPING OUT IT IS
VERY HELPFUL AND SO SHIFTING I
GUESS TO THE ACTUAL. PLATFORMS-
AND THE LEASES- EIGHT EIGHT I
KNOW THAT IT'S CAL JAM THAT HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO ISSUE THE
PERMITS ON NEW DRILLING OR
EXTRACTION. AND WE DON'T
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE A
REPRESENTED FROM CAL JAM HERE
BUT MAYBE YOU KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THIS- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
WHICH IS THE- WHEN. IT SO AS
YOU KNOW I BELIEVE YOU AND I
DISCUSSED I I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE LEGISLATION ENDING
DRILLING AND EXTRACTION
INCLUDING UNDER EXISTING LEASES
AND THAT IS THE MAJORITY LEADER
REFERRED TO. DOES RUN IN THE
EMINENT DOMAIN TAKINGS ISSUE.
NOW SOME HAVE SUGGESTED THAT WE
COULD DO THE SAME THING
THROUGH- ENDING PERMITS-
REMOVING PERMITS AND I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO
WHAT CAL JAM HAS TO CONSIDER
EITHER FROM A STATUTORY.
PERSPECTIVE OR A CONTRACTUAL
PERSPECTIVE IN DECIDING WHETHER
OR NOT TO ISSUE NEW PERMITS
UNDER THE LEASE IS THAT IT HAS
THESE EXISTING LEASES. I WISH I
COULD BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
HELPFUL IN ANSWERING THIS I AM
NOT AN EXPERT ON CAL JAM
STATUTORY AND REGULATORY
AUTHORITY- SO- I I'M I'M NOT
VERY EXPERIENCED IN TERMS OF
WHAT. THEY NEED TO CONSIDER IN
ORDER TO ISSUE A NEW PERMIT-
FOUR ADDRESS LANE- UNDER OUR
OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS LEASES.
ARE OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS
LEASES- ALTHOUGH. LEACH THEY
ARE- SET. A DAY DO ALSO REQUIRE
THAT THE OPERATORS COMPLY WITH-
CURRENT- AN EXISTING STATE
REGULATIONS AND SO EVEN AS
THOSE REGULATIONS EVOLVE AND
CHANGE AND BECOME MORE
PROTECTIVE. THAT OPERATORS ARE
SUBJECT AND REQUIRED TO COMPLY
WITH THOSE INVOLVING
REGULATIONS- SO UNLIKE OUR
LEASES WHICH ARE STUCK IN THE
PAST AS I MENTIONED IN THE
BEGINNING OF MY PRESENTATION-
THE STATE'S AUTHORITY FOR
REGULATORY AND OVERSIGHT.
WHETHER IT'S CAL JAM OR OTHER
REGULATORY JURISDICTIONS AND
AUTHORITIES. THE LAST HOUR
OPERATORS ARE STILL REQUIRED TO
MEET THOSE EVOLVING
REQUIREMENTS ASSUMING THAT IT
OPERATOR IS COMPLYING WITH THE
REGULATIONS COULD WE- JUST DEY
WILLINGLY TO DENY THEM A NEW
PERMIT FOR NEW DRILLING UNDER
EXISTING LEASE. I CAN'T ANSWER
THAT THAT IS REALLY UNDER THE
GUISE OF CAL JAM AND THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THEIR
LEGAL AUTHORITIES GOT IT I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR MAN A
SIMILAR. I'LL JUST BE
RELATIVELY BRIEF- BECAUSE I
THINK SENATOR MAN EXHAUSTIVELY
WENT INTO THE ISSUE AND IF WE
WERE REALLY GOING TO MOVE INTO
SOME OF THESE AREAS OF OIL
POLICY. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND REGULATORY STATUTORY
OF THE RELATIONSHIP OF FEDERAL
EMINENT DOMAIN AND THERE'S SO
MUCH AS THE PERSON. THAT WAS
THE SUPERVISOR OF THE
PREDECESSOR AGENCY OF CAL JAM
FOR EIGHT YEARS IT IS EXACTLY
R. A FACT FINDING LEVEL BEFORE
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND THE POLICY
LEVEL IT IT SO IT WOULD REALLY
DO THAT AND THEN I'M SORRY
SENATOR HERTZBERG LAST I HAD
JUST HAD ONE COMMENT ON HIS
COMMENTS. AND THAT IS A SINCE
IT MIGHT BE A WHILE SOMETHING
THAT SOMEBODY ELSE CONSIDERS I
STARTED TO VET THE NOTION OF
DOING- RIGS TO REEFS BILL WHEN
I WAS IN MY LAST YEAR IN THE
ASSEMBLY. AND I THOUGHT IT WAS
A SIMPLE CONCEPT THAT NO
LIABILITY IS RELEASED OF THE
OIL COMPANY AND DOING IT THAT
THE REQUIRED TO CAP AND CLOSE
OFF THE WELL BECAUSE THEY WOULD
BE AS IF THE RIG WAS A 100%
BEING RENEWED. AND THAT YOU
WOULD TAKE ANY DIFFERENCE IN
REVENUE- FOR BENEFIT AND ON A
100% BASIS MOVING TO OCEANS
PROGRAMS ALTHOUGH IT COULD BE
MOVED TO BACKING ORPHAN WELLS-
OR OTHER COSTS IN THE FIELD.
AND IF THAT SEEMED SIMPLE BUT
TO ME AND THE ISSUE WAS BETWEEN
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND THIS IS IF
SOMEBODY WAS ATTEMPTING IT
AGAIN I MEAN. A CENTER.
HERZBERG ALLOWED AS TO HOW IT
FAILED. IT FAILED BECAUSE IT
WAS SUCH A LACK OF TRUST IN OUR
WOULD SAY JIM THERE. BETWEEN
MORE ENVIRONMENTAL CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS AND GENERICALLY
MORE OIL PRODUCING COMPANIES ON
THE BELIEF THAT SHOULD GET MOST
OF THE WAY IN THERE. AND THEN
THERE WOULD BE THIS COMPROMISE
TO DATE ONLY BE RESPONSIBLE
470% OF THE MONEY THAT THEY
WERE OTHERWISE AND IN THE END.
THEY WOULD BE GIVEN SOME RIDE
THAT WOULD'VE EXISTED IF THEY
WENT THROUGH EXISTING TO A
CLOSE AND DECOMMISSION THE
WELLS. A. N. THERE WAS A
CONCERN THAT I DIDN'T THINK WAS
FELT THAT SOMEHOW IN THE
PROCESS THEY WOULD BE RELEASED
FROM LIABILITY AS WELL. AND SO
IF THERE IS A SERIOUS INTENT OF
DOING THIS BY SOMEBODY. I THINK
THOSE ARE THE MOVING PIECES
THAT HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED A
LACK OF TRUST BUT IT WOULDN'T
REALLY GET BELOW A 100% THERE'S
NOT A RELEASE OF LIABILITY AS
PART OF IT. AND THEN
POTENTIALLY YOU COULD GET THERE
BUT I THINK. THE IT. IT IT IN A
SUNBURN HURTS BERG WENT RIGHT
UP TO THAT AND I THINK THAT IS
THE NEXT DISCUSSION. AND THOSE
ARE THE FACTS BETWEEN THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND SO I JUST
THOUGHT I WOULD MENTION IT SO
THAT. IF ANYBODY IS CONSIDERING
IT DOES OR WHAT YOU'D YOU'D
HAVE TO DO SO. I APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY OF THE- DIRECTOR. OF
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
BECAUSE- DID. IS THERE SUCH A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE WELLS
SAUNDERS ARE 100% RESPONSIBLE
PARTY SOME THERE'S THIS MASSIVE
COST SOME THERE'S A SMALL COST.
SOME SOMEBODY'S JUST WALKED
AWAY FROM AND- IT IS ALWAYS
DIFFICULT TRYING TO. ADOPT A
STATUTE THAT APPLIES FAIRLY AND
RESPONSIBLY FOR THE STATE TO
ALL THOSE DIFFERENT SITUATIONS
AND I THINK THAT'LL BE THE
CHALLENGE AND IN CRAFTING
LEGISLATION BUT- I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING. WITH ANYBODY THAT
IS CRAFTING THE LEGISLATION IF
THERE'S ANY WAY THAT I CAN. BE
OF ASSISTANCE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO. MAKE SOME
COMMENTS WE WILL WE WILL TAKE
YOU UP ON THAT OFFER- AND I
WOULD SAY WHAT WHAT COULD BE
PRODUCTIVE IN ADDITION TO THE
THEN. THE. LOOKING FOR SORT OF
A- EARLY FIFTIES- OF THE AFTER
ACTION REPORT OR SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS OR GUIDANCE FOR
GOING FORWARD IN ADDITION- IT
WOULD HELP TO GET I KNOW STATE
LANDS SO I'VE BEEN THROUGH YOUR
WEBSITE AND ALL YOUR LEASING-
CONTRACTS AND SORT OF YOUR YOUR
MAP IN ALL YOUR TOOLS FOR
LOOKING WHAT'S ON THE BOOKS AND
ALL THE VARIETIES OF. DIFFERENT
LEASES THAT ARE CURRENTLY UNDER
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE- BUT TO
AGGREGATE SOME OF THAT AND TO
REALLY- FOR LACK OF BETTER WORD
DRILL DOWN ON- V. THE SORT OF
NET AN INDIVIDUAL- LIABILITIES
FOR NOT JUST SORT OF POLLUTION
COSTS BUT THE DECOMMISSIONING
AND REMEDIATION COSTS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT HERE AND HOW THAT
MATCHES UP AGAINST THE
COMBINATION OF BONDING AND
SINKING FUNDS AND MENTION LEANS
BUT THOSE OTHER TOOLS AND IF IT
IF YOU COULD SORT OF AGGREGATE
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION FOR
US. PUT IT UP IN AN APPLES TO
APPLES WAY SO WE CAN LOOK AT IT
AND WITH THE REAL EYE ON WHAT
MONEY HERE IS BANKRUPTCY PROOF-
WHICH OF THESE FUNDS DO WE KNOW
WE'LL BE ABLE TO ACCESS
REGARDLESS OF THE WHIMS ARE
DECISIONS OF THE PARTICULAR
OPERATOR- IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU COULD PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE I KNOW A LOT OF THIS
IS EXISTING WORK YOU'VE GOT ON
YOUR WEBSITE BUT JUST TO BE
AGGREGATED IN IN SOME MORE
COMPREHENSIVE WAY AND PERHAPS
A- PACKAGE THAT UP- WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR SOME OF THE
OTHER ITEMS. CERTAINLY WE'D BE
HAPPY TO DO THAT OKAY GREAT-
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL FOR
WORK GOING FORWARD BECAUSE I DO
THINK WE'RE GOING TO WANT TO.
BE GETTING INTO DETAILS AND
SCRUTINIZING SOME OF THESE
LEASES AND THAT DISENTANGLING
SOME OF THE JURISDICTIONAL
ISSUES AS WELL AS SOME OF THESE
LOT LARGER FINANCIAL LIABILITY
SO THAT. THE PEOPLE THE
TAXPAYERS ARE ENVIRONMENT IN
OUR FUTURE. ARE NOT LEFT
HOLDING THE BAG- I WILL
ENTERTAIN ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS BUT IF NOT I THINK
WE DO NEED TO GET THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY HERE SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION- WE WILL TURN TO. A
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO THANK-
DIRECTOR CASEY AND DR HUCKLE
BRIDGE FOR THEIR PARTICIPATION
FOR EVERYONE ELSE'S FORMAL
PARTICIPATION IN A HEARING
TODAY- AND WITH THAT- OPERATOR.
WE G- I INVITE THE PUBLIC IS
GOING TO PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN
NOW JUST AS A REMINDER TO THE
PUBLIC- IS- WAR WATCHING TODAY
IT'S EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE. FIVE FOUR EIGHT NINE AND
THEN WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE
YOUR ACCESS CODE WHICH IS TWO
THREE FIVE. FIVE THREE FOUR
THREE- AND DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF THESE
HEARINGS. WE MAY HAVE TO
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. AND WE'RE CURRENTLY
AT THREE TWENTY FIVE- AT THIS
POINT LET'S LET'S SEE HOW MANY
FOLKS ARE ON THE LINE. AT THIS
POINT INITIALLY AND WE'LL WE'LL
FIGURE OUT WHAT KIND OF TIME
CONSTRAINTS WE'VE WE'VE GOT
HERE. BUT AT THIS POINT MAXIMUM
OF TWO MINUTES EACH- AND IF WE
DO HAVE TO LIMIT FURTHER BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF CALLERS. I
WILL LOOK AT THAT BUT AT THIS
POINT THOSE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES OR EVEN
LESS- OPERATOR- WOULD YOU OPEN
LINES OR ACTUALLY LET'S FIRST
SEE IF WE HAVE WITNESSES HERE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE. BUT I DO
NOT SEE ANYBODY- WARM ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TWO WE TAKE A LOOK
NO ONE'S IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
OKAY VERY GOOD- SO LET'S LOOK
AT THE TELECONFERENCE. ORVIS
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS. THANK YOU. FOR
THOSE THAT HAVE DIALED IN ON
THE PHONE NUMBER PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO YOU HAVE NOT
ALREADY DONE SO. AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. ENDING IN PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TAKE THE FIRST
QUESTION OR COMMENT. YOU'RE NOT
QUESTION BUT A COMMENT. NO
COMMENTS POST YEAH AND MODERATE
HOW MANY DO WE HAVE ON THE LINE.
SO FAR JUST ONE IN Q. OKAY VERY
GOOD IT'S PRETTY. NINE THIRTEEN
YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR COMMENTS. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON I WAS HOPING FOR
FIVE MINUTES BUT- IT'S OKAY MY
NAME IS LADY UP ON ST I'M
CALLING FROM THE UNDEFEATED
LAST KNOWN AT THE TIME BUT
PEOPLE- REGARDING SOME BUT
PEOPLE INFAMOUSLY KNOWN AS
BENNETT I AM MY OWN AND I AM
CATULUS. I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE SOCIETY OF NATIVE
NATIONS AND AMERICAN INDIAN
MOVEMENT AND I'D LIKE TO THANK
SURFRIDER FOR THE LAND BACK
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT GOVERNMENT
RELATIVE- YOU SHOULD TAKE NOTE
THAT YOU SHOULD ALWAYS
RECOGNIZE WHAT LAND YOU ARE ON
THE UNCEDED LOCAL TRIBAL
PEOPLE. I ASK THAT YOU STOP
NORMALIZING OIL SPILLS AND
TRUCK STOP JUSTIFYING ALL OF
THE DISASTER AT HUNTINGTON
BEACH OIL CONTRACTS AND STOP
JUSTIFYING ALL THIS WITH JOBS
JOBS JOBS BECAUSE JOBS CAN BE
CREATED WITH A JUST TRANSITION
THE POLLUTION OVERALL HEALTH
INCLUDING THE STANDARD WING IT.
THE LADY THAT OTHER COORDINATED
THAT SHOULD BE GOOD THE CREEPY
CRAWLERS AND ALL OF OUR
RELATIVES MY PERSONAL LOSS BY
GREW UP AT LAVAGNA AND THOSE
FEATURES AND THANK YOU KNOW AND
THE- UNDERWATER OCEAN- BUT WITH
THAT I. AM LOOKING AND LOOK YOU.
OUR LONGER IN THE- IT BACK IT
STARTED. NO UNDERNEATH. TWENTY
NOW THAT MANY THAT THE- I'M
GONNA SAY THAT MY GRANDDAUGHTER
RECENTLY HAD ME ABOUT CAP FROM
A MARK NOW- BY- AND SHE THAT IT
WAS A TREASURE AND SHE CAN YOU
THAT SHE CLAIMS THAT THE SHALL.
I DRILLED A HOLE IN IT AND PUT
IT ON TRAIN AND I WEAR IT THE
GREY ARE NOT RUNNING BAYBERRY
COME OUT THERE BARELY NOTICE ON
THE GOING BRAIN RUN. THIS IS
NOT ENOUGH WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE TO STOP
THIS FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND-
BANKRUPTCY IS REQUIRED DOES
THAT MEAN THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
ACCEPTED. I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
WHO APPROVES OR DENIES THEM BUT
EACH BANKRUPTCY IT NEED TO BE
THE NIGHT. WE NEED TO CUT THE
ANCHOR THAT. ALL THE THINGS ARE
PEOPLE MADE MAN MADE QUITE
BLANK KILLING RULING. OUR WE
PAPER AND HAND BE IT MONEY OR
BE. UP WE CANNOT WRITE OUR PO.
OUR WE CANNOT. AFFORD ANOTHER A
FEW LIVES IMPACT OVERALL GOLD.
THE HELP OF OUR WORLD THE HELP
OF SEVEN GENERATIONS DESERVE
BETTER. WE NEED TO SHUT DOWN
THE OIL PIPELINE BECAUSE THE-
QUOTE. OIL PIPELINE WILL NEVER.
LEAK THE END THANK YOU OBVIOUS.
YOU KNOW THE INCENTIVES OF
GETTING YOUR HEART. YOU KNOW
WHAT YOUR CHILDREN AND YOUR
FAMILY ARE DESERVING. AND THE
CHILDREN. IN YOUR COMMUNITY I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. OTHERS WITH
MODERATOR BELIEVE OTHERS ONLINE.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN THE COMMENT Q. OKAY
VERY GOOD- WELL I DO APPRECIATE
THE TESTIMONY FROM- ON BEHALF
OF THE TONS OF PEOPLE BUT FOR
YOUR DIRECT TESTIMONY AND- FOR
THAT MARTIN ELLIE'S. BOTTLE CAP
THAT SADLY HANGS ON THAT
NECKLACE IS WHAT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE A MODERN FORM OF A SHELL BUT
I THINK. YOU'RE YOU'RE SPOT ON
IN TERMS OF- TO NORMALIZE THIS
IS SORT OF BUSINESS AS USUAL IN
THE COST OF OUR OF OUR
LIFESTYLES AND WE MOVE ON. AND
WOULD BE A HUGE MISTAKE SO THIS
IS JUST THE BEGINNING OF THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THIS ISSUE-
WILL BE SCRUTINIZING- LAWS THE
PROJECTS THEMSELVES- AND
LOOKING FOR BIG BOLD SOLUTIONS
THAT. ARE NOT GOING TO PLACE
THAT BURDEN ON US ON TAXPAYERS
ON THE ENVIRONMENT OR ON OUR
KIDS- AND WITH THAT- WE ARE
GOING TO COMMENCE THIS HEARING
AND- WE WILL BE. HELLO SIR WE
WILL WILL WILL. DEFINITELY
DON'T COMMIT WE COMMENCED WE
WILL. WELL IN THIS HEARING AND-
REALLY DO APPRECIATE ALL THE
PARTICIPATION OF EVERYONE WITH
THAT. IS IT YOUR.